what up guys Welcome to the
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel welcome Amiri to
the Channel Good Boy The Fresh Prince of
someone
you know I heard you got I heard you got
fired that's what they said yeah the
fake news media right the fake news I'm
fired yeah a lot of fired fired by
all the oh that's what all the fake news
media reaction Outlets are reporting
now we have beef now apparently right
now that's why I broke my military
uniform for you
now guys now guys all right so
so
today
I need to get a Mary monetized
all right so if you want us to react to
Abba and preach
I need you guys to go subscribe to
amiri's channel we'll sit here all night
yeah well you got time yeah I got time
yeah I got time today I got time today
but what I want to talk about is how
certain reaction channels I won't name
names
right right we won't we won't name names
but they don't care about the truth nope
they don't care about what's right and
what's wrong they have their certain
lens and how they see the world they
have their certain ideology
and
they got no point they just like to
argue yep what do you what do you think
they're fake news Bob do I look cute in
this
um you know you're uh you're you're
looking swell swell looking good for
some smoke yeah
let me
all right so make sure you guys go
subscribe we're gonna I'm gonna pull
this up on my phone blessing it'd be
nice if one of these days we could get
like the chat on the screen
oh really yeah
yeah
oh wait oh I see I see we can
where first time oh yeah
oh wow
we're so good at YouTube all right guys
listen do you mind if I can't drink
though
anyone can you throw these away
yeah man can we do a wall or could you
can I get a water too
what's the Pearly team saying man yeah
so
w w
140 viewers guys make sure you go
subscribe to amiri's channel our our new
Talent right are the
you know we're very selective in who we
pick for these
amazing contracts
reported by fake news networks with no
evidence or proof
but we're very selective who we who we
pick and Amiri has been one of our stars
on the show for months now of course he
was on one of our most viewed episode
and we always want to give back to the
people that help us out you know he's
he's been he's also one of our top
recruiters
and you know and he's he's a big
supporter of the network so we want to
get him to a thousand subscribers and
then we'll we'll react to all of the
fake news
all of the fake news that has been going
on
around here tell see look at more fake
news they say you have a gun to your
head
yeah you see this fake news
wake up and smoke a coffee Bob
delusion
modern women bro who told who told their
fans to come in at me
all right we got 270 people in here now
guys remember we're not going to start
until
Amiri gets to a thousand subscribers
now I know this might be Petty but he's
at 197 subscribers so the ad is in the
description the ads in the title
um The Fresh Prince of zumanda
I don't even know what that means but we
give we give our talents creative
freedom here you know right do I not
[Music]
[Laughter]
see that subscription's going to me too
much to my channel
let's not get carried away
rat he's got 198 subscribers
all night to address all of the fake
news propaganda yeah
it must be done it must be done
um
listen I'm not saying to necessarily
Force like putting in a headlock to
subscribe I am putting them in a
headlock to subscribe you know what I
mean like we can we can just end the
stream and just you know just just chill
here yeah so okay the piano we will yeah
yeah we we make music here do we not we
we will do stairs we'll run their boxing
today
there's a lot of stuff we could do
you need to get you need to get them on
the on the screen man what do you mean
you used to get your um
your chat on the screen my chat or
something Oh you mean like so they can
see it there you can see it yeah I don't
know how to do it do you know how to do
it yeah
yeah because giving them full full
access to the chat mate this is 212.
this is 212 for his channel guys we'll
be here all day now why did I invite
Amiri to this right I could have just
addressed the fake news by myself of
course but Amiri was brought into this
by reaction channels that are just
trying to spin a narrative
that believe what they believe
regardless of the facts the same
reaction channels that would paint Kevin
Samuels in a negative light by watching
clips and not watching
the full show and spinning a narrative
without knowing what they're talking
about
I'm gonna blow a fuse at a thousand
subscribers man let's get it but you
know we don't work for free here
we need to get a Miri to a thousand
subscribers beautiful it's going up
thank you guys what do we have they want
to see some spice now the app for me
Prince of zamanda Zamunda I think she
says
what's it from I don't know Coming to
America it's uh what's what's that is
that a movie
thank you Gail Gail is everywhere I know
man
she's active and enjoying girl actually
banned me from eating on my stream see
Bandy from eating yeah you can eat an
ice cream I know I know that's what I'm
saying like yeah yeah so
yeah you know here at jpt
we don't work for free which is why we
need to get a Miri monetized we need to
get him monetized yesterday
so you know once he's monetized we will
answer all questions yep I really think
that's a fair thing we can answer all
questions
and talk about fake news media
fake news media guys can you imagine
making a whole hit piece having never
watched a full episode can you imagine
making a hit piece admitting admitting
that you did not watch the full
episode do you know what you know
against a friend can you imagine you
know fair use here is like if you're
doing like a news report so as a as a
reporter you're supposed to like get all
your facts and all your informations in
order before you even consider turning
on the camera and look at we know
mistakes happen of course we expect
mistakes to happen but when it's not
corrected
when there's no effort to be biased when
there's no effort to tell the facts of
the case tell the real story that's when
we have a problem here at jpt and we
have been taking notes
hey I'm watching I'm watching you I'm
watching the chat guys you know I'm
watching the chat guys bro I love my jpt
chat guys man now guys again we're at
228 for Amiri
228 do you know how many watch hours you
need to be monetized I actually don't
get four thousand four thousand all
right we'll work on that later we're
gonna get the a thousand Subs first I'll
get that quick yeah yeah we just need to
get you your base now guys why subscribe
to Amiri well I don't know anybody
I don't know anybody
as creative and entertaining
as him no seriously this man has gone
viral before he even had a channel he's
been on many of the most watched
podcasts and tell him what you would
like to talk about on your channel tell
them what you he has a finance podcast
coming soon yeah tell tell them tell
them about what what type of content so
listen so basically my podcast is going
to be based on like Finance
for the Layman's
you know for the guys that don't know
you know we're gonna get some money in
your pocket so we're gonna aim to keep
it in there I'm gonna get some of the
best finances the best
mergers and aqua just Acquisitions we're
gonna get the best
um day Traders already we already got
them lined up you know how we work you
know we work how we work how we work how
we work yeah
so that's that man now if you want to
get your stocks up check me out if you
want to see me blow a few check me out
now
there's a lot of
questions in the chat we do reaction
channels so how are we different than
the fake news media that's a fair
question right yeah
I think um
I'm so unbiased to my own detriment
that's what I think
well
it's all about going into things in good
faith
about looking for the facts of a case
and not just spinning a narrative
these guys know man you know for example
I would hate to say
that a certain someone has no life
experience when I've just been sitting
in my room reacting to [__] for 10 years
shots fired now I don't name names here
she was fired man you know
dog man
I would hate to say that you shouldn't
always attack the argument and never the
person
and then call someone a [__] a dweeb
and a weirdo isn't that quite rude yep
now is that someone that's objective
that's looking at the facts of the case
you're giving them too much
um you're right I'm sorry guys I'm
giving them too much
subscribe to amiri's channel and we
and this fake news media
fake news
well what are we at let's let's look
what you're at now guys when we get him
to a thousand subscribers
we will go in now
[Music]
I know this is a lot
I know maybe you're thinking
I don't wanna I'm here but against my
will
and to answer your question yes you are
why yes
well I am but like yeah willingly yeah
oh I was talking about the chat were you
talking about yourself oh my bad now
you're you're free to go you're free to
go you don't want to be here yeah okay
you're yeah yeah let's go let's get
let's get those guys no but they'll clip
it they'll clip it and be like he's
scared oh yeah yeah yeah they clip ya
they sit and look for a 30 second Buzz
clip
listen
we almost got half a thousand in the
chat
start playing around go to my channel
And subscribe
we're gonna go you know I'm saying we're
gonna get some spice going we're gonna
be reacting
to the big hit
we're gonna be reacting we stayed silent
here
about a lot of accusations crazy
a lot of negativity we didn't say a word
I had a few to say about a couple guys
but I'll be saying a lot more
oh yes I told you that on my channel is
coming bro it's coming from so playing
with me bro I make you wait for this bro
I'm gonna disrespect my friends
yeah and guys The Fresh Prince of
zumbunda I'm just kidding he's got my
back all right
bro if I get a thousand subscribers I'm
Gonna Make Her Say it correctly bro
zamanda and then she's gonna do the
whole intro everything
2 40. yeah
so it's supposed to be no we'll be here
all day do you know what bundes is
no
the bundesligas
I don't know what that means
are you gonna tell me
listen at 300 I told her what this means
oh okay
going to teach about the wilderness
so it's a Monday samanda
well I was speaking British soon bro
it's Amanda
he's like can you subscribe to me with
the fresh prince of Manda
now I'll tell you something about Amiri
he is the hardest working
this man how many reaction videos did
you do in your first like two three days
you did like 30 something yeah he's got
he's got content loaded yep we're
working on our backlog right now we got
to go through it I've got a dating show
coming up as well and he's gonna have
the most viral Moment In Our dating show
yeah should we give our thoughts on this
dating show hell to the no it ain't
still they've not yet no that's what I
was gonna say not yet okay not yet we
don't work for free guys
now I could ask you for Super Chat a
grifter might ask you for super chats
but
me all I want is subscribers for the man
the myth the legend the fresh prince of
zamanda yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um Amiri keeps slapping that subscribe
and I'm seeing it going up bro so I love
you guys
yeah you were on that show no there's
well there's more than one girl that has
threatened to sue me oh Lord there's one
oh
should I give the backstory oh wait was
she not yeah I don't want to give him
too much but I'll tell them I'll tell
them
wait was I on that showpo
you were one of the lawsuits I was
threatened well actually no this girl
then threatened to sue me she threatened
to come beat me up okay okay because you
were on the show okay and you said
what's you guys's body count and most of
the room was Silas
except for this girl
um and
what happened
you got those reality
well apparently some she she said it was
five right what that's what she said on
the show but I guess in India that's
like Haram oh like in the West in the
west they would be like oh thank you
Jesus that's not so bad but in India
in India that's Haram so she threatened
the India Mafia to come and get me
people don't know what I've been through
behind the scenes to be honest
yeah and I was like well I hope they
don't but that's an Indian Mafia you
know
the Indian Mafia
they're scary though
well I hope they don't come here coming
in yeah it's been long enough I don't
think they're coming but I was a bit
worried for a minute
I know them man
of some serious guys bro
what is this pole they probably designed
to her
have you liked oh [__] what did I do
oh here you go you're at 260. now we got
400 people in the chat there's no reason
why we shouldn't have 400 subscribers of
course there is these men are just
standing there watching bro go to my
channel click to subscribe and come the
hell back and stop playing with me
tell them
at 1K Amiri get Pearl to watch come into
America no at one at 1K I'm getting
power to watch American Gangstar City of
God
shutters yeah within the whole full
Works bro but in a way though sorry the
point of my story in a way you kind of
made the mafia come after me because you
asked her the body count question yeah
but she didn't have to answer them I
know nobody else answers so the Indian
Mafia probably came off the house yeah
well I think so I think that's what
happened
people don't know what I've been through
behind the scenes to be honest I've been
robbed I've been I've been extorted
ain't nothing happened to me but these
guys chat crap about my name
and that um I'm gonna destroy them
literally I'm gonna destroy them
I'm gonna destroy the two backup dancers
I'm gonna destroy the Uncle Ruckus
looking guy and destroy all of them you
know listen but we won't destroy anybody
until
we don't work for free
so let's see what you're at you're at
beautiful 268 subscribers guys go
subscribe to his channel the ad is in
the description
we will not be watching it we will not
be talking about anything
until you subscribe to his channel
and get them to a thousand Subs I know
this is a big goal you might think this
is unfair but a subscription is free
listen a hundred thousand I'm gonna have
them I'm gonna have po Puff the Magic
Dragon
I don't know what that means
you know like I'm old school when they
used to like make bubble balls of
dragons or not foreign
remember 100 000 subscribers
I don't think I'm gonna do that
I feel like this is uh something else
I'm playing I'm playing come on guys
let's go for what lovely what do you
guys want to know what behind the scenes
stuff do you guys want to know
listen I know I I don't know how to hold
my mouth so
oh where'd the chat go
a live chat here we go
oh no something's itching
I'm allergic to life
yeah look at 24 it won't be here we'll
be here all night
we'll be here
wait have they even liked your video
let alone this video I mean um subscribe
to my channel yeah it's only 195 likes
oh you know disrespectful this is so
disrespectful this is so rude this is so
rude I'll sub once I see the clips
what but it's not this that is not how
it works
well we need bro listen
I'm gonna watch watch when you are
locked onto mine and you can't take your
eyes off my channel I'm gonna do some
Kevin Samuel stunts bro trust me gonna
be liking my stuff he's very talented um
out of all the we had maybe we've had
two dating shows and I have to say Amiri
had the best dating show it was so funny
it was so funny it was the funniest [__]
I have ever seen in my life remember
people be yourself at all times man
um we're here being ourselves you be
yourself man
I should have so many things I want to
say don't tell them no trust me they
have the power right now to do it Omar
said keep calling me stoned because of
my allergies guys I don't like we
EDS
so
anti-cannabis you don't even know
anti-weed some people imagine there's a
visible line here and that is like
Ukraine Russia border me yup that's me
I'm on the Ukraine you know
okay you're on the loose inside right
now I know you know they look like they
lose them
I'd like to say one thing here at jpt we
don't negotiate with what we don't
negotiate with tourists we don't
negotiate with terrorists we don't
also guys make sure look at Gail in the
chat
we have we're gonna do meetups in the US
and the UK
so make sure you go subscribe to our
Google form go follow it it's going to
be a lot of fun let's go let's keep
let's keep typing the level I love what
you are doing I'm watching the numbers
right now
4 41. yep listen I don't want no fake
followers as well you know if you're not
just gonna come and be ghost followers
you might as well understand
no that's fine that's fine we don't need
no ghosts followers over here oh wait
yeah we gotta eat you
okay okay
listen you're 91. so I'm saying this I
mean work I'm on this channel in the
front of the camera for two weeks Paul
two weeks
yeah and I'm doing this part time so
when I'm full time on these guys
I'm gonna start
dodging these guys there
look at what the fake news did to Tate
oh the fake news put Andrew Tate in jail
and it's the clips channels in the
reaction channels
it's not no the no the fake no no no no
the fake news didn't put Tate in jail
they needed to be in jail post so
that when even if he's innocent or not
they could also they could always say
when they're
bringing them forth to the world Andrew
take the
um
he's dead he was in trial for dead and
then accused of then and when they're
introducing him so they could discredit
him basically that's what they've done
so it doesn't matter if they if if he
was guilty or not they could also they
could also now say
what'd you get but I'm saying the fake
news media painted a narrative that's
what I mean and that's what these
reaction channels do they did it to
Kevin Samuels they did it to Andrew Tate
and now they're coming for me because
they don't care about what's true
they're vultures and all they want to do
is make money off of drama they don't
believe in anything they don't stand for
anything and they are the TMZ of YouTube
they are the TMZ of YouTube
entertainment purposes
and you know take we were like a whole
sea of Soul fake journalism fake news
and if you guys want us to give our
thoughts
on a lot of these reaction channels
go subscribe to we'll be here all night
until we get 10 to a thousand
subscribers
295. remember guys
yesterday someone came up to me and was
like oh you all right I was like yeah
some random person I was like yeah he's
like yeah man I had poor fired you I was
like is it I had to pick up my phone
like did I miss a text
did I forget a text did the text not get
through to me the fake news media it's
the fake News why would you report that
somebody is fired with no evidence why
would you report that someone recruited
someone and they've started a case on
you without evidence why would you say
why would you say that without did any
of them reach out to you for a comment
no no did any of them did they reach out
to any of us asking for your Instagram
none no I received nothing none they
know who I am nothing none they could
get hold of me
they know who I am and all of the people
that were so concerned during all of
this drama nobody reached out to my
staff the people affected
nobody reached out
well if they reached out then they
wouldn't be making all the money they're
making right now I'm not making videos
on you
but you know hate always comes from
Below
yeah hate always comes from below and
I'm really glad that we got to test this
because we got to see who bends to the
will of the mob
who throws their friends under the bus
for clout
who's a strong man and who's a weak man
what do people do in crisis
and I got to see firsthand that Amiri
here stands on what he believes no
matter what he doesn't let he doesn't
bow to the will of the mob
and he he doesn't let people control him
and I found out that two people that
called me a dancer or actual dancers
huh hmm
two people who called you a dancer who
get to it we'll get to it we get to it
and we can't wait to go into this we
cannot wait but we don't work for free
guys we really don't and there's 464 of
you in here live
and
oh that's something we need you guys to
go subscribe to The Fresh Prince of
zamundus Channel
the at is in the description the ad is
in the live and we're going to take all
your questions
we're gonna give the the truth
which nobody cares about nowadays
you know what I'm gonna type in the chat
we'll type it in the chat
he's almost a 300 subscribers now we
need to get to a thousand I know you
guys think that's a lot
and I I get that
but
we don't work for free no
foreign
use your brain man you've been on
computers your whole life man if the
link is not going you're getting me find
a way to go well it's that in the in the
description if they click the tag if the
fake news media
oh that's a rude one
news media is the TMZ of YouTube then
this is the Jerry Springer of YouTube
it's trash with trash guests sure but
it's damn honest and entertaining when
well when all the guests are all the
trash guests are on anyway this is the
other fake news media that we are the
same as Jerry Springer if we are the
same as Jerry Springer then why in a
year of shows have we had four kick outs
with over 200 and something shows across
the network
hmm
is it that doesn't seem like a lot with
hundreds of women in and out of here the
majority of our shows are tame how much
does he pay for that the majority twenty
dollars listen use another twenty
dollars and explain to us how is it like
generation yeah have you ever and that's
my question any of you Jerry Springer
was one of the best sit-down talk shows
so he could mean like that or it could
mean that you know maybe yeah maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm reaching right
yeah but let me know is this
the Jerry Springer of YouTube oh
explain I'm not just gonna down your
your suggestion you spend twenty dollars
instead of going to my my channel and
liking that about trash he's shocked
it's only for a while
you would be you would be shocked you
know another thing that the fake news
media is reporting that I think it's
okay to cheat
another it's a fake news I never said it
was okay to cheat but yet the fake news
we don't say something you may later
which relied on court what do you mean
they think I said it's okay to cheat I
never said it's okay allegedly oh well
done guys 320 keep it going yeah 320
we're not we're not remember
we will not be going and talking about
these issues
until Amiri gets to a thousand
subscribers
he's currently at 322 his at is in the
title
let's do it man let's do it
let's do it all you got to do is click
the at and hit that subscribe button
you're killing us Pearl well you're
killing us by not hitting that bro
there's 485 yeah yeah go to my channel
click them subscribe come back and we go
and get into the madness don't piss me
off bro because I'm already pissed off
with these fake Brads bro don't piss me
off bro go to my channel And subscribe
you know does Jerry Springer help people
find love on a dating show
nah does Jerry Springer help people come
together and find love from the show man
rip Jerry Springer man yeah
like that's gonna happen with 400 views
we got all night
would you mean like that's gonna happen
before there is already subscribers on
my channel when you subscribe it adds to
the amount of subscribers on the channel
when you like this video it lets a a
million point four people know that
we're live that's how YouTube works
like the video
I'm gonna get into this madting
Paul doesn't even know they were backup
dancers how how have you look how have
you allowed her to to go through the
world without knowing about other people
that are talking about her with their
contradictory self how
that's that's that's that's a lot of
your question
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait
man I could just tell you that love when
I Wildlife myself you know you see the
hump of of content come on
foreign
just here being a feminine woman
but I'm here against my willpower you
are my boss
um you are my slave owner
you're my Colonial oh yeah yeah
they're gonna clip that and say see
here's the proof because that's what
they do they don't care about what's
true and what's false they don't care
about what the truth is Imagine
no I'm
gonna I'm gonna wait I've had so much to
say
so much to say and I've just let
everybody make money off of me
let's see we're at
358. again guys if you want us to speak
about the reaction channels and the fake
news media
the fake news reaction channels
subscribe to not even my channel I don't
care if you subscribe to my channel
subscribe I don't care if you super chat
but we do appreciate it you know what I
mean I don't but it's not my goal right
now my goal is to get Amiri to a
thousand subscribers I don't know
anybody more deserving than a Miri of
hitting that a thousand subscriber mark
so
go subscribe his his at is in the title
you just gotta click it and hit the
Subscribe button
listen if you like to subscribe and I
reached to 2 000 subscribers I'm gonna
bring like five only girl fans in here
for entertainment and educational
purposes only though you know yeah and
you guys you guys he's open to
suggestion too
we go and have them up in here
you could turn into my room into my room
[Music]
she's gonna have them up in here that's
2 000 though
a lot of the fake news media
has been stunting on our names
the haters man haters I think you know
that I was told to tag a certain content
creator
all right let me should we tag I'm gonna
I'm gonna show you the content creator
but this content creator isn't really
relevant
so should we tag this content creator
that's what I was told to
counted enough yeah you know
[Music]
I don't know
he gonna find out anyway
he gonna find out by the end of the day
he gonna know
one of you not gonna tell him
452 viewers in here
guys like the video that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams all right and if
we want to get to our goal of a thousand
subscribers for Amiri
then we're gonna need some likes to push
out the stream if you're if you're not
going to subscribe to his Channel at
least
like the video
Tori really wants us to tag him
but he's not
relevant
no allow that guy as well man what
I love that guy
he going here as well he gonna learn
today
fake news media who do you think is is
Imagine creating no original content for
10 years
that would be crazy just reactions I
understand sometimes you got to start
with that
but if you're spending 10 years doing
the same thing becoming bitter sitting
in your room reacting reacting reacting
maybe once a year going out and doing
something original maybe twice a year
you're just the TMZ of YouTube you are
the fake news media you don't go into
arguments in good faith no
no you don't
what okay Gail at night thank you you
know
bro
allow it please
I'm going to talk about the panhandler
soon okay just get me to a thousand I
want to talk about the Panhandle Clint
says I'll be back when there's more
delusional folks getting school that's
all right Clint not everybody wants to
hear about the fake news media
not everybody wants to hear about it but
for the people that do
make sure you go subscribe I don't even
need you to subscribe to me subscribe to
The Fresh Prince of Zamunda did I say it
right
did I say it right Zamunda
I think I did
when when you say when you say someone
oh yeah what what do you think of when
you say it Zamunda yeah that's what I
think of but how do you what do you use
to remember it it's Amanda
remember I told you just remember Bunda
it's a wonder
what
yes guys 25. oh it's crazy a lot of
these people calling me dumb
or actually 21 more and then I'll tell
Paul what wouldn't this mean
okay
a lot of these people that call me dumb
call me an idiot haven't accomplished
what I've accomplished in a year
there's many women that are equally as
attractive as me if not prettier doing
the same thing I'm doing
and they act like I have no credibility
or don't know anything I'm talking about
because they're jealous that they can't
do what I do
but I win in life right
I don't think it's jealousy I think it's
fair
um
they fail you man
oh it's fear yeah
it's fair man
that's what it is I don't know why
you're afraid of a 20-something year old
chick
without the help of them because they
try to make people unsubscribe to your
Channel
they tried but they can't succeed we're
actually still growing growing growing
better than ever
thanks to Eula of course thanks to you
lots thank you
like you should feel disrespected
because when they say we don't like you
know I'm saying we just chat crap all
day and you know listen you know sitting
down listening to three hour podcasts
sitting down talking to these These
Girls and these guys here every day yeah
because if Pearl's not working then the
the jpt still works
we have more than one Studio we're still
working
I don't think because Pearl takes off
live that she stops working no continues
work it
no they actually no pearl how much
people have come up into the studio and
said I didn't know this how much it
takes for a successful podcast to be
nobody nobody knows all we do here
that's the crazy thing
crazy thing the same people that
criticize us constantly come in hand
could not do what we do they could not
and have not signed talents they could
not and have not gotten 40 000
subscribers in three months they
couldn't and have not done it and many
have had the opportunity to do it and
still did not do it
a lot of them will credit My Success to
imaginary
management imaginary
people paying for my stuff but when the
actuality is
there's thinkers and there's doers and
there's people that think about ideas
for years and don't do them there's
people that talk about ideas for years
and don't do them and there's people
that make dreams happen there's people
that work for it do you know who works
for it you no you you you as well you
look it look it because
he said he wanted he was recruiting he
said he wanted to be a talent
and he came in and did 30 reaction
videos in two days
that's somebody that wants it
but a lot of this wait wait no don't
blame don't don't thank me for it thank
the panhandling Uncle Uncle Ruckus
looking guy that we're going to speak
about when I reached a thousand
I don't need to tag no one he knows
he we're at 384 guys again we're gonna
speak about everything that's going on
we're almost halfway there we're almost
halfway there but
we cannot speak on anything until we get
paid Rome was not me
uh we I'm not even doing this for myself
I want Amiri to be successful I want him
okay okay let's let's I'm already
successful
we're trying to get them to sub to you
right now we talked about this
yo guys man you listen when you see my
channel and you're gonna see what I'm on
You're Gonna Know to subscribe don't
just watch my videos watch my lives as
well see how I break down stuff like
come on man 385
lovely we'll be here all day we got we
got the time do you have the time do you
have to don't you have to pay for the
um Studio
oh yeah
I own it
yup we're here back
and we do everything here what'd you do
when you got here today
uh chilled on the couch ate some popcorn
no no no what'd you do when you got here
today
oh yeah yeah we did that obviously yeah
yeah they know we work but I thought you
meant like all the other things apart
from work Pearl like the exciting part
apart from work because this is what we
just do anyway you know wow this is what
we had a boxing match with King
Richard's today we run we run up 21
flights of stairs
obviously I
I'm not telling you you're gonna have to
watch his video to see
what happens on that
you know
in fact he's live right now
who's live
in the richest lab right now oh yeah
yeah
if you're bored here go to King Rich's
he's you know we support all our talents
here
we support all of our talents here
I would say why would they think of why
I gotta do they gotta subscribe to my
channel
stop playing Ralph I wish we could put
it on the screen
do you know what you're not gonna start
doing I'm gonna I promise you I'm gonna
do 388 listen I'm gonna I'm gonna wow
I'm gonna turn off the light and put on
some opera music bro if you don't act
fast breath it's not playing RAV
cheese
listen if you want if you want to ask us
something of unrelated to all them super
guys yeah you know you know the flower
power guys then just send us a Super
Chat and I'll answer your questions
because right now I'm just seeing a blur
of whatever man
foreign
not sure what this chant this channel is
about just that you guys have the time
you do everything can you order nuggets
okay we can get something to order this
I mean if you five five bucks won't
cover the delivery for the Nuggets you
know I mean bucks
we're gonna need more for the Nuggets
I'm not a big do you like nuggets I'm
not a big nugget not really but that's
going to the delivery guy you know at
least delivery guys taking five pound
all the stairs he has to climb to get
here um
do you know what I will do though at 10
000 subscribers I'll do the one chip
challenge what is that don't worry I'll
make you do it as well
ten thousand subscribers I make her do
the one chip challenge I don't know what
the one chip challenges so I may not be
agreeing to this okay I mean just we're
almost to 400 we need seven more to get
them to 400. that's almost double in
this stream you can't tell me that this
is an impossible goal
okay come on bro you know I got the time
you know what we're doing
listen I know some streams yet that they
they literally leave you with a picture
for like 50 minutes
they let you wait we're actually talking
to you while you're waiting because this
is not actually the start the start is
when you look do and not watch and see
and talk you've got time to type go to
my channel And subscribe and then come
back and type
foreign
the lady on this book today
or not today last week
I interviewed the author
tell them what the name of the book is
occult feminism the secret history of
women's liberation
[Music]
I'll read you this book you know
listen that's not 55.
for me to sit down around 55 subscribers
listen bro four thousand subscribers I'm
gonna make Po I'm gonna teach you how to
cook oxtail Bravo you dumb brat
come on half a million I'm taking pills
to Trinidad brochure in a carnival why
do you think these reaction channels are
so much we're not going to talk about
our situation but let's just talk in
general why do these reaction channels
have so much fake news media
why don't they care about the truth it
makes money
why why have they profited off of you me
and the rest of the people that work
here why all while also pretending to
care about them
charlatanswav
I don't know what a charlatan is bro
these guys listen they they're here to
save they had to save you
but at the same time like a church
pastor they're charlatans they come to
save you but they want your money in
order to save you they you know they
need you to be in a frame of mind
think in a certain way in order for
their dead hustle to continue
because otherwise they'll never bro if
if if if they realize that
why and black we could chill in the same
room and there's no war there's no red
or blue or no bull crap yeah then they
can't make videos about black power no
more about all of this crap bro
no one's watching them bro
you have to talk about us in order for
meant to watch you
and the majority of these content
creators have no original content they
just want to react that's exactly they
just react and according to fair use
they can't use our full contents that's
why they can't watch the whole content
code that's the real reason why well and
the other and the other issue too
there's a difference between reacting in
good faith and reacting to spin a
narrative and it's very obvious that a
lot of these reaction channels just
react to spin a narrative they don't
care about the truth they are the TMZ of
YouTube
they are the TMZ of YouTube do you trust
TMZ as a credible Source that's what
these reaction channels are do you know
some of them right now are like they're
sitting waiting on the screen
they are they're sitting they're so
excited because now this is going to
make them their money for the month so
they're just looking for a clip they can
pull they're just looking for
a sound bite they can take
to spin a narrative
now let's let's read these is this
enough for nuggets now no it's not
enough
I'm with you Amiri but now get her to do
the one chip challenge now that is goal
worth reaching for if not that use this
as a delivery fee for not why do they
want us to eat nuggets so bad bro
if you know what's inside of this head
you would know that this Channel and
this channel is going to go to Mega I'm
gonna make a do the one trip challenge
bro he's he's at 4 10.
690 more subscribers to go I'm gonna
make it do the one to One Challenge Sam
and I will stop at nothing to get these
nuggets ordered
well YouTube takes like 40 of the super
chats or 30 so you know
we're getting close but we're on a
budget here because we've had slanderous
claims made about our reputation
bro I don't even I don't even think you
could go on deliveroo and Oxford plastic
bag of McDonald's and it's not gonna
even be enough for what you've paid
he'll pay the dollars where in England
notice pounds bro
um
the conversion rate isn't good here bro
it's converted then YouTube takes this
car and then
you know I've got to take my little car
and then Paul takes her cup you know
I'll talk about something that happened
to me today online
can you imagine having such a crazy
world view that you can't even imagine
that the justice system discriminates
against men
oh yeah can you imagine arguing against
that no
when you know damn well it is but that's
the thing they don't go into
conversations in good faith imagine
speaking to a 20-year divorce attorney
who tells you that the justice system
discriminates against men
and thinking you know better
imagine that's crazy that is the fake
news media I wonder how many
um
lawyers they've spoken to
none
oh maybe the lead attorney they've
spoken well no that's that this reaction
channel did in fact speak to the lead
attorney but he doesn't believe it okay
doesn't believe it and that's the thing
they don't care about the truth they
don't care about what's right
all they want is to push a narrative
hmm
I hear you boss man
listen you got money to spend Fam I'm
not trying to get your money bro I'm
trying to get your subscribers brought
417 Brooke beautiful adding to the
nuggets
4 17.
um
and you know I'm gonna make you do as
well I'm gonna make you punch that you
know I'm punching machine things
you're not just punching machines oh
I've used one what's your score I don't
remember it's in the summer brah and
we're gonna do it like if she gets
really 100 she gets below 200 we're
gonna make her do something below 300
gonna make it do something below 400
gonna make it do so our middle 500 gonna
make a do something and it's suggested
by you guys
best way to get revenge on the fake
media order nuggets
I'm gonna eat you on stream but Doug and
that's gonna get pissed off of me should
we react to something else
while we're waiting yeah something
unrelated again guys
we will talk
oh it seems like
seems like Destiny was saying TLA could
not be right because he does not believe
black men well that's a narrative that
the fake news media would spin that's
how they would spin it bro who even give
Destiny all these flowers bro like what
has he done like who is he spoken to and
where did he go school like bro come on
bro come on Rob like people give this
guy like oh what have you what do you
know Pearl what do you know where have
you gone today what have you done which
friends of YouTube which relationships
why is no one asking these guys the same
question
where has Destiny got his information
like where did Albert where did come on
bro stop playing with me bro
do they know I'm getting a degree in
Psychology I don't know nothing they
don't know nothing
do they know
who and if I'm dating
listen at
listen at 3 000 subscribers I'm gonna
tell you who that opel's day in love
no he will not
no he will not do they know what my life
experience is
nah
nah anyways no all right that's
obviously your your family came for
money right so you you were born into it
so you don't know what hard work is even
though yeah that's how you became
wealthy in the first place all right
let's let's see what we want to react to
it should be an example for you you you
little dweebs bro
that's possible to come from zero to
nothing
no you know my big management just paid
for it
my big
yeah they just but they could go to the
start of your videos and see how you
started man like they could they could
but they will not
no oh let's react to Candace Owens no
sir oh Lord we've heard
no no I was gonna say she says I already
watched the one with Crowder so I want
to do okay wait
all right does Christianity support
abuse
we'll we'll react to this first guys if
you're tuning in
know that we will react to some of the
allegations that have been made against
the jpt network however we will not do
it until Amiri hits a thousand
subscribers his at is in the description
it's the fresh prince of someone the
baby yes yes click it subscribe
we got all night we got the time so
first and foremost I am not looking to
rehash this this could be a 24-hour
stream don't play with me we'll be here
until don't play with me bro Pearl do
you recommend men becoming a high level
before
resuming women I'm tired of wasting my
time on women that but all but all their
value that put all their value into
looks what I think I think you should
build yourself up as a guy before you
pursue women but I don't I don't think
you need to like do like you can do it
at the same time you see oh are we
allowed to disagreepo yeah we can yeah
you sure no I you know there's there's
no um there's nothing where I tell you
are we allowed to disagree you're
allowed to disagree with me what do you
I don't have a strong opinion on it do
you think men should build themselves up
first
hell to the no I think as soon as their
balls drop they should be locked down
trying to find a woman that's trying to
get them locked down
I think it should be locked down as
quickly as possible
I think I think it makes more sense for
guys to wait till their 30s
we have a different leverage opinion
unless unless you're marrying a girl
that's like like high school sweethearts
I feel like there's two ways to do it
you could do like the high school
sweethearts thing or you could wait till
your 30s and marry younger okay so are
you is this just for the men but men
yeah
listen I think you should be giving your
wife the best years of your life
and she should be giving University as
of her life
yeah I think that's idealistic
but how many women are doing that now
blessing um they're saying that the
audio is bad I need you to back in here
Come On Blessing I need you back it's
getting a little hot I might crack a
window I'm sorry trip check
come on drip check I might crack a
window a little bit come on check post
drip check
yo blessed
Helen
I don't think Helen knows how to fix it
[Music]
um
wait what's wrong with it
is it too low is it too loud
I think it's too high I don't think let
him Super Chat and tell us
um
the video was to let me what if we oh
um ah that's okay
the video is too low
um
I don't know how to fix that
go on WOW
press place if that's better all right
situation I think I've made my position
no I think it's the yeah yeah try making
a little lower abundantly clear I hope
that I have made my position
let me call to our producer man
foreign
how many subscribers are we at
all right fresh prince of Zamunda
all right guys while he's gone while
he's gone
subscribe and get it to 500. I think
it'd be so cool if before he came back
he hit 500 I could be like look you're
almost there so hit it hit it quick
quick quick quick quick quick quick
quick
it's in the uh add in the description
add in the description
okay
all right wait hold up
yeah he's on his way he put it in the
chat
okay damn it someone unsubscribed
that's good that means they they saw
they watched my video
[Music]
yeah man
maybe we should maybe tease him a little
bit with the beginning
should we tease him a little bit
with the beginning of the Abilene preach
holder Mis tease them a little bit a
little bit but wait we the audio is not
working
tease them just a little bit you know
no jumper yeah
just tell me something
yeah do you think
do you think
that wait hold on hold on do you think
yeah oh bloody hell maybe audio oh no no
forget the audio
we're just watching for now
yeah do you think Pearl
do you think that is a suitable shirt to
be wearing
[Music]
yo hey that button is saying freebie
hey
yo bro that shirt is too tight
foreign
a lot of Mercy all right let's see how
many Subs you're at
blessings again bro you know you're not
allowed right was it that NASCAR song
all right wait guys guys guys we're
almost to 450 for a Miri come on can you
tell them to subscribe top producer
subscribe to the channel in it
guys subscribe to amiri's channel get it
get it to a thousand subscribers there's
over 500 people in the chat it's like
there's no excuse
me no they want us to stay on stream
longer man they're playing
which is all right you know I know we're
likable yeah but got bigger titties than
Pro that's rude
dude was that a Super Chat no it was
just in the comments rude rude I have
huge knockers
yo when putting on the line has that
effect for somebody
you won't be able to see it firsthand so
you don't think it's happening but the
same way Kobe Bryant did that video and
it hadn't affected me the same way
Patrice O'Neill was doing videos and it
kind of shaped my psyche they're never
your suit a dancer and you're super
successful it's like you and 10 other
people are behind cardi B and nobody
ever knows your name exactly if you want
to say that again if you want to know
whether or not a art form is like
profitable
what what he's a backup dancer
he called me a backup dancer
he's actually a backup dancer yeah
bro listen do you want to sit in exactly
bro if you want to yeah if you want to
know whether or not an art form is check
his government just look at the top paid
people and compare them to the other
disciplines and you'll know very fast
you know you think about the best dancer
in the world and you've probably never
heard of them right and you've and their
salary is not that great but compared to
the top singers or the top uh music
producers or the top painters you know
so it's just it's one of those things
that I feel so bad because I think it's
such a dope form of art but
unfortunately Hey listen fair use
fair use do you think that shirt isn't
the right shirt do you think it's a good
color
I played the fifth
terms like making bread people sometimes
invest their whole lives see I've got
time for you like she ain't got time I
got time I got I got time today I got
time today
afterwards
How Are You Gonna Keep dancing in your
late 40s and 50s for a living it's not
something you can sustain but knowing
everything that you know about five come
on come on you said it yourself social
media and YouTube now would that have
colored how you were viewing dancing
because I'm sure that there's people who
do different stuff that are making good
things and stuff right right guys
they're making like decent livings but
it's like it's true it's far few in
between
you can uh
you can tool and make a really good
living right not too many dancers can do
that at a medium-sized level and then
tour right the top end you can always
find a few but I don't look at the top
and just find out if an art form is
sustainable you gotta look at the people
in the middle and the people on the
bottom and can they eat at all and also
most dancers they make their money off
other dancers it's kind of like a
pyramid scheme in a way so basically a
backup dancer you were a backup up
dancer right that's not a sustainable
thing you think about musicians they got
fans they got people the public who just
[__] with their [__] if the only people
that you get money from are the people
who come to your classes or your
workshops or your battles and they're
all dancers she was battling as well
bro so wait so Abba was a dance song
at least at least preach was in the
dance song wait how does he how did he
move with all the blubber going on bro
no I'm serious like oh
I'm just asking the tough questions here
I'm just asking the tough question like
I would just
we're not trying to make him feel
discriminated you called him well before
you're just making money from the
you said a female that thinks she's a 10
but
sorry continue
community of ours so it's kind of it's
not a good way to make money we don't
want to just poorly things too
display things one get you money
um that Blue Tick soon don't worry
that's so true you're really making me
think about skateboarding BMX was like
very similar problems yeah so I was
saying
so we know ABBA is a dog a backup
all right that's bad
okay that is super bad but at least
preach I got faith for my brother preach
he is not on that crap as well he's not
a dancer
he's not assume yeah because if the
general public is not behind it how are
you going to get advertising dollars how
are you going to get people to pay
tickets to come to your event they don't
really [__] with BMX like that or if
they're not like interested in just
watching it do you see wins I mean no
they could never hold me a backup dancer
and bear back both backup passes if one
of them you know what I'm saying they're
one of them that's all right like two of
them that no I have faith and preach
that he's like me and he's not a backup
dancer MMA fighters are into it but
because the general public wants to see
people bash their heads and you need
those casuals to make something really
profitable long term very very true so
okay
gonna do they're gonna say oh look
they're reacting
so and that no that's what they do
they'll be like oh look they're reacting
and they'll be like look at they're so
emotional to you oh I thought you meant
like reaction in terms of no no because
we say this reaction channels are fake
news and they are yeah and they are and
so what
reacting to
to you yeah
fake news sorry continue
yeah make something really profitable
long term very very true so okay you
moved out here and tried to do the
dancing thing for a while you gave up at
some point uh it's not that I gave up
it's just like when you see what it's
like behind the scenes you're like I
don't want to do this for a living this
is not a
lot it's just too much you probably
don't get paid enough
I don't know what I don't know I wanted
I love doing this and I still do it to
this day but I don't want to make money
off of it sometimes you just have a
passion for yourself I'm sure you got
[__] that you so he started
he thoughts is in his bedroom
like no one sees it on the creaky floor
that's why they got creaky floor
yeah man preach could never be a dancer
make money off that you still do right
so that was that mindset so after that I
ended up picking up stand up and that
stuck once I did stand up I was I
started making YouTube videos on my own
this is about 2015 2016. so you're doing
stand up in LA or did you moved back
home I'd move back home yeah yeah I mean
they're moving to Montreal Canada to
start doing stand-up and then I never
stopped after that point really so you
thought you had a real knack for it
right away I just got on stage and I
bombed so hard my first time and I'm
like I [__] love this [__] really
yeah that was trash I remember growing
up I had this like terrible bit about
like uh oh it was one of the worst bits
I ever wrote and I still laugh about it
sometimes but I had this bit about like
um how my dad took me to a funeral and
it was like raining and he said you know
when it rains during the funeral it's
because Jesus is uh washing Away The
Sins Of The Dead and
I wrote this joke about like oh well if
you know if it's uh the tears of the
Dead that are being washed away by the
rain then when it's snowing it's Jesus
is just and then the crowd was just
quiet bro like I remember just hearing
like you know when you hear quietness
yeah and uh
preach
he's definitely not a loser he's not a
doctor like this guy I'm just putting
the disclaimer out there that preach is
not a dancer just this fat guy over here
is a dance song we're not disrespecting
both of them we're just sticking I'm
sticking to one
I'm just Abba because preach is not a
dancer no way could both of them call me
a backup dancer it's bad enough that
preach knows Abba was a backup dancer
and he allowed Abba to call me a backup
dancer even though
I was a backup dancer but preach I know
you I got faith in you my brother that
you are not a backup dancer
the one thing I remember during that set
was when I spoke even when I had a pause
people were listening and that's
sometimes even more in toxic Kingdom
when people laugh right it's like when I
speak even if it's not funny right now
you're fully paying attention to what
I'm saying because some Comics can't
even grab I am fully paying attention to
what he's saying okay I hope the whole
of GPT is fully paying attention to what
Abba has to say because we don't just no
we don't go by hand say we just go by
what you say
what he's not what Paul says it's not
what I say what he says this is just
until you subscribe to my channel we
just got a few little stuffs and stuff
so we've established that the backup
dancer called me a backup dancer and the
non-backup dancer allowed the backup
dancer to call a non-backup dancer a
backup dancer okay so that's where we're
at
that's where we're at like in this
YouTube space people's attention or be
interesting enough to like get people to
focus for long enough same thing with
YouTube but I can speak to these people
and they want to listen if I just get
the jokes and then I got this so I just
kind of kept going from there you ever
been in a room full of people and like
everybody's talking it's kind of like a
wild conversation and you try to launch
into a story and you get maybe like the
first sentence or two out and then like
everyone just stops paying attention to
your story and that sort of humiliating
feeling of like oh [__] like I'm used to
people paying attention to me I'm
apparently not like my at least the
beginning of that story did not hold
people's attention yeah I would say it
happened to a dude yesterday playing
poker I don't know if anybody else knows
that I was paying attention I saw the
pain in his face from realizing that
nobody wanted to hear his story about
going to the club and you did the right
thing right I didn't say nothing but I
was just like looking at him in pain
like damn tell me how you recognize that
[__] you still left my man left my man
hanging because they'd be like hey man
do you want to keep going with that
story you could have brought him back
you could have saved his self-esteem but
you just watched him burn and yes he's
screaming for help you're like no he had
said a bunch of other annoying [__] up
to that point so I was kind of like
happy to like see him like perishing you
got a petty bone can you make sure that
my salads are in the fridge while we're
on the topic sorry I don't mean to put
that on you or anything okay
but yeah I mean I could I I could see in
that way how the feeling of having
everybody hang on your words is
gotta there's gotta be something to that
in in comedy do you feel you don't do
bro yep Pro
Pro
if you do not put your titties away brav
well we're on the topic sorry I don't
mean to put that on you or anything okay
but yeah I mean I could I I could see in
that way how the feeling of having
everybody hang on your words is
bro
my man's titties is resting on his belly
and his belly is resting on his lap bro
am I lying
oops
I've got a chair for everything
gotta there's gotta be something to that
in in comedy do you feel you don't do
life Gail can you let him know what's
going on in the chat tell him we will
address certain things
that fake news media pushes we will
address it once Amiri hits a thousand
subscribers we got all night people
we got all night all right but we don't
work for free
working for free that would be modern
day
a horrible thing to do that'll be more
than day Nick Fuentes
that would be modern day
indention
[Music]
so so again
and remember we don't negotiate with
with what we don't negotiate we don't
negotiate with terrorists we do not
we you know speak to people that attack
ideas but once you start calling me a
[__] a dweeb and a weirdo
you lost the plot man you you
we don't negotiate with terrorists we
don't
um but if you would like to know you
know what we're even talking about
make sure you subscribe
and not to my channel
to amiri's channel that is in the title
now what it what are you at right now
468 471.
thank you guys we're trying once we get
to a thousand we'll address some things
but sorry we'll continue this reaction
all right
no never done it we should do a live
podcast you guys have done it I I do
live shows I don't do like uh I do live
stand up so I know that but I haven't
done like a live like filming of YouTube
but I see some people who do like live
podcasts and it works well like your fan
base will come out for sure yeah and
it's a great way to monetize what you
already do and uh if you do that you'll
see the energy like
doing [__] in front of crowds is a
different ball game because you have
that one-on-one inter not one like it's
direct it's not through any editing it's
not there anything they can feel the
energy of the people there and it's a
different ball game you feed off of it
sometimes when the when the rapport with
the crowd is on point and it just
heightens everything yeah you know it
has me [__] up is that I remember back
like three four years ago we were gonna
do a live podcast and I remember looking
at the money and thinking like oh like
that's a great bag
is he a grifter
I like to Adam
I thought he was nice
a whole network and you don't want well
get out of here man yeah
yeah I mean I'm trying to get me to do a
podcast the other day and it was like
the same negative thing oh you seen it
no I haven't seen it I know they do it
though they told me on the show
I just think it's a negative like at the
end of the day what do you stand for
what are you
and I didn't think this at the time at
the time I was like well I don't really
care but I've had a long hard think you
know what I mean
times you gotta think about life and
you gotta really think about what you
represent what you push and what you
stand for and the problem is that
nowadays like the new religion is
standing for nothing
and pushing degeneracy
so I don't
wait Listen Hold on hold on let me check
to see what y'all got first I like Adam
though no offense Adam I do like you no
we go get into that I do I do we're not
changing no subject I'm not I'm trying
to be rude it's just like it's
degeneracy you know it's not
it's not a good thing all right what how
did the conversation go did you say with
Adam it's all on YouTube no no what
about his um
yeah I mean he interviewed me it was oh
my gosh I was so sick during it so I
just was not on smoke because like
honestly I was so sick during that
interview I felt horrible
yeah nah
contour and make a really good living
right not too many dancers can do that
at a medium-sized level and then tour
right the top end you can always find a
few but I don't look at the top end to
find out if an art form is sustainable
you gotta look at the people in the
middle and the people on the bottom and
can they eat at all and also most
dancers they make their money off other
dancers it's a kind of like a pyramid
scheme in a way right that's not a
sustainable thing you think about
musicians they got fans they got people
the public who just [__] with they [__]
if the only people that you get money
from are the people who come to your
classes or your workshops or your
battles and they're all dancers right
then you're just making money from the
community of artists so it's kind of
it's not a good way to make money that's
so true you're really making me think
about skateboarding BMX was like very
similar problems with that yeah because
if the general public is not behind it
how are you going to get advertising
dollars how are you going to get people
to pay tickets to come to your event
they don't really [__] with BMX like
that or if they're not like
it's very important interesting just
watching it you're going to see wins not
because MMA fighters are into it but
because the general
fighting
I don't think so oh is that just Johnson
I would be shocked look wants to see
people bash their heads and you need
those casuals to make something really
profitable long term very very true so
okay you moved out here and tried to do
the dancing thing for a while you gave
up at some point it's not that I give up
it's just like when you see what it's
like behind the scenes you're like I
don't want to do this for a living this
is not I wanna I love doing this and I
still do it to this day so is he a
grifter because he's a dawn saw he's a
backup dancehall that's doing YouTube
now
is he a grifter
I'm not sure I mean they call everybody
a grifter but I don't want to make money
off of it sometimes you just have a
passion for yourself I'm sure you got
[__] that you don't make money off that
you still do right so that was that
mindset so after that I ended up picking
up stand up and that stuck once I did
stand up I was I started making YouTube
videos on my own this is about 2015
2016. so you're doing stand up in LA or
did you moved back home I'd move back
home yeah yeah and they're moving to
Montreal Canada to start doing stand-up
and then I never stopped after that
point really so you thought you had a
real knack for it right away I just got
on stage and I bombed so hard my first
time and I'm like I [__] love this
[__] black blessing come back
come back
really yeah that was trash I remember
going up I had this like terrible bit
about like uh oh it was one of the worst
bits I ever wrote and I still laugh
about it sometimes but I had this bit
about like um how my dad took me to a
funeral and it was like raining and he
said you know when it rains during a
funeral it's because Jesus is uh washing
Away The Sins Of The Dead and so I wrote
this joke about like oh well if you know
if it's uh the tears of the Dead that
are being washed away by the ring and
then when it's snowing it's Jesus is
just and then the problem
dance is the worst first off there's no
health insurance right you [__] up your
leg
La has a rich Street Dancing Yeah you
know you got the stuff in this dance
professionally
um so I was doing that for a few years
that was always part of your life too
for me there's just certain issues in
regards to like you you don't you don't
have any free time in the military
technically you're always on duty that's
why even if you're on the job and you're
in City clothes if you act crazy they
can still reprimand you right if you're
not on the job it's a bit different so
they can court-martial you they can send
you to prison so you have to always be
mindful of how that's going to affect
you when you're out wait what military
was he in like was that pre-pre-weight
I know they've lowered the military
requirements now you can like be fast
yo when was this Rob when you was when
when they're in the world and um
I don't want to get into the details but
I had an incident that happened to me I
was like pretty pretty big deal in my
life and
um unfortunately when you get posted to
the wrong spot and you're under the
wrong Sergeant they can just destroy
your life or they can [__] with you as
much as they want because you know chain
of command so right I unfortunately had
somebody above me who made it their
mission to to make sure that I was going
to be miserable and I was like do you
make your mission for me to be miserable
no
no that's probably why I haven't left I
don't want to be crazy
it's horrible
going on
that they get nothing out of
you would think they would leave with
all the job offers that came everybody's
way not from the content creators that
had the most criticism and have never
hired anyone but maybe an editor or two
in their life
not from them but from other channels
that said they would hire my poorly
quote-unquote treated
employees if it's so bad why is everyone
still here
do you know
that's crazy
probably like the height
why would they report fake news media
that you got fired why would they report
that
um
why didn't they report you talking about
how much you enjoyed working here oh
would you mean oh hell to the north oh
hell no
why didn't they report that because why
didn't they report blessing's statement
that clip had so much juice
on these got on these dead guys that
they would never show their own they
would never show it they would never
show it and you guys always
obviously you guys are different but
their fans they're not gonna go and sit
down and watch a whole hour streaming a
city and where I destroy all of them
somebody who wants to bring me in every
day to [__] me up you know what I'm
saying that I have to take orders from
so uh I decided at that point that I
didn't want to keep living that way so I
was like even though where do you go
from there uh after that I ended up uh
moving to La for a few years I was doing
dance professionally
um so I was doing that for a few years
that was always part of your life too
dance no dance I picked up when I was in
my early 20s I um
in my formative years man I just tried a
bunch of [__] I wanted to see what I
like doing in life because I was
confused I didn't know why I wanted to
go and dance ended up sticking as like
more of a hobby later online later on
life but uh yeah I like going out to
dance I like I just like dance in
general I'm part of the culture I'm
about that life so yeah that's what's up
I've never known too many dancers and be
honest but like I don't know too many
nonsense but he is a dark saw so I know
I know one dance huh I know one dog song
Turn the YouTube volume down oh no no
this is from earlier okay now that Tick
Tock dancing is so big I'll have rappers
tell me like man I can wait is it
sake I've just been not dancing all
these years like yeah there's lyrics to
it I mean you got the stuff that happens
on social media oh [__]
I didn't even know this
because I'm not a dancer
but I didn't know this there's layers to
these thoughts and stuff and that's
that's one layer but then you also have
Ellie has a rich Street Dancing Yeah you
know you got the stuff in the studios
where people get hired to you know dance
behind Justin Bieber but you also have
like an underground senior here that is
super rich and it's got some of the most
behind Justin Bieber
I need to see this how do you just
seeing people chat [__] out there I
gotta see this he was dancers in the
world living right here uh and so you
know it's its own subculture and it
exists it's kind of like graffiti
culture or skating culture like a lot of
people may not know but if you're part
of it you know it's big yeah I remember
I went on a date with a girl one time
and uh last
we ended up going to some bar that
apparently it was like a little party
for a bunch of people from her dance
school
and let me tell you it's something
really intimidating about being around
that many people who are in really good
shape and really have like masterful
control of their movements yeah being
that I don't have any of that and I
couldn't really imagine dancing in my
life depending on it don't be too
envious because uh they're all poor
really
yeah no it's like that oh yeah if you
want to talk about the the worst
professional
they don't do it for money
and then if you want to get money
dance is the worst first off there's no
health insurance right you [__] up your
leg you're done working secondly when
you are working you're not getting paid
that well so you better save up [__]
and if you don't you're going to be
homeless very soon so it's like one of
those professions that it's um the
problem with dance is uh it's ephemeral
like you you have to see it and you
catch it and then it's gone right it's
not something you can just reuse all the
time you can't like film a great dance
video you make a YouTube video it's
there for 20 years right and people can
watch it later on in life and they're
going to enjoy it right so we wouldn't
know that you were dancing because you
didn't record it right but you said
you're a dancer right okay
you're almost wear it guys guys click
his at in the description in the title
subscribe to his channel he's almost a
500 a thousand
we will address
any question that you guys have really
um
we're gonna go in in but we don't work
for free
that would be indentured servitude
[Music]
if you're not doing it you don't get the
same responses and so comedy bit or
whatever so it's just a monetize dance
really well
a dancer and you're super successful
it's like you and 10 other people are
behind cardi B and nobody ever knows
your name exactly if you want if you
want to know whether or not an art form
is like profitable just look at the top
paid people and compare them to the
other disciplines and you'll know very
fast you know you think about the best
dancer in the world and you've probably
never heard of it and their salary is
not that great but compared to the top
singers or the top music producers or
the top painters you know so it's just
it's one of those things that I feel so
bad because I think it's such a dope
form of art but unfortunately in terms
of like making bread why does my man do
that
pause bro people sometimes invest their
whole lives and then come out and have
to like be
pause that man just you know so it's
just it's one of those things that
I feel so bad because I think it's such
a dope form
yo I'm on to him right but unfortunately
in terms of like making bread people
sometimes invest their whole lives and
then come out and have to like become
bus drivers afterwards and they're
devastated I'm like
How Are You Gonna Keep dancing in your
late 40s and 50s for a living it's not
something you can sustain but knowing
everything that you know about social
media and YouTube now would that have
colored how you were viewing dancing
because I'm sure that there's people who
do dance stuff that are making good
livings on social media and stuff right
they're making like decent livings but
it's like it's like just just eyeball he
was obviously making good money like he
was in a backup dance he was probably a
like a front doctor like in front that's
probably what he meant
you probably meant he wasn't a Beckham
dancer I was behind him dancing oh
but I'm not not so but you are a dancer
we know this
it's far few in between yeah you know
what I'm saying not preach he could
never be a dancer as a medium-like sized
artist you can a musician for example
you can tour and make a really good
living right not too many dancers can do
that at a medium-sized level and then
tour right the top end you can always
find a few right but I don't look at the
top end to find out if an art form is
sustainable you gotta look at the people
in the middle and the people on the
bottom and can they eat at all and also
most dancers they make their money off
other dancers it's kind of like a
pyramid scheme in a way right that's not
a sustainable thing you think about
musicians they got fans they got people
the public who just [__] with their [__]
if the only people that you will get
away from are the people did he say it's
not sustainable if you make your money
off of other dancers yeah
does he not know how any business works
wait no
this guy's cuckoo we've established that
time ago
um I established I don't know if you
established I established this time ago
this guy I watched these guys for
entertainment only we'll come to your
classes on your workshops or your
battles and they're all dancers you're
just making money from the community and
even CNN is fake news hey allegedly it
really makes me think about
skateboarding BMX was like very similar
problems with that yeah because if the
general public is not behind it how are
you going to get advertising dollars how
are you going to get people to pay
tickets to come to your event they don't
really [__] with BMX like that or if
they're not like interested in just
watching it the UFC wins not because MMA
fighters are into it but because the
general public wants to see people bash
their heads and you need those casuals
to make something really profitable long
term right obviously very very true so
okay you moved out here and tried to do
the dancing thing for a while you gave
up at some point uh it's not that I gave
up it's just like when you see what it's
like behind the scenes you're like I
don't want to do this for a living this
is not a cap can we just crap in it oh
my God look at look at guys bro okay you
know I had a pro volleyball contract but
do you know what made me give it up
more money yeah you know what I mean
it's like okay you can make
pennies
in an industry that doesn't pay because
you're not good enough to get paid
or you can go make let's just call a
spade a spade you know it's just like
can we call it what it is literally can
we just be real I love doing this and I
still do it to this day but I don't want
to make money off of it sometimes you
just have a passion for yourself I'm
sure you got [__] that you don't make
money off that you still do right so
that was that mindset so after that I
ended up picking up stand up
I started making YouTube videos on my
own this is about 2015 2016. so you're
doing stand up in LA or did you moved
back home I'd move back home yeah yeah
I'm gonna move into Montreal Canada to
start doing stand-up and then I never
stopped off to that point really so you
thought you had a real knack for it
right away I just got on stage and I
bombed so hard my first time and I'm
like I [__] love this [__] really
yeah that was trash I remember growing
up I had this like terrible bit about
like uh oh it was one of the worst bits
I ever wrote and I still laugh about it
sometimes but I had this bit about like
um how my dad took me to a funeral and
it was like
love what you do I just hope this
Insanity doesn't spread to Denmark
though we have some wokeness here most
people laugh at
thank you Michael
go subscribe to The Fresh Prince of
zumanda
let them let them see your face properly
when you say that the fresh prince of
zamanda
498 two more subscribers two more and I
tell her what bundes is all right all
right
foreign
halfway to a thousand Subs we got all
night we'll be here all night and check
this out yeah so Bunda is like a woman's
derriere
that's what we call a woman's derriere
abunda yeah Bunda yeah so Zamunda
Zamunda samunda
sounds similar
there's no relevance has no relevance
other than the fact okay
yeah Zamunda Zamunda yeah again see
Boon does yeah she got a fat Bunda
yeah yeah
what else did you want to show me in
this video are we gonna wait we're gonna
get to the
is there a
you're gonna get to that we're
definitely going to get to that
I'm gonna get to that
I'm gonna definitely get to that
what are you at let's
five ten yeah we're getting there
what do you think they want to hear us
address let me know in the chat what do
you want to hear us address
what clarification do you need about all
this madness that has happened the last
month
wait what helps me that again
no I'm talking to the chat
what what what are you looking to see us
address what are you looking to see us
talk about
what are you listening to
these not gonna find out when it reaches
a thousand
what let's see in this what are they
seeing
[Music]
um
where is snico sneako is not here
he is in the U.S
the you know the Fuentes answers
cannot come without a thousand
subscribers
to amiri's channel
cannot come
they want to know what happened to Sarah
Sarah
you know Sarah was a good
an interesting fella
Auntie is in the Caribbean right now
um you know she's she's got some family
stuff going on so that's what she's
doing
but it's interesting how when certain
people leave
and don't speak about me
their channels tank
you know it's tough making the content
that people are reacting to because
they're all trying to paint a narrative
they're all trying to paint a picture
and me
I'm the one having the conversation
I'm the one pushing the conversation
forward where they're just sitting in
their rooms looking for a 20-something
year old to talk about
all right now what is Amiri gonna show
us
mom did we're just reviewing this oh I
didn't mean to pin and then I did these
live interviews with these girls and I
was like we're just watching Big Short
guys and all this other stuff wait hold
on hold on
for those that just
just um that just got in
we've already established watching this
no jumper interview
that the backup dots off
who
called me a backup dancer
it's actually a backup dancer
okay do you know my mom told me what she
told me when people insult you they're
really using things that they used to
describe themselves
wow so she was like the reason they see
you that way is because they know
they're that way so they can identify it
in you
so
I'm gonna watch what I say to people
then
yeah yeah that's what my mom told me but
yeah so no but preach is not a backup
dancer it's only Abba like Abba he said
his own words that he's a backup
launcher preach no it's bad enough as I
said that preach who is not a backup
dancer who has never been a backup
dancer is allowing a backup dancer to
call me a backup dancer that's what we
have established so far Pearl right
that's all we've established it's like
oh you know you know if I wear heels or
I just I want to hug him and feel like
I'm in safe and security and I'm like
all right cool and I was talking to them
asking like you guys ask for men's
height
on Tinder profiles I'm like yeah I think
it's important for men to post all right
I'm like what if they post like a weight
requirement and the women lost their
minds and it was just like this
juxtaposition between the two points so
yeah that went viral and then from there
I just kind of kept going with YouTube
ever since so I pretended I'm jumping on
shortly afterwards and uh yeah how did
you know
he's also a street dancer oh okay
wait what
no no
no no no no no
I've I heard wrong
that was he's probably talking about
himself I heard wrong what did he say
what did he say bro
I didn't hear him properly what did he
say he said what what's that girls and I
was like asking them let's turn this up
a little bit I can't hear it and like oh
you know he doesn't you know if I wear
heels or I just I want to hug him and
feel like I'm in safe and security and
I'm like all right cool and I was
talking to them asking like do you guys
ask for men's height
on uh Tinder profiles I'm like yeah I
think it's important for men to post all
right I'm like what if they post like a
weight requirement like and the women
lost their minds and it was just like
this juxtaposition between the two
points so yeah that went viral and then
from there I just kind of kept going
with YouTube ever since uh preach ended
up jumping on shortly afterwards and uh
yeah how did you know
he's also a street dancer oh okay
he's also a dancer
he's also a backup dancer
oh hell no
he's also a dancer okay okay okay
I'll take back everything I said
we have two backup dotses
calling me a backup dancer
no
bro I bro yo listen I'm giving money to
whoever sends me a picture of them
dancing brother
someone has got it on the internet of
dead man dancing
I need that footage
that's what I need
oh hell no hey yo listen bro subscribe
to my channel bro we're going bro I'm
going in bro
we go in
we go
in
I need to hear that one more time Carl
he caught me talking about my beloved
preach bro
preach could never be a dancer
wait
did it
and the women lost their minds and it
was just like this juxtaposition between
them yeah that went viral and then from
there I just kind of kept going with
YouTube ever since uh preach ended up
jumping on shortly afterwards and uh
yeah how did you know
he's also a street dancer oh okay yeah
yeah I didn't hear you I need to rewind
this went viral and then from there I
just kind of kept going with YouTube
ever since uh preach ended up jumping on
shortly afterwards and uh yeah how did
you know
he's also a street dancer oh okay
[Music]
do you see why I don't respond to some
people brav do you see why bro many like
yo you got finished by these guys and
I'm like bro
I'm not I'm not responding or not making
all My Bro you've seen this listen watch
this
bro you would never believe this bro
this watch like I'm in safe and security
and I'm like all right cool and I was
talking to them asking like you guys ask
for men's height
on uh Tinder profiles I'm like yeah I
think it's important for men to post all
right I'm like what if they post like a
weight requirement like and the women
lost their minds and it was just like
this juxtaposition between the two
points so yeah that went viral and then
from there I just kind of kept going
with YouTube ever since uh preach ended
up jumping on shortly afterwards and uh
yeah how did you know
he's also a street dancer oh
step outside
bro
yo bro yo bro you caught make this up
Rob you cannot make this up bro we don't
negotiate with backup dancers bro we
don't negotiate with backup dancers bro
yo bro what yo play storms stormzy what
storms
listen to me Brethren oh damn yo bro oh
damn
oh wow the blubber is gone
look at that this is the Dancing Days
wow
that's a dance
they always give participation trophies
that's why I'm ended it because he's
like bro I can't deal with that bro what
wasn't Sarah Dancer too oh nice yeah
different type of dances
is there a trend with this the feminine
bro feminine
row
oh wow bro okay okay I guess I'm saying
bro
oh man
you're not they can't see your screen
right now I know they they haven't
there's not a thousand subscribers they
can't see what we're looking at
I'm looking for a particular is that
really preach his wife bro let's not
even get into it no I shouldn't yes
let's not even get into that okay
I got fresh and put in a lot of trouble
[Music]
leave his boo alone man that's his boo
you know but this is what they'll do the
take this clip and be like we are so
offended bro
black power to him in it no
where is my where is my picture bro I
need to find this
where is it RAV
what's
fire button you know man yo listen
subscribe
subscribe back
yeah let's see what you're at right now
you're at 5 18 on his channel remember a
thousand
subscribers and blessing shows his face
I'm just kidding but but a thousand subs
and we will react to the drama
we will answer all of the questions all
of the misinformation
all of the horrible things going around
about the channel actually let me I
accidentally pinned a random message let
me pin
doing this
the shadow thing another smear session
coming from ABBA and preach we're ready
no they said they would stop talking
about me they're done right
aren't they done
that's what they said aren't they men of
their word bro how they called me a
backup dancer and they are actually both
backup dancers both of them both of them
are actual backup dancers bro both of
them
I'm fired but I'm here
what else they got Ralph
trying to rap and they can't rap
[__]
I make the editor work today bro I'm
gonna work today I'll be back can you
handle the stream I think so can you
handle the you know work the date bro
play with me bro
listen
ing
sound is low okay
how's that
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah
how is that
foreign
Cobra Commander yeah I'm here you know I
mean
all right all right guys I hear you I
hear you
what's up right now
yeah
it's not all right my dad
uh cool cool cool
yeah I'm an AI Robo in it
you want to hug me Jesus
all right
yeah
and you know what I found out over there
that
um preacher's related to Rick James
I'm Rick gamsby
bro I've I heard that he's related to
Rick James bro
don't quote me on it but that's what I
heard him I don't believe that bro if
you like bring a picture a side-by-side
picture you can see the resemblance oh
there there actually these activities
were named I think everybody wants this
mask on you know I don't think I think I
think he's related
that's what they say anyways
Duma Dave damn how did you come up with
your name bro
uh thank you couple Gandhi
guys go and subscribe to amiri's channel
fresh prince of Munda in the building
okay
so I'm gonna try to find one I might
feel my face
when I'm in this channel
well a lot to the people there bro
listen my channel is going to be full of
entertainment entertainment the
entertainment in my opinion I mean the
more subscribers and the more views the
more the Mad thing I do bro okay I
missed a b style on them damn right
I'm identifying his pill right now
they do look alike bro you know what I'm
saying
[Music]
rob you can't say this guy don't look
like this guy about
I said preaching Rick James you know
I'm gonna find a lovely name for him
mate
that is mad
his name is Eric
I'm not calling him Priest No More bro
Eric
for a second love
I'm gonna go this whole stream without
talking about that woman
I'm talking about oh my name and leave
me out this box
oh what's that oh
what's that podcast that one
what's this one bro nonsense put that
one up bro
we have to investigation to do are we
going to find the best one that looks
like him yeah
protection is better than your
protection
our production is better than their
production
I want to help them you know I want to
fix the squeaky flow
brown cows guest house
bro
you can't tell me
listen whoever told me that was not
trolling
James you know oh how do I make this a
big picture without going into today yes
show them right there
you're welcome
yeah
bro you don't quite tell me you don't
can't tell me Bob this isn't slavery rob
you don't tell me that they're not
related bro what you can't tell me that
preacher's not related to Rick James bro
[Laughter]
I'm Rick James [__] bro
look at that RAV
so we have a Rick James looking guy
I'm gonna play
mad
just get bro look what we're going we're
going to find another one look we're
gonna find another resembles bro you
can't you can't tell you can't deny
about these resemblances bro
look at this crap bro
why is everybody thinking you're high
enough oh yeah because yeah they're all
saying I'm high how crazy is it because
she's chilling with me have you been
taking something no you know I don't I'm
anti-weed don't say you're anti I am
anti-weed I think it should be banished
you know I won't name names but if some
people come in here smelling like weed I
tell them to go home I don't want to
smell that all day
the anti-weed anti I'm anti-weed
what's wrong with weed man
let people get high high they can get
high just don't do it around me talk to
your Colonial to the Colonial Master
please guys we need we need some we need
some more
up in here you get me
no
looking for all the content creators
but I did go do it
you know what yeah yeah offer
offer them what I offered them
do you think they can afford you
blessing
um
[Laughter]
no no no no no no
you're telling me they made The
Boondocks after this man
right casino
man's life
you can't tell me
I'm lying direct connections bro direct
relations right yeah
look at that Ralph Uncle Ruckus no
relation look at that
[Laughter]
go subscribe to Mary's Channel bro I'm
gonna play with the internet Casino
go subscribe to amiri's channel
no I'm not
stop it
no stop what did I say what number did I
say though po now they're getting about
three thousands but if I talk about it
then they're gonna clip it and then say
Oh Pearl is starting and only face this
is what they do to me this is what they
do to me you could have a reason to for
them to click on this video just send
them what if I started in only fans and
it was and then I like hyped it up and
it was just me eating sandwiches
that's coming
yeah like hype it up what's going on
here it's just me like eating
I don't die bro you're always in the
comments but you're always hating like
what's your beef stew
I don't go but I don't be good
yeah
well done guys
loving it
I'm loving it loving it loving it I'm
loving it like that man hey bro listen
you don't actually get to talk in a chat
without where's my thanks
for not making it a members only chat
where is my thanks bro
you don't get to chat away you know what
I'm saying
Hollow one two gallon for sure get the
hell out of here
on them
cheese
okay let's see
um
that comment if girls don't know what
her face oh no
we see you
we're so close
yet so far we're actually not that close
guys
click the line
go follow the link follow my channel we
want to talk about
blessing how have you been affected
I'm not affected by any of this [__]
how could it be I want to talk about I
want to talk about myself I'm living my
best life oh God
I'm a woman I want to talk about myself
you know I think that
a lot of these people criticizing me
again couldn't do what I've done and
they could say I don't know what I'm
talking about and I have no credibility
and I have no life experience but these
are the same people that sit in their
rooms reacting for 10 plus years these
are the same people
these are the same people that have
spent the last couple of years
criticizing everybody with no original
thoughts no original ideas and no
original conversations they don't move
the conversation forward they just
criticize they might as well be the TMZ
of YouTube the biggest Critics on the
internet
and no I haven't had wine
but maybe I will wait what someone said
you had wine yeah now they're saying I'm
high and drunk
on a on a random Wednesday come on get
out of here mate
let's do
oh he says this is cringe well this is
cringe you're banished from my chat yeah
you're here though but you're here
though
that's the crazy thing they're here
banish him I I banish people yeah I
don't in the chat I'm a banisher
bruh
do you want to see something do you want
to see something amazing
I'll show you that something amazing
right
they're starting to comment on your
stuff
through
I see my someone that's
um
apparently this girl raised money to sue
me
so that was that was that's a full slide
as well that's what that's what O'Shea
said he said I recruited her oh no do
you know what's funny though you know
what's funny about it I
person that actually recruited her of
him telling her the channel she was
going on telling her the topic and her
saying oh I can't wait to come but did
the fake news ask me for my side of the
story did the fake news report on
anything no men just defamated my
character he defamated my character by
believing a crazy lady on the internet
um remember the people that are putting
out information about me that I knew one
point it's like they're crazy people
because they're reactionary
if somebody's really horrible
they don't wait till everyone else comes
out they come out when it happens
do they ask for my side of the story no
they just push a narrative wow
that's what I'm trying to find one
that's not a mainstream Channel rather
just mute the sounds at least
bro
but someone's got it then someone's got
it that was fake bro that's not fake
it's real messing right it's happened
yesterday if I'm
this happened yesterday
no this is oh this is another comment
you you haven't experienced a lot of the
things you speak on
what how do they know
how do they know what I've experienced
and what I haven't experienced why why
does what okay so let me ask you
something here and you guys all watch
what's what's his name that that um
interviewed Andrew Tate
oh
on on um Kevin Samuels had no experience
with marriage yet he spoke on it all the
time what's what's the what's the guy
what is their point what that talks
about red pill that's what they do come
on guys you know who I'm talking about
man what's this guy and they don't even
know anything for sure they just
speculate and they create these stories
that aren't even true or maybe they're
half true and
I don't know why you take the modern
breath
I know I ignore them 90 of the time but
today I'm trying to get you to a
thousand subscribers you know what I
mean this is for a greater cause
this is for a greater cause yep
this guy's disguise boom P.S Morgan
Pierce Morgan do you think Pez Morgan
knows anything about red pill not one of
well come on bro
this Vice guy is inside of his house
this doesn't attack your argument they
attack your character like one of the
hit pieces that Adam preached did on me
was about chores all right now let's
talk about it from a society perspective
is it good to get divorced over chores
is that a good I'm so tired of talking
about this it's like no man you like to
subscribe to my channel love yeah yeah
but but they don't analyze the argument
they're trying to draw us out bro no no
no I'm gonna talk about this because
this isn't the real that's not the real
thing they're waiting to hear
but they don't they so now they're like
oh well I say it's not good to get
divorced over chores I believe in
marriage I don't believe in divorce over
silly things like chores I think things
can be worked out and what do they say
what are the Christians even the
Christian channels were reacted like
this is why people leave the church
because now you got pastors talking
about yeah get divorced over I'm like
what what now two two
the other thing they do is they'll take
a clip without the full context
for example they referenced me they said
oh you just used one study and then they
used a study that was and you know what
the study who it was made by
um a lady that had a what a gender
studies degree are we gonna take
seriously a lady who made
a study with a gender studies degree
and then I say oh don't get divorced
over chores and they say are you married
are you single
where's your experience and I say don't
you know I just don't think it's a great
thing to get divorced over chores when
there's kids involved bro how did you
even get married to someone without even
and this is what they do then they just
pick at you they call you a [__] a
dweeb and a weirdo
quite rude
classy is the best attraction
thank you
[Music]
that's crazy
bro if they oh no way and let's let's
talk about a society guys
it's all about perspective
no to the way
oh no it's only gonna take another two
hours to put together that thumbnail
let's just call them and you know what
life is about perspective okay
life is about perspective you know
people used to work through horrible
atrocities famines
the plague you know crazy [__] and now
we're getting divorced over what chores
what would you get divorced over for
I don't believe in divorce I think okay
this is what I think don't get clips
they're gonna clip me anyway like that's
what they're gonna do whatever I don't
give a [__] so I think this is where the
people that actually want to like think
about this stuff What is marriage if
divorce is on the table
are you asking me yeah if divorce is on
the table What is marriage
it decreases the value yeah it's not
marriage
because it's a relationship
if you can break up over every little
thing it's not marriage it's a
relationship
that's the problem
I think abuse when it harms the kids
um
extreme cheating but I still think
cheating can be worked out to be honest
um
no like genuinely I think when you get
married it's a contract like I think
it's between you and God no I'm not
laughing at you I'm laughing
oh this thumbnail is funny guys
you know what I mean no I
have the contract between you and God
yeah and I like I think you make that
promise like with God and I'm not even a
crazy religious person but I just think
like once you take once divorce is on
the table marriage isn't marriage
anymore
me leaving you know
well do you know in the Bible they talk
about men can divorce women for adultery
but like women can't divorce men
[Laughter]
ah
the church father's got you locked yeah
but I mean they even used to separate
before getting divorced
like like but I think I I think so are
they saying that
they should have separated they should
just
no I think that the modern generation
wants to get divorced over any and
everything I think the modern generation
wants to get divorced if the woman makes
more money if she doesn't feel like he's
doing chores which was they don't talk
about is a lot of times women don't talk
about the stuff that men do and they
just like they only account for the
stuff that and I've done that in a
relationship before do you know where
I'm like thinking oh he's not doing this
this and this and like you're being too
critical and then you don't then like he
then one day it's like he says oh well I
did this this and this and you're like
oh [__] I didn't even realize and
sometimes as women like we take men for
granted for all the things that they do
for us
and that's happened to me before and so
it's like that's what I mean like
like life is about working through it's
not about changing people it's about
like loving them for who they are
and the problem with our generation
today is it's like they want to get
divorced over every little thing and it
and it takes out marriage and I just say
if you believe in getting divorced over
every little thing then stay stay with
the people in relationships why get
married but the problem is for the
people that really like believe in
marriage they've taken away the sanctity
of marriage with no fault divorce
because if you can get divorced for
everything it is not marriage like you
used to have to write like a petition to
the court or something I don't know the
ins and outs of it but it used to be
difficult to get a divorce it was really
only like cheating abuse and addiction I
think there's maybe one more
and like that's that's the problem with
our generation
is and that's the problem is all these
reaction channels they don't know what
they're doing and all these left like
they've never thought about it from and
I'm not even a crazy crazy religious
person but like a more religious
person's like point of view where it's
like you guys are destroying the
sanctity of marriage for us because now
if I get married it's not marriage and
the guy that I marry doesn't know that I
won't leave because it used to be that
even that if a guy married a girl and
maybe she was a little overweight or
maybe she had a high body you know maybe
something was wrong with her but he knew
in exchange he got the Loyalty for a
lifetime and he knew that she wouldn't
leave to go like to another guy or she
wouldn't leave
um and take the kids but now it's like
what men are walking away from marriage
because of what everyone else has done
to it because they have ruined the
sanctity of marriage
and that's what I think and that's why
it's like a lot of these reaction
channels and these news outlets like
they are promoting the destruction of
society and they don't know it
they don't they don't mean to what if
what if the reason why you're you're
actually getting married in the first
places for the wrong reasons
okay go ahead so say for example like if
I really loved you I don't think I'm
Gonna Leave because of something Petty
so it would have to be that I didn't
really want to get married in the first
place
so why is no one talking about the
people getting married instead of the
people getting divorced
why are we not talking about the people
getting married instead of the people
getting divorced
you say oh
we should be getting divorced for chores
or they shouldn't be getting divorced
which was why are you getting married in
the first place
why are you marrying someone that
doesn't do chores
yeah you know you know what I mean yeah
why are you marrying someone that you're
gonna divorce for do if they're not
doing the chores preach you don't need
to get married to be together so why are
you getting married
why the hell are you getting married
and it's supposed to be about something
like it's supposed to be about something
bigger than you and that's what they
don't talk about like it it's okay I
look at my parents right and they always
make fun of me for talking about my
parents but it's like why would I not
talk about these people that have made
something that is so great okay so wait
you should no because they they'll make
fun of me because I talk about my family
a lot and they're like well and then
they'll say oh just lonely things or
whatever like they'll just they'll just
say but it's like why would I my parents
built something that people dream of
building like that what they did was
actually amazing you know and I'm not
saying their relationship's perfect
right it's not but they met you know
when my mom was
she she was young she was right out of
high school right and she met my dad
they got married uh like five years
later and they built a multi-million
dollar business together
they they they they built a 10 bedroom
house together
they
um they raised 10 kids they adopted
three together
and it's like
you don't think I should learn something
from people that are more successful
than most people are in society and all
of our kids like most of my every
sibling that's older than me makes six
figures they have a family of their own
wait wait wait you proved my point
because before I said to you that there
was a line there was a line here of
Ukraine Ukraine and Russia remember
there was a line that was here between
Ukraine and Russia where I was saying
you should get married as early as
possible so if your dad didn't get
married to your mom as early as possible
maybe he wouldn't yeah but the issue is
the women have changed today
that's the problem it's like the women
the women aren't the same and that's why
like what I realized is men waiting to
get married and playing the field is
just a reaction because you might get
played by like if you have less
experience than the woman which
typically young men do the issue is
you're naive and predatory women take
advantage of you that's why I say to
wait
yeah but shouldn't you just be teaching
the men how to be better
shouldn't you teach the men to be better
equipped yeah well I can't well I I
can't do that because because I don't
know how to seduce women you know I mean
like I I can like watch like I've been
to a pickup artist or like what like I
can listen to you guys talk about it but
it's different than actually doing it
like you can talk about sales but if
you've never done it remember what I'm
saying the argument is you should be
marrying a woman younger because they're
more to mold and
you know they should be no I'm saying
you should wait as a guy till you're
older and marry someone younger oh okay
yeah no I'm not saying Mary
okay
but that's like that's like genuinely
this is the problem with like the TMZ's
the cnns the reaction channels it's like
they don't know they are promoting
degeneracy like they're promoting an
evil message whether they like it or not
getting divorced over chores is an evil
message like do you know what that does
to a family like single mother homes
perpetuate every problem in society
they're 80 of the prison population
they're more likely to run away from
home they're more likely to be homeless
every big problem you see in society
stems from single mother homes now how
do I know this one you can look at Stats
and two I I talk to people all the time
on the street and just ask them their
life story you know what I mean so it's
like I go there's a homeless shelter
down the street and I've spoken to
multiple people there about why they
think these problems happen and they so
many of them have said incompetent
mothers mothers with multiple baby
fathers like these these men have never
had a stable like upbringing and so it's
like when you're promoting the message
that women can leave over everything
like to me that is an evil message do
you think do you think with
that actually left a relationship
because of what they saw
I think it's highly possible that
someone has seen that and thought wait
should I be leaving because of chores
I'm leaving
I don't know
you don't know I think I think probably
at least one that's at least one and
it's like you know
women come up to me all the time on the
show and say you know I've changed this
decision because of you
that happens to me all the time and it's
never but it's a it's like I'll say Hey
you know
get married as young as you can you know
or I say hey don't listen that happens
to me Poe and I haven't I've got how
much subscribers
and I have
532 and people come up to me and say you
changed my life
foreign
but it's like this is or or they'll come
up to me and say hey like you've helped
me understand men better and it's not to
say there's not other content creators
that do the same thing they do like I
think there's a lot of great like I
think fresh and fit's a great Channel I
think that um I think Rolo tomasi is a
great Channel I think Sterling Cooper
Justin Waller like I think those guys
all have phenomenal content I'm not
saying I'm the only one who should do it
but sometimes it's like women can't hear
it from a man and they don't hear you
until a girl says it too well some some
women some of them others and some men
hear your message because it's coming
from you as well
you know like that's what that's the
whole point of this whole thing like
that's why I don't get about some of
these content creators if you are just
regurgitating talking points where do
they get the talking points from
because I I hear a lot of regurgitation
from the same people that are saying
regurgitation it's like you're not
supposed to stay on code with what the
the consensus is of red pill well and a
lot of times like I'll give them a story
as to where it came from and then
they'll use the story against you and
say that's not enough that there's no
life experience but those same content
creators sit in the room streaming all
day no I'm serious like what life
experience do you really get like do
content creators really have normal life
experience for the average person you
tell me Po this content creator
you know um no I don't think I think no
I'm serious okay
let me explain it let me explain there's
two types of content creators there's
types that only do reactions and their
only thing is news no there's two types
there's content creators creators that
make content
creators of content they create content
create content she creates it and you
review the content that she's created
yeah and they wanna and they want to
throw it out in my face and be like oh
well you've done reaction channels too
but it's like okay you can do reaction
channels for a little bit but for how
long are you just sitting there
criticizing everybody go make your own
content stand for something believe in
something they don't believe in anything
exactly it's like where where do you
stand where's your content being created
yeah you can sit down and review content
no one's saying you can't review content
but where is the content for you to be
reviewed
sitting down watching other people's
videos for you to sit down and criticize
them where's the videos of you for us to
criticize where are your dancing videos
so we could criticize your thoughts and
videos and it's genuinely like what do
you believe in and what I believe in you
cannot you cannot tell me is not good
for society I believe men and women are
better to get for are better together
but I believe that the systems we have
discriminate against men and that we
should work to dismantle those systems
and make them more fair it would never
happen
where to where as men we're too easy to
go along with do you know what you're
right you know you're right it's not
affecting me that that you're right and
then you sit down as a man is like wait
hold on a minute there's no way the
world has changed like that and then it
has
you like I've so many men have been like
there is no way this is how females are
you have to be picking them out they so
think I I go out and
cherry-picked these goals like not all
of them are not like this like they
literally think we Cherry Picked no
these are
and that's that's the other thing
they'll say like okay do you know what's
crazy one claim that he had about me was
that oh you only dunk on black women or
something like it's all about black
women and what so what I what did I do I
had one of my clippers go through and
and Mark what race all of the people
that came on my show were and let me
tell you
um it was
not the majority black woman oh I know
because you recruit them I know and the
crazy thing is and the demo I mean it
was slightly higher it matched with the
city of London demographics in match it
was slightly higher in black women but
it's based on where we live and so it's
like what do they expect me to do but
they don't but they don't care about the
facts all they care of is about pushing
a narrative because that's how they make
money now do you know what it is for me
Pro like so I recruit them and when I
bring them here and they embarrass me by
doing something I go out to this right
this way I go out yeah I go out to look
for a black girl to save the day if she
comes in and messes it up again then I
go out to look I prep every single one
of them
I tell watch the show watch the show
before you go on know what you're
getting yourself into understand this
boom boom boom yeah yeah boom boom do
you think I just do black girls no black
girls white girls Asian Chinese Indian
Somali I don't care what they said they
they lied too because when I dm'd them
the the P you know who when I dm'd them
they said oh all of her content was her
clowning on black women well at the time
my top content was me roasting a fat
chick if anything the most discriminated
against has been the whales
but and but that's what I'm saying like
they have a narrative and they'll tell
you their narrative because they even
said they didn't like me I don't know
when they before they knew me I knew
this and so it's like I told you this
you did and we would if we got to a
thousand
s we're giving them too much
you guys have to subscribe you have to
subscribe to amiri's channel we're gonna
react to the hate video we'll be here
all night we have to get to a thousand
subscribers okay they say you know what
you believe
and it's it's not what's in hatred you
just got to describe better
um you know what you believe
and
the other thing they don't talk about is
like what are the outcomes of the things
that they push
what are like like today I was going
back and forth with Destiny on Twitter
on Twitter No and like what what are the
outcomes of the things that you push
like he he is always giving excuses to
women for leaving men and it's like what
outcome does that have I don't really
give a [__] about like like parents can
come back from this but the real people
that suffer are the kids those are the
people that suffer Pro Destiny needs
real men to leave women so he has a
better chance about
no real woman is sitting down with no no
pink head Railroad
no fluffy guy brav taking him seriously
none he's not debating me
through the bank power
these femboys brav I'm telling you from
I'm gonna leave them you know what I'm
saying
you know what they say
he runs the world well and the other
people that were criticizing my
contracts have offered contracts to
nobody and they're twice my age a lot of
them so it's like why why are you
criticizing what I've done when you
haven't seen it none of them asked to
see the contract none of them reached
out to us they just reported what they
wanted to report and
and do you know listen do you know what
yeah do you know what you know what I
saw I saw that they were saying some
couple people saying that you don't
treat your workers correctly so I saw a
video with them treating their workers
correctly and they were giving them a
present so I thought wow what what
president
who gave it to them dude
the content creators were giving their
workers uh special people gifts I was
like oh wow bro it was a wallet
a metal wallet
well and people's no no I'm not finished
sorry the metal wallet was given to them
free from the sponsor of their video
well
and the other thing they don't talk
about is people's peoples know people's
lives have been changed by working here
people's lives have been changed like
King worked at Amazon before do you know
it's like working at Amazon I don't want
to know um there's another person that
worked as a train like you had to get up
at four in the morning every day work on
a train
um
you know blessings making more money
than he's ever made like people's lives
have been changed by working here and
but they don't they don't talk about
that and none of them covered that they
just covered what they wanted to cover
and it's unfair journalism it's them
pushing a narrative they're trying to
find a [__] in your arm man
be dodging them like
we got my way
how much Subs do you got get out my way
I'm coming
move out my way you see what did Abram
preach fans say you can't go for them
you only got six hundred thousand for
subscribers
oh a lot changes in two two months
[Music]
subscribe
oh look at Thane mattress Thane Metro is
literally actually one of the most like
generous super Chatters in the space he
supports freaking everybody you need to
subscribe blessing why are you still
here off to the camera rehab fam
no seriously guys subscribe to amiri's
channel because people's lives have
changed by working here my life is like
so many people's lives
got one of these
now you can never have one of these
you need to actually work hard to get
one of these I know hey
appreciate probably get one of these you
know what if you spent enough that all
that energy to be like Pearl can we work
together you might have got one of these
already
yeah and it's also like what
what kind of person like makes hit
pieces on their friends is that is that
a masculine thing to do like people can
you know I I didn't always like fresh
and fit to be honest yeah you guys claim
that don't send that on the guys that's
the thumb guys no at one point I didn't
but like you can you can say what you
want about them but they're they believe
what they say and they would never turn
on their friends it's actually amazing
how loyal they are to their friends
Fresh and fit I'm gonna call them
they're they're so loyal to their
friends you know I wonder I wonder if
they I wonder if these reviews would be
happy if you didn't do podcasting
anymore
they would you reckon yeah no I think
they would I think they like they're
waiting for us to fail that's what they
want that's what they want like that's
why every time our views are lower
they're like oh look she's falling off
or every time like that's why why do you
think these you know these reaction
channels were offering my entire staff
jobs at which none of them took but did
they report on that no and and why is it
is it because they want me to succeed no
they want me to fail in their bullies
all of them are bullies I don't think
you'll view let's listen YouTube for me
is this like a successful Channel goes
like this
if you know stocks you know there's a
downswing an upswing
higher highs and and higher lows
yeah
it goes up and down like this if you
have a channel like certain man it goes
like that
get me
lower highs and lower lows
we're doing higher highs and higher lows
every single YouTube channel no Channel
goes like that and stay go keep going
like that no
even Mr Beast goes like that goes like
that goes like that that's how it works
well it's the long game and that's what
I see you know
um
you know that's I see the long game and
that's what a lot of people think that
like throwing people under the bus in
the short game is good when in the long
game it screws you up because nobody in
the industry wants to work with you and
we see your true character exactly we
see your character and exactly
yeah you burn enough Bridges there will
be no cross
and it's like dude do masculine men make
hit pieces on their friends is that like
something and that's the thing it's like
all these gossip channels they're
they're so feminine bro it's like
they're so feminine yeah man
you had a big man talking about next big
man come on bro
who does that bro that's that's you lots
culture that you try to promote nah man
real man we saw it out in the in in in
in the cigar room we're chilling in the
back no one hears about it it would know
that there's there's disagreements just
come boom this is how we in front we
unite in front in the back we could
argue however but they don't know about
it that's how real men do it
that's how real women do it and you know
I actually I actually changed my mind on
the whole album preaching I was team
Abba and preach I was in the beginning
of um the fresh and fit drama but what I
well no I was but I didn't realize how
they took Myron out of context and they
painted him has that like they basically
me-tooed Myron by painting him as like
some Harvey Weinstein type [__] by not
putting those texts in context it was
actually disgusting I'll tell you what
happened
a comedian
was [__] on
comedically and they couldn't take it
they couldn't take it they couldn't take
men talking about his fat wife they
couldn't take it
sorry but they started it that's
something can I say overweight
what I need to find a cute way of saying
fat who else must look cute okay right
that's if you want to disrespect them I
just want to be like fluffy about it
what's nice and fat
chunky
that's a little over chunky
giving Facebook then match her again one
giving negative energy in life is a
colossal waste of time learn eventually
I don't want to smoke I'm not coming for
no one that's not in no YouTube space
that's your boo that's you I am not
coming for you whoever I'm saying people
love who they love bro I'm on that
that's the only thing I wish Mara never
went down that road
but
I'm not gonna add homonyms I'll I'll
come I'll come for your belly button and
honestly yeah yeah I gotta get fresh and
fit credit you know I think they offer
you know and this is me even conceding
like they offer more value than anyone
in the space who's had more men's
Improvement guys on I can't teach men
game I don't know how to pick up women
I've never done it do you know what I
mean and it's like so they're out here
giving Solutions and making the world a
better place and what like what do these
reaction channels stand for that have
been [__] on them the past year and
a half like I guarantee fresh and fit
I've saved literal lives bro fresh and
fit blue Abba and preach fresh and fit
blue Kevin Samuel fresh and fit blue
Andrew Tate fresh and fit blue jaywala
fresh and oh
attack men after men of the men of the
men Tommy so demaio's career revived on
fresh and fit I'm telling you the people
that come inside are fresh and fit and
have these amount of people that's
watching them live the real guys that
sit down every day and watch this stuff
is clocking on
yeah you take whatever you want to take
from there they talk about finances
Health Fitness whatever your fed 11
whatever you want to get from that those
two guys you get from over there and I
can even say that I I used to have a
different perspective on them like I
really didn't like them at first but I
can I can genuinely look back and say I
was wrong and triggered back then to be
honest and it's like you don't see all
the good that they're doing but it's
like all Advent preach has done for
years is like hit piece hit piece hit
piece it's like they just sit on the
lives waiting for to take something out
of context so
the amount of sour breath
I'm subscribers I think we're giving
wait listen I'm talking way sorry way
too much
you forget why you don't have something
listen 538 fam
I I think okay I I think that Kevin
Samuels also brought a lot of value to
the space I think they're about 100
million I think they were both great in
just like different ways they're all
great
yeah
even Destiny Destiny's great at doing
what he's doing he's great these men are
all great I don't [__] on these guys but
if they come for me or come for you I'm
going for them I don't care about and
like whoever who are the real grifters
the people that don't stand for anything
or believe anything or the critics like
the critics are the real grifters on
YouTube because they follow where where
the trends are where the people doing
gender genuine conversations and pushing
the conversation forward it's like
they're the ones creating the content
that everyone's reacting to I don't let
listen part this is how I see it yeah
they say you stole this dot dot that
format from this one that that or
whatever from this but what I've seen is
that
you've used to your tools where everyone
has always done on YouTube yeah and
you've done it better than them and not
only that people like if you check the
timeline correctly you will see that
they took it from you not you took it
from them they took it from you don't
try it Ross I've watched bro sat down
and watched you cats bro what are you
talking about bro do you know how much
YouTube channels cat what we do bro
I'm not and I'm not hating on them
called power to the power to whoever
wants to be a content creator out in
this space is difficult but if you work
hard you get it bro there's enough pies
for everybody but don't try tell man we
stealing nothing bro don't come around
we do we do our own thing ahead we big
our air
you see just pearly things yeah
I can't even do your British accent mode
sort it out mate
all right guys you need to subscribe
there is
439 people in here we're trying to get a
Miri to
um I read that already yeah yeah yeah
that's the coming to my channel yeah
yeah no I'm serious guys yo Mary really
does offer a lot of value on his channel
he's really entertaining and you can't
he's he's the type of guy that you can't
he believes what he believes and he's
not gonna waver on it
um so make sure make sure you go
subscribe and he he really wants to help
like he really wants to help men with
their finances not only that yeah
like I don't see you know I don't
understand why if you have a
disagreement with someone on something
do you does it have to be a war with
someone or something
whatever happened to I agree to disagree
or yeah we we agree 99 why are you
focused on the one percent that you
don't that you disagree with the person
on that's what I find a lot like people
be like yeah like Andrew Tate yeah like
a lot of his pointers but I don't agree
with everything he says yeah and it's
like do you agree with what everyone
says like you don't even agree with 100
what your mom says but you love your mum
what are you talking about bro you ask
these guys what do they hate oh yeah I
can't really
get to mine what it is I can't pinpoint
what I hate
um
it's bare those you don't know because
people have told you today
people have told you to hate and what
we're coming to now is feminine guys
that are telling their girlfriends ah
don't listen to that Andrew take guy
like what excuse the hell to the me a
guy telling his girlfriend not to listen
to Andrew day ah we have a lot of work
out here to do man
ah we have a lot of work to do
guys
make sure you subscribe to his channel
I need you to get I need you all right
guys we're gonna We're not gonna talk
until you get it to 600 subscribers he's
at 43.
he's at 5 43
we need to get to 600 oh we'll be here
all night
we don't waver yeah we don't need to go
nowhere yeah I got I got nowhere to be
I'm a YouTuber I can do what I want
clearly boy boy black most most of my my
audience is in America we got time what
does he mean clearly I don't know
YouTube
what does he mean by that
Oh wait we're not gonna talk until
what is he what do you mean by that I'm
not just gonna [__] on you what do you
mean by that clearly I don't know
YouTube
explain
elaborate
but
what are you going to show me with the
album Preach video
which one you're wasn't there a part of
it you were going to show me
hold on
there's a lot bro these guys are losers
bro what do you mean no like the the one
the no jumper interview
I thought you were gonna show me
something
what the belly
it's belly
the fact that both of them are backup
dancers
the fact that they they're a
self-proclaimed grifter
oh okay I didn't know what what do you
mean what what the hey bro anyone that
has any bro listen there's so much
there's so much like bro that's what
that's the thing about YouTubers yeah
that's the the dreaded thing about
YouTube you and you do so many videos
that people could like catch
contradictions but everyone contradicts
themselves bro every living human right
person but that's the thing like is it
good in going into something in good
faith if you're going through years of
reaction videos looking for a
contradiction but do you want a face
fake fake reaction from me
do you want me to like okay so say for
example
say for example you something
catastrophic happened that made you
change like before you used to fly now
because five of your sisters died in a
plane you don't want to fly anymore and
then you said now I don't want to fly no
more someone's like oh you said you
wanted to you love flying you you fly
waffle you like flying it's like I'm
entitled to change my mind about
whatever I want to change my mind on
though you can't tell me I can't change
my mind bro who are you bro well I'm in
my 20s like why would I not change my
mind in my freaking 20
do you have the same opinion you had at
26.
and I've been on here since I was 24 I
think
if you guys
had me when I was 24 I would have been
canceled RAV
yeah look at this is what like mystery
this dude was cut from Pearl's lineup
for talking trash to Adam preach now she
brings him back on when she's feeling
desperate it's like is that true this is
Brad dumb and deluded but so this are
you stupid anyone pull me from any panel
you dumb brother oh yeah show me the
show me where I got pulled from the
panel
show me where I got pulled in a panel in
fact I was on shows after that you dance
breed bro we talking about brav I got my
own channel on the thing top top recruit
above restructured the background Ralph
what are you talking about bro you don't
know what I do here Brad
you don't know what Paul does other than
what you see in front of the camera bro
and whatever dumb review is listen
what's up talking at your backside bro
I'm done RAV
not talking to Old Shea bro we tell you
one week later no I told you now bro
shut up Ralph no one pull me up from
your panel brav
you get me all I found out on that on
that panel is that sorrow is a snake
brav he's a Judas brav
about not me not me not not I'm not bro
yes where are you not here
not part of organization that's what I'm
gonna say about that guy now
this who is that guy the deluda guy bro
come to my channel and check that
westbro
guys go subscribe to Mary's Channel
bro go subscribe it's all you have to do
is click um his uh at in the description
in the title and it's the fresh prince
of Zamunda it's also in the chat click
it go subscribe we really want to get
him to a thousand subscribers tonight
and once we do we will react to the Abba
and preach
can you tell the difference between me
and Pope pose where we please guys just
me I'm like bro if you don't
I'm gonna grab you little
shake it till you urinate bro if you
don't go to my channel subscribe bro
that's how I feel inside bro sometimes
I'm too excited like ah left to right
but inside them like this outside of my
eyes
inside of my life
you know
wait can we react oh let's react as a
clip from your channel oh no
let's react to one of the clips from the
show
which one which one you go to your
channel click like click here oh
we can react to one of the shows we did
together
I don't even think we should be like if
these not a lot real fans of yours if
they don't know that I'm in and around
the channel since the almost the
beginning bro like we talking about bro
and I've never stopped RAV
in fact the episode the direct episode
after I came on
then I came on a direct episode after
I run up in the building stopped
production and said brav
elephant hair behind here what are you
talking about bro only true fans that
watch all the podcasts would know this
bro
lose around
certain people didn't even know I'm the
same person can't cut my hair you know
what else I'm sick of everyone's saying
oh Pearl's single and teaching wife
School
I I go through wife school it's about me
learning more traditional skills
and learning like what skills you need
to build a family and yet
no so pick one of the ones from the show
like from like one of the first ones bro
this is like this is like a week and a
half of us working with are you crazy
these are not doing that bad what are
you what
no pick uh pick one of the first three
do the first one
check
this is a chick that threatened me
and I have evidence if you ever go
through with it I have tax receipts
thank you social media with having
dating apps now that that hasn't caused
an issue in terms of individuals now
committing what does social media have
to do with the conversation so I find
that social media has a major hold on a
minute
is this me what what is she moaning
about
is this me just Clowning clowning women
no but what was she moaning about I just
say I'm skinnier than I was then look at
it look at my arms I'm skinnier now oh
no yeah yeah yeah
that dress was not flattering but like
okay I'm skinny right now
you're not fanatically dressed I don't
know what I was doing I didn't have any
money for clothes I used my mom's
dresses what is going on with them shoes
though
I know that was like my biggest
complaint for the longest time was the
shoes I had like no money back then I
literally that people don't believe me
when I said back then I had no money I
had no money guys subscribe to Mary's
channel the his title is in the
description I'm here you little fake
bread where are you about talking about
come on bro I'm hey bro we talking about
bro man's been part of the institution
for time bro with the conversation in
terms of dating because expectations
what's she complaining about I don't get
it she got destroyed on the panel
intellectually wait let me go I don't
know let it play it so hi I think it's I
think people expect I think it raises
women's fair use fair use I don't want
it's the owner of this copyright for
copyright
because women's are DMS are flooded they
are that's true yeah and so it gases
women's up moving up and think they're
hotter than the arcs they can get you
can be an average chicken of an NBA
player slide into your DMs it cools your
confidence
don't get me wrong I I don't think it's
great either way so I do think there's
an issue in terms of it it sets
expectations to be higher and then when
you have so much access to speaking to
you know hundreds of women on a daily
basis but see this is the delusion she
thinks that men have access to hundreds
of women
yeah okay men also become more picky
hold up hold up
it's a small it's a it's a small
percentage of men that are picky because
again yeah yes
and that's what I'm saying you're right
it is harder to get you know I almost
feel like I almost feel like they want
all women to sleep around so they could
be wifeyed
oh these girls no no one in particular
I'm just saying I realized their
argument now they want all I didn't
understand why would you want other
women to follow in your footsteps is
because they if you lower the price of
everyone else exactly you can eat better
in the market because they're 9.99 and
everyone else is 100 100 pounds they
need everyone to be 9.99 so they could
get picked finally well and that's what
people don't understand is like they say
that I [__] on women but I actually care
about women I just think our choices are
the result like have resulted in a lot
of issues in society and it's like but
and in the end they affect us and we're
not happy we're not happy on
antidepressants at 55 by ourselves
because we divorced our husbands like
we're not we're not happy we're not
happy in financial trouble because we
spend too much money on our credit card
because like because my money is hit
like his Mo like we we're doing this
equal partnership type [__] where you
have equal sales in the household on
money you're not happy arguing with your
husband all the time because you're
trying to wear the pants in the
relationship and there's a lot of
information that we don't have and we're
not told because most of us have never
seen a traditional relationship we've
never seen it our moms wore the pants
and the relationships our grandmas wore
the pants in the relationships because
we have a system that pushes women to
the Forefront and a media that does it
too that doesn't talk about
traditionalism and submission when we're
naturally happier in that
and make they can [__] on me all or they
want and say oh you've never been
successful in relationships blah blah
blah but it's like I'm not dumb and
anyone with common sense can can tell
you that what works and what doesn't and
let's just look at history for a second
like traditional relationships have
worked modern relationships have not and
you know they're going to argue that the
women weren't happy but while the women
are on antidepressants more than ever
today
I've realized that
your channel among other channels have
actually helped and it's worked to a
certain extent where I think like to the
point where some girls when I was
stopping them like I just felt like
there was a change in the air of how
they've that's well that's what that's
what started also go subscribe to Mary's
channel the ad is in the description
title all right please please stop
watching for free
um but no that that's how what started
the channel these same people that are
saying I hate women and that all I do is
[__] on women do you know what I would
do during these shows and I haven't done
this in a while because I've just been
busy but but before a girl would be I
could see the wheels turning in her head
and I would say Hey you come back
tomorrow let's film some reaction videos
I think I could show you some stuff that
would change your perspective and it's
really empowering when women we don't
have to view ourselves as victims like
we can do whatever we want to do if we
want to go start a company and be a
multi-millionaire and not have kids you
can go do that but
but be warned that if you go that route
but I don't want you to I don't want it
to be given to you though
what like it's a say for example I want
you as a woman to reach to the top
without it being handed to you right and
when it's not handed to you that's when
I could give you your ratings because
that's how I that's how our movement
so if you are equal that's how I wanted
to be with you like I'm not gonna just
like give it give a manage props when he
was handed to him I didn't know
who's calling Charles King bro he's
handed to you RAV
you didn't you didn't fight no one for
that
you didn't do what your your ancestors
did to get that
come on bro you need to you need to
fight for what you're actually doing and
actually do it yourself don't tell me
I'm a boss babe and then when you when
you when you need problems or need help
you call this guy for to change your
tire you call this guy to come and fix
this door you call this guy to drop you
this place you want that guy to buy you
this and you say I did it by myself no
you didn't well and women we're not
happy that way we want a husband we want
to be married
and it's like you don't really need to
rocket science to figure that out but
the problem is like even in the UK we
constantly call each other partners
you don't want a partner do you want a
husband do you want a wife because those
are completely different roles
being an equal partnership and a husband
and a wife like equal partnership means
equal say where husband and wife means
submitting to your husband's Authority
women are happier that way you reckon
I think so in you mean modern day women
I think modern day woman well so I think
they've been taught to not like it so
they actually just generally don't like
it and then well some are too far gone
yeah like you need to give them an
incentive for why it's good for them
like and not just like not not good for
them sorry beneficial for them because
it's good for them beneficial for them
women don't want to make decisions all
the time it's stressful I mean just when
we go on a date you don't want a guy to
ask you where you want to eat you wanted
to tell you we're going here I'll pick
you up at this time we're less stressed
out when we do it but the problem is
women are so controlling they don't want
to do that they want control over
everything in our lives
um and when it comes to incentive I mean
let's be honest the incentive is to
leave all the reaction channels will
tell you to leave all the incentives
were like you're paid to leave it's
unfortunate and that's why that's why I
harp so hard on the laws that's why I
harp so hard on the child custody law
like that's why I harp so hard on
marriage it's not because I don't
believe in marriage it's not because I
don't think marriage is a good thing for
society it's because those laws ruin
Society
it changes the way that me and you
interact because if me and you are if me
and you are married and you get paid or
and I get paid to leave and you are only
given money to stay then you're always
going to be pleased like trying to
trying to
get me to you're always going to be
trying to make me happy all the time
I realize women cap like there are a lot
of couplers so I'll give you an example
here like this Brave old yeah we are
equal
to when you see a woman's rule nature
pill like I'll give you an example here
last night yeah I'm walking through the
alley to get to my house it's a dark
alley yeah I'm walking with my hood up
because it's cold yeah please believe
there's a woman walking through I don't
know why you're walking foot this time
in that year but she's walking through
the alley because she's she she's fully
entitled to yeah but that's the only
time I get the true feminine nature from
them so I get the excuse me
excuse me
smile everything bro
bro you can't fraud me bro because on
the High Street it's I don't want to
stop for you yo you know you know how to
be a lady yeah and and use that feminine
nature of yours about
they got me you don't want to put it out
obviously I'm not I don't think I'm
scary but and you know what else I think
the women like we shouldn't be empowered
to make decisions that hurt us later
because a lot of times women we act and
I and I've absolutely done it where I'm
mad no you should be able to but I mean
you should be able to no wait something
like like okay
I there have been times in relationships
where I I have acted like angry right
and I've maybe been spiteful or I
haven't done like things that I'm proud
of right and I think everyone has had
that happen to them right where you're
angry in argument whatever but we're in
a society where we reward women
for doing things out of spite for doing
things out of anger and that's my
problem is it's like we shouldn't be
okay it's like and I know this is
kind of weird to compare like women to
children in a way but it's like if you
Empower a child to
um give them a treat every time they
have a temper tantrum
it's like are you is that really kind to
that child is that really nice to that
child I'm not saying women are the same
as children but [__] we act like it
sometimes and it's not it's not to hate
on women but it's like wait do you hate
do you hate women because you talk do
you hate the child because you told a
child it's wrong to give you a candy no
if you do a temple time no no it's not
wrong and that's and that's my problem
is they say like calling out this stuff
is is wrong and then they'll get at me
and they'll say oh well where are your
Solutions and I say and they say well
you're single too and the my issue is
that it's like they've never watched
wife school which is talking about you
know building like becoming like
figuring out the skills that you need to
have to be a wife and so like I'm doing
like next week guys forget this this
woman she makes it sound so boring bro
it's just wise school and just I'm
teaching you how to be a wife listen if
you watch wives school that is some of
the most entertaining thing I've seen on
the internet graph literally
you better click in that if you want to
be entertained bro don't play with me
that's Entertainment there that is good
production no it's really good that's
why that's one of my favorite pieces of
content that I've made I know like they
don't listen but they don't they don't
see it they don't see the vision and
they don't and again they don't realize
like what they stand for and genuinely I
think that some of the people on the
left some of these reaction channels
stand for evil and they don't realize
that they don't know but the [__] that
they're pushing is evil and like
especially like they were calling you
guys slaves Mass like that is evil that
is an evil thing to say to someone I
don't know and yet they will they will
die on the guise of like be having some
moral superiority and they will attack
me because I haven't got the means to
attack them yet bro but bro if you
subscribe bro you think man is gonna
send for me and I'm not gonna tell them
I'm not gonna light up the internet bro
fat boy and and and and and funny man
don't play with me bro
don't play with me RAV you get me
literally bro oh every time I think
about these oh my God
I don't think I'm losing sleep though
all right listen sleep for you guys
freaking guys okay what are you at I
really hope you're at 600
569. bro you look dumb make it five well
six five six sixty nine jeez
a six thousand nine hundred nine nine
thousand six six
hundred nine hundred hey sorry
I really am done listen
six
hundred and ninety thousand subscribers
I
guys he works really hard he works
really hard go subscribe to his channel
we're really I really want to get him to
a thousand subs tonight like that was
the whole point of me doing this stream
it really it really wasn't even to go
after like I genuinely do believe the
things we're talking about with the
reaction channels but genuinely I just
wanted to bring attention to how
talented Amiri is and how much he's been
working they know this and and I really
I really just think you guys should
subscribe all you have to do is hit the
at in the title and hit it and it's the
fresh prince of zamanda Zamunda zabunda
zabunda and
um
[Music]
yo listen
ah 50 000 subscribers
I'm going to bring
Andrew Tate and tutorial shooter here
I'm Gonna Run them up I'm gonna pay for
their flights at 49 000 subscribers I'm
going to turn it out for a month
yep
I think I'm gonna film The First
podcast listen hey what am I doing yo
guys
um so on my channel
I'm gonna be doing a fine a financial
podcast bro
you look let me know if if you are
feeling that kind of Vibes I'm gonna do
a financial podcast
where I'm talking about how to make
money and how to keep it
and how to make it grow
you get it that's what I'm gonna be
doing on my podcast I'm saying no one
can't tell me I'm trying to cancel this
one no bro I'm making a financial
podcast on how to make money
how to keep it and how to make it grow
I'm Gonna Get The Best Day traders in
here famous YouTubers up in here I'm
gonna get the best
um mergers and Acquisitions the best
contractors the the best brokers I'm
gonna get bro oh
[Music]
I'm going to get the financial Authority
up in here
I'm going to get a
um ahead of a website of brokerage up in
here bro
584 you're at sometimes I think that's
16 more 16 more 16. I'm gonna get ICT up
in here I'm gonna get Roger Banks up in
here are you dumb bro do you know who I
am bruv
rogate CEOs of companies up in here
I'll get your favorite artist the person
who signed them up in here
I'll get the owner of the big four
companies record labels up in here Brad
I'll get the head of BBC News up in here
you look gonna ask me ask the ask the
board yourselves
how much you think they're fake news I
will ask the questions and I would ask
them from you not
I think I'm playing bro this is the
crazy thing if your content was good you
wouldn't need someone with 1.44 million
Subs to push you well you said that
someone in the chat but it wrote a
channel started last week no no but this
is what but like they don't talk about
how did you get someone with 1.44
million Subs attention
I don't know but we started last week
there's a reason why we're allowing you
to say what you want bro
look at me
89 we're out we're almost to 600. yeah
bro you think I can give a damn what
what what what
emat has the same RAV let's go to emad
yeah bro you don't think I'm you think
you must think I'm flipping
some some weird bra up in there bro
let's go to emac bro let's hold e man up
bro
how can I hook this bear up bro
listen you lucky I can't hook you up
right now watch some hot you up bro
thank you
I'm gonna do it on my phone
if you all if your comment emad is still
there by the time I hot you up watch
where is this e-mat
where is he
there we go
hey hey who's chatting crap
look who's chatting crap
look look at him bro I can't even make
this up bro look my man has no no videos
four subscribers
bro I started last week and I got bro
come on bro alarm me bro allow me bro
you joined 16th of May 2015 roll please
RAV don't bro come on bro
your your work you're just like a
reviewer bro you watch content roll that
people like us make bro don't chat
chat baloneybath
like you could entertain more than 10
people for how long we've been on
already come on bro stop playing bro
chair let's see what you're at 5 94.
you're almost to 600.
listen when you all got time after
subscribe to emad bro he needs more
subscribers to be talking to people like
most shut them up
yo why do I need some of a 1.5 4 million
to promote bro listen
this is this is this is we work together
do you want to not promote me
then you look could say oh [__] I'll
promote did she don't promote her
peoples yeah you know what I say how are
you gonna win no you can't win how are
you gonna literally can't win you don't
promote me then it's like oh you don't
and you promote me it's like why do you
need to promote me bro do you like do
you like tell O'Shea do Jackson about
how much weirdo brace he promoted on
this thing all the time bro
come on get out of here bro you can't
tell us what to do bro
so
it's not even top chat we're paying a
hundred dollars to say it bro
it's like well but I'll make dugging
them and get to working on start legoing
man out of here no bro don't play with
me bro
before I do it myself brav
you read this already yeah yeah
we should go wait go back to reacting to
the clip
make it full screen
the small percentage of guys to commit
because if you find this guy attractive
a lot of other women probably do too why
would he commit when he can just bang a
bunch of chicks let's put all the 20 on
an island somewhere and we're all live
happier you would go to the island
subscribe to my channel Jordan
[Laughter]
I think that Jordan come on bro from
back in oh come on bro I look at guess
right now and be like bro hang tight
Jordan bro Hank attack boom boom boom
Hank attack them in there Hank them in
there I totally forgot about that we had
the mics in the kitchen I kind of like I
kind of like that shot yeah I mean it's
kind of dope like it was like the exact
time I'm gonna say a fresh and fit like
their background thing like you're on
this shoulder I kind of I kind of missed
this like set of the room like it just
felt a little bit more cozy
it looks so much better now so I'm like
not even comparing but I kind of miss
like this feel because I know what you
mean Pro but you've moved on you're
getting nostalgia
yeah yeah
there's something about like there's
something about like the come up that's
just like you can't appreciate it when
you're in it but like when you're
actually everything's moving it's just
such an exciting time the journey
estimation yeah yeah it's just something
like
there's just nothing like like to come
up like you just can't replicate it
I've lost weight around my face too it's
like bro all these people why I'm all
right
sorry okay I don't know what I was gonna
say I was gonna say you're still on your
come up to be fair until the whole world
knows about you we're not stopping
Mr B says like how much subscribers
above there's enough people in like
there's that he would say uh you you
only come up we'll see we'll see
you see how pleasant she could be guys
we'll see
I didn't know they said they said they
say I'm the meanest I'm the meanest who
says they all say I'm sorry whoever says
that don't watch you no I know that's
the thing all I do is just it's like
they didn't even watch a full stream is
this me just dunking on women does it
sound me like be this is one of our most
viewed streams bro I guarantee you if
people didn't come at her she would have
said oh oh and in fact after this
podcast she said she enjoyed herself
yeah she wanted to come back it wasn't
until the comment section that's what
happens
in the comment section though we can't
tell we're even they're even coming at
us and we're the flipping
come on you want to go to the eye and
only that if you take away the 20 of the
guys and put them on the island then
there'll be a new 20 of guys that
I'll just jump dropping gems there was
that someone else's talking points this
is back this is this is before undertake
Pearl was talking about the stuff before
Andrew take before you not even know who
he was before he went on fresh and fit
this episode had already aired
so I'm not interested exactly let
everyone get a chance man so you you
always want the top you can't settle
settle
settle for what you like it's like lower
your expectations I don't think that's
that's I don't think that's a hot take
but
Alex
come on bro oh yeah he's two subscribers
away from 600. he's two guys go
subscribe sorry Listen by the way this
guy in the corner hey yeah this guy here
Alex Bro
my guy
but come on bro what how was my take off
I said 20 if you take 20 of the top guys
and put them on an island then there
will just be another 20 the lower twenty
percent next there will be the new top
guys
or the girls would just go to the island
with the top 20 guys is bruv you can get
a settling 2023
men
from your personal experience do you
know these young women to be settling
bro for the average men they look like
fives and fours and sixes bro remember
Kevin Cameron Samuel says exclusive
because everyone will just say seven bro
you're blameless six
I'm blatantly a six
or five or I think I'm a five that's
what I'm trying to say bro average bro
what's wrong with being average bro
there's nothing wrong still be rich and
still enjoy your life so doesn't mean
ugly that's they always mistake it for
it's like ugly
um no I wouldn't say I wouldn't say no I
know no I'm saying like that's what
women always like mistake fives for like
they think it's an insult no bro I'm I
think I think I'm a five six because
I look all right
I have what 600 subscribers
you know like I'm not like huge like
mics
um
I'm not super wealthy yet
bro I'm being realistic about
to play the play the video you're
dropping gems what very good I don't
think it's the hot take to so so I guess
my opinion on this is a bit more nuanced
than that yes everyone
[Music]
it on right
yeah it happened as you know
expectations that can vary and sometimes
it can be a bit ridiculous so but I
don't think that's a bad thing I
actually actually enjoy the hustle I
don't think it's a hot take to tell
women it's that hey you should you
should settle for less you should settle
for the average expect I think it's your
job as a man to be that that top person
you're either a beta or bro you see
a successful man inside inside of this
in the dating game because only a man
that's winning will say that
I will tell you I'm not necessarily
winning I could be doing better but you
know and I I think I'm fine watch the
destruction bro do you think Alex is
here chatting [__] about oh oh you
destroyed me bro what should I destroyed
Alex bro what are you talking about
[__] I think it's your job as a man to
be that that top person you're either a
beta or you're a successful man inside
inside of this in the dating game
because only a man that's winning will
say that
I will tell you I'm not necessarily
winning I could be doing better but you
know and I I think I'm far from my Beta
I just that's just my my nature are you
virgin
no see you so you're winning then
because you're in the higher perspective
you're in the smaller percentage of men
that's actually been sexually this was
this summer is going to kill us this is
going to kill us this summer it's hot
here too I do quite well there you go
no wait wait it doesn't it doesn't favor
you to change it maybe like 50. but I
think it's it's more about like the
attitude though I think it's more like
because when you when I say I do quite
well that I probably go out more than
you I probably put in more time and
energy into understanding the game than
you probably had more experiences that
have affected my dating experience know
these people so people act like you know
it just happens it takes work and I'm
gonna keep working on it you're right
there is a group there is a group of men
that like are addicted to Corn right
they just play video games they're not
working on themselves and they have bad
results and you don't really feel bad
for them for having bad results but on
the other hand you have women that are
super overweight asking for a guy that
makes six figures and like you don't see
that type of male delusion wow well you
actually do see some of that because I
know sunburnt then I just got back from
vacate that was so summer a lot of gamer
boys with very poor social skills that
think they're entitled to you know top
shelf women like but being real do you
really feel like it's at this in fact
you came back from America
I didn't go to America this summer
yeah I went I went to be I went to
Iceland with my family it was okay yeah
yeah it was okay yeah either just come
up so sunburned oh my God it was so hot
you see him sweating this guys it's
gonna it's gonna be just as hot this
summer it's gonna be horrible I'm right
I mean it's protests differently that
that guy gets shut down it's
embarrassing yeah that's that's what I'm
saying like like men are faced with
reality quick yeah women aren't because
we lie to each other that guy's not
happy yeah and then we and then we have
movements like you know [__] shaming
right fat phobic we have all these
movements to like cushion us yeah and
don't get it twisted I have my
frustrations with women as well like I
think in a casual dating game that was
definitely
um expectations are quite high and I
think personally a lot of women don't
understand how to have a healthy casual
relationship I think people mix up with
that you agree with my point Alex please
sentimental sentimentality and that's
why they get played by the same guys
because these guys know you want a
connection you're saying you're a big
girl but you know when they mess with me
they're like oh why aren't you texting
me at night because we're a college
relationship I'm not gonna kiss good
night you can have a healthy casual
relationship that's that's my view yeah
and I've yeah absolutely definitely it
just takes majority you just have to be
transparent be transparent be mature
um yeah I do hear this it's like you
useful casual relationship but is that
what you want to push
you know what I mean like
like but for women no that's no he likes
that yeah that's what I said literally
he's winning so why would you want to
change the way it is if you're winning
if you're the top 20 man and your
machine girl day in day out you don't
want it to change why would I want the
system to change if if I'm if I'm
winning
if I'm my only fans go and I'm getting
all this money and I could somehow
convince a man to lock me down after
I've done all the the wholeness you're
winning you have no reason to want to
change it why would you want to change
it guys subscribe to his channel it's in
the description
and the title hit the at hit the ad at
605. oh jeez
E
I don't think women are biologically
predispositioned for it like
statistically they're not they're not
and and I think as a guy you're like
yeah you can have a healthy casual
relationship because that's a man's
point of view and some and some girls
can do it but like in my experience
typically like they've just had a bunch
of sex to the point they don't care
anymore but in my experience every time
we orgasm is that triple
what
that women have sex to the point they
don't care anymore
every girl
you didn't say women you said no I
didn't I said that's like man's point of
view and some and some girls can do it
but like in my experience typically like
they've just had a bunches yeah in my
experience I said in my experience with
Dave just don't try to do that
no I was just making sure I was making
no I know
I know I didn't say that no no no
every every girl I know that like
genuinely every girl I know that
um like sleeps around a lot or just like
doesn't get attached during sex
it's really just because she slept with
too many dudes but she wasn't like that
at the beginning
you don't think that's true
yeah I think slots are made I don't
think they're born 100 million percent
like I don't think any girl is born like
banging a bunch of dudes and happy I
think that I think there's in fact
there's so many girls that
I've
been so upset that I've had to
cross them off the list of potentials
because of how nice their personality is
or
oh but they're banged many people yeah I
mean it's like why did you have to
why did you have to go there and do that
to yourself
cruel cruel too much man you know you
just be going on a first date and then
you gotta be like yo did you go out with
my dinner I'll be like yo how did how
you're more famous than me bath
it's like no I can't do this
scary
it's to the point they don't care
anymore
you don't like my school silences do you
I enjoy them
every time it makes them think you're a
wise
not not you have to do the
um
you might you might be right
foreign
every time I'm saying early on so so
girls typically Bond more with the first
couple of guys they slept with yeah okay
and and so and they tend to do that
through orgasm yeah
we can't talk about that stuff without
laughing
you know what can I say something yeah
these girls here
did you know that they have a podcast a
sex podcast
no I didn't know that yeah they got
Dirty Talk podcast which ones all of
them
I don't know if the the I don't know if
the Asian ones involved as well
yeah the two on the right on the couch
they've got a podcast
no I didn't know that
um does this give demonic Vibes I saw
this girl that said my podcast was
demonic I was like wow this would be
rude what hey there's some girl because
you want women to get married you're
demonic
the internet is undefeated plan to be
able to be able to do this so they tend
to be older they tend to be like over 27
yeah they don't necessarily have a high
body count but they're normally very
educated they have that they're
independent they have their own lives so
my my ideal woman is actually what a lot
of people would say is the woman that'll
give them the most stress because these
guys say oh well this he basically wants
to wife he is hoes woman thinks she won
the show yeah you can run the show I'll
see you once every two weeks
Alex is single as of now
as as of this video
or you know women who are still I wonder
if I should call him and ask him no I
think he's single but with some other
dude cool you can see him in the two
weeks I'm not seeing you you know and
and if you think like that that's called
frame though because I have nothing to
prove and when we want to escalate the
relationship then there are a lot of
ways that you can build closeness but
I'm just I'm just someone where I know
what what when what I'm doing is
building a more intimate relationship
than our relationship is actually at so
you're the sad guy no I'm the main guy
actually no in terms of like if she's
got a husband a partner and you see you
see her in between the relationships
you're like the side guys no she this is
not my woman this is just women who are
around maybe they may be seeing multiple
guys I don't ask because I don't care
because so you're winning in the game
then casual relationship in the Casual
game it's a mindset though that's the
thing I'm asking if it's I'm saying are
you winning yes he knows where I'm going
he knows what I'm going with this I do
all right so wouldn't it wouldn't it be
like
um bad for you if the game was to change
and women to stop having casual sex with
you counterproductive such a good point
I don't think I caught that then see
because you're saying that he's saying
this because the game it would be bad
for him if the game changed exactly he's
winning yes oh I didn't catch that do
you get it so why would I want as a man
that's
hitting these educational goals that
that want to be boss babes and I I could
have sex no but that's like what the
guys do they say they like these things
but you know they don't no they don't
because they don't wife yeah they don't
work like that yeah they don't wipe them
so they'll they'll say oh I like this
this and yes no you don't you don't bro
you don't read like you like you love
the fact like that one yeah you know you
love the game yeah because you could
smash every week every time you go to
the pub bro and there will be enough
people in there to be like yeah we agree
with that like we're all independent
like we could do what we want if I want
to take you home tonight then it's my
choice I wanted to do bro come on bro
you're winning in that why would you
want it to change
it's so sweet I got him bro would not be
counterproductive if woman was to stop
having casual sex yes I guess so right
so you're not right so you're not you're
not advised to give um advice the right
advice because because you're telling
girls to sleep around benefit to you
exactly so you didn't know Pearl the
Pearl back then knew yeah the Pearl back
then but it can also benefit them as
well you see it can also bro come on bro
how does it benefit a girl to sleep
around bro
in the long run like if we're being real
honest with each other here
how does it benefit her if she's she's
slept around bro and then you say man
hates women bro
you like to say I'm the one that hates
women bro when I'm saying bro
I'm gonna check the chat bro I want to
see what you don't think wrong because
there's no way that ELO disagree with me
on this one Ralph
yeah if I'm
people
yeah
you're right
yeah you're right Ralph you're right no
I know I'm not tweaking bro I know I
wasn't tweaking
because
like even me and Alex Bro me and Alex
are calm bro me and Alex are cool bro
that's one of my like my guys well I
like Alex you get me but we're allowed
to have a disagreement and still be cool
that's what happens when I say we're
we're widening the Overton window as to
what views are allowed on our channels
bro what are you allowed to say and be
comfortable with saying you know I'm
trying to say that kind of feeling where
you like you could say your point and
then someone else has a point and like
you might get to edit by the end of it
you might get to a little like a little
um
a medium where you think you know what
he might be a bit right about that or he
might be a bit you know what I'm saying
I don't really disagree with that but at
least we're talking about it and we're
discussing it and we're trying to change
stuff
is that is that something wrong now
do you would you prefer to see me in in
in
um McDonald's
serving serving you
serving your burger and your fries is
that what you think my position should
be
instead of doing this why enjoy and I
love
come on bro man man it's not
come on bro you can't it can't do that
bro I'm literally telling you I am
literally promising you look I'm
promising you look
yeah
I am promising you lot
I have creative control on my channel
RAV
so what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna make make my channel as fun
and as entertaining
as it can be
and I'm gonna make it grow grow and do
bigger and better things the bigger and
better my channel gets bro because we're
working on resources right now so I'm
trying to say that's what we do we don't
want to say we don't over extend our
hand bro we do what we do what we can
and then we hope that our viewers and
our supporters could do the rest bro
because that's how YouTube works
we work hard so you feel like you could
work hard as well do you know it's one
of the worst things bro like even from
when I was coming up doing my little
things and my jobs and that out there
you see there's nothing worse than when
you work hard and someone that you're
working with ain't working as hard as
you bro you don't feel like working as a
hard you know but if someone's working
hard next to you and you're working you
feel like yeah where
we're both putting in and you know it's
working like we're getting places so I
don't want to be [__] up you know I'm
saying don't be playing with me bro you
know what I'm saying what is that what
is the most conducive to building
families uh stable emotional
relationship yeah yeah and so like
that's why you see 50 of women over 30
being single and childless and then you
have the least happy group of women are
45 that make over 50 000. out there in
the pub having sex brother and it ain't
got no time for not being in the house
looking after Imaginary Kids that they
ain't got
and then when they're all 30 now they
want I I
um iaf and you know I'm saying they want
to inject themselves with with
um
hormones and stuff to make themselves
pregnant when they easily just open
their legs and and kept it open
at 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 20. all
them years you could have just kept it
open and God would have just blessed you
with it just by the the the the the the
um the benefit of a man just leaving it
in there let me just
you know I'm saying and do a little
extra work and leave it in there and now
by God's grace
you have a you
now you gotta go through all left right
and do this and go appointment this and
that to try and get a youth now
why it's unnecessary
the club ain't going nowhere
ain't nothing special up in the club
ain't nothing special up on these grams
ain't nothing special about these
these only fans things bro there's
nothing special about it bro you think
do you honestly think
you're in the same category
are only fans girl that's made a million
do you think I would rate you the same
or more than a girl that done hard work
as I don't know
a loyal son went to college uni and they
only got half a million
you got a million they got half a
million who do you think I'm rating more
now who do you think Society rates more
I got more money than you you you're
just looking for clout you know you
ain't Up On My Level
how did you get that though
that should be the new thing we're
bringing out for people how but how did
you get that
that's the new response we should have
them for them do you know how annoying
it will get them
yeah you ain't gotten that and I paid
for my own how about how did you get
them
yeah I got my own yard but how did you
get them
even man them bro
you you want to do crime and and and be
on the wrong side of the law
anyone tell me about what did you do and
bro how did you get that though
I'm moving equal equal rights equal less
for everybody how did you get though
so I'm saying jokes in your mouth
I mean playing
let's get back in this dollars per year
that's the least happy group of women so
casual relationships leave women unhappy
in the long term if they don't have a
family yeah but that also depends on the
mentality of the people around them the
men at the time so a woman you can
consider quite Pious now you could go
back 10 years and she's not someone
who's acting completely wildling out oh
yeah part of it is like the the society
birth control change dating forever yeah
yeah that too birth control did change
in a way you can't go back absolutely
but yeah I personally I don't think
casual sex is is the worst thing but it
has to be approached with care it's not
something you do carelessly this idea
that yeah I just sleep around check
whoever you want whatever is is the
reason that a lot of these girls are out
here getting played and Crossing two
things casual and intimate and I don't
even know but I know that and getting
them
them herpes and them kind of things
there and all of them problems and that
and unwanted pregnancies and stuff brav
foreign like oh we're just having fun
like no this is serious bro
kids come from from this casual thing
that you're talking about RAV
women
pair one bro they actually with the Bros
how much girls
that would start off the relationship
like yeah we could just smash nothing
not nothing serious we could keep it
casual they get one little thing
and now they're in love
they're in love now fully invested I'm
like wait hold on a minute
bro didn't I tell you
how we're gonna lay it down like how
Alex is saying right now like Alex is
saying right now oh but you have to be
very aware we have to be know what we're
telling no no you have to know maybe in
the know yeah but Alex how many girls
smash you and after they smash you now
they're whipped bro bro if any man is in
the chat right now and that has happened
to them bro bro let me know bro or am I
just bugging by myself brav
a gal said I'm on this thing casually
only yeah I'm with you on that and after
you you lick it down yeah
of course after you you know what I'm
saying
you rest it down here now they're fully
in love bro
I want the man them I'm gonna oh I'm
gonna look at the chat right now and see
Beth comment wanna know if I'm bugging
up by myself bro I'm bugging if I'm
bugging let me know I'm bugging bro
foreign
yeah
you might know bro
yeah you gotta know bro you might know
bro you know bro you know I'm a captain
Ralph
you know I am not lying RAV
yeah you know I'm not lying
um
mm-hmm
where's po I'll pose in the um
the kitchen fixing me a sandwich man
and don't tell her I said that you know
we better take this out bro leave this
clip out
leave this clip out
hey yo subscribe to my channel let me
see what all my subscribers I'm on let
me see my subscribers are um
this kind of thing you get me this get
this grabbing
subscribe isn't it let me see
my citizens there's someone is in there
yeah family are real ones bro keep
subscribing bro huh
oh yeah you look real ones bro
I'm not gonna lie to you bro honestly
like you should watch my channel and see
how how like grateful I was for 100
subscribers bro so you're not just
smashing that that subscribe bro I have
nothing but love for all of my
subscribers bro you know the real ones
he's at 6 17. yeah so will you make me a
sandwich
you fixed me a sandwich
I know what your tea tastes like
guys when Paul says she makes tea yeah
she really means like she's one of them
Bush People brav
like literally one of them Bush People
bro she has the strainers and that with
the bush and smelling like cow food in
that like bro I'm not involved man
what did you make me Ralph
oh I smell cheese
um
oh salmon in that
hmm
the dog's gonna be pissed off
[Music]
oh
hmm
that's some good stuff well
we're selling salmon and cream cheese
and
salad
a lot of Mercy
let's get back to this
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
hot second
um
okay so guys as you know who wants to
know what ish looks like everyone in the
chat put a one in the chat if you want
to know what ish looks like let's go so
guys send donations so we can get a
camera next month so we're trying to
save up for the end of next month to get
Isha camera it's good looking guy I know
you guys want to know what he looks like
drum roll please we're trying yeah okay
so beef 20 Super Chat thank you we do
not have beef because you are subscribed
um Trevor Lane dude got shot in the
armpit um
oh yeah it isn't even settling it's
going for a man who's actually checking
for you who can match you you attract
what you are not what you want cheesy
May women believe that men's experience
on social media is the same as theirs
they don't live in reality and that's
and they're not required to ask them
white the white lady in Black if she
dates black men
hey yo the old JPC look
the the the chat guys
we've evolved
Stephen Pierre Jerome um the 20 of men
are highlighted in women's minds or
where the other 80 are almost invisible
um you only see them when you need
something you want or desire Army D do
not say that
when she needs when she needs her Tire
done she knows your number
she needs groceries she knows your
number
she needs to go on a date to feel better
about herself she knows your number
a new a new movie came out she knows
your number
she ain't got no money is the last day
of the month she knows your number
I want no scrubs
you see that bush thing
show them the bush thing I put I put
um mint and mint tea
cow feed nuts
I think it's good
I think it's very good the only thing
you got going for you is that it tastes
like mint it does it's good I'm gonna
smell that mint male version of
hypergamy is a nice body and a great
attitude and that Indian woman is fine
and Mary D another 10 super chat Jin oh
God guys I think see guys
the the comments did care about her as
well they gave her props as well names
Jen Ricky or Michelle my mother had
three boys she explained many times they
asked where issues rip
look
the the they're like getting some
cameras on each other like what happened
there so like
don't worry about it you know
that women earning more will bring it up
in marriages and hold it over the man's
head
um finds Sebastian Shaw the voice in the
corner please stop you will keep
inflating other countries with the UK
and you have an issue with classism big
link to black people's fool cheesy Mae
uh Jeezy May a man doesn't care about
how much money a woman makes but I
actually thought you made your come up
from dunking on black people
I swear that panel's not black people
and we'll talk down to men they don't
look up to find Sebastian this is one of
the most popular shows like one of one
of them
sha women need to stop moaning UV now
got the power of your body and there's
no more blaming us for potentially being
a piece of crap you can choose please
Choose Wisely Jeezy May women want men
who are experienced and desirable if a
guy told a girl he was a virgin she
wouldn't be interested in sex with him
for lack of experience de prequel advice
for single poppies to phone Pierre
Stephen Pierre Jerome Society lets us
women use the excuse I was young and
stupid as a get out of jail free card
guys from the time they were born are
held accountable as grown men
um w-r-y-d-d-a no after 35 you are
Undateable because by that time you have
too much life experience and you're
stuck in your ways and you're unmoldable
refund md1 hey Pearl wanted to send you
a question for your knock at this level
of super chats anymore I was just about
to go into that
so have do you think your
super chats that you read
do you think they had any influence on
your views
or do you or do you think you all you
stole all your views from other people
from other content creators
um
I don't think Super chats had a lot
maybe a little but no not much
I would say it's like parsley like you
hear the ideas from content creators
then you look in the real world to see
if it matches then you might look at
studies to see if it matches too and
then that's yeah that's kind of so when
these content creators come out with
these like sayings do they want
themselves to be promoted or the same
itself but are they trying to fix the
problem or they're trying to promote
themselves
credit police bro
you know I just realized on YouTube it's
like all these men it's like there's so
much credit like oh I came up with that
idea I came up with that idea like I'm
so tired of the credit police
it's like okay nobody owns ideas
do you think Elon Musk is whining that
competitors also were trying to make an
electric car
do you think he's saying oh oh I make
better electric no he just does his
thing you know what I mean and so when
people whine about credit it's just
because they're not doing good to be
honest they're doing good they wouldn't
care yeah
um and typically they weren't the first
one typically the same creators that
whine about credit someone else is
whining where there it is cut like
other people are saying they gave them
their ideas like the same person I think
he needs to come across more what okay
do you know what I mean so like
all right if I'm if I'm person C and
they're saying A and B gave like Pearl
stole the ideas from person A and B okay
well
the same people person A and B other
people are whining that they stole all
their ideas from D C and F so and so
it's actually like the dumbest [__]
because I'm like okay one you can't
copyright an idea and does Einstein
every time we talk about Einstein's
ideas does Einstein roll in his grave
and say I need my credit it's like no no
the people that and I had I had a
certain content creator I want their
names that was trying to accuse me of
not getting like it's like then you give
them credit and you don't give them the
credit in the way they want the credit
and then it's like oh well you gave me
credit in this way I need credit in that
way forgot about him and
and then if you don't give me credit in
the way I want credit now I need to run
to the Internet it's just like this is
what I've realized people will never be
happy like one time someone was whining
at me for not giving them credit and I
was like I gave you credit at this point
they're like well you didn't tag me you
didn't do the tag button
and it's like there will never be happy
they're just looking to whine and it's
literally just projection because their
content's not doing well typically and
if this isn't even directed at one
person to be honest because I can think
of like five people that will whine
about credit
and it's not even just me like everyone
whines about credit with people and
again the people that whine about credit
have not created a good enough product
if your ideas were that good then you
would have created a better product they
know this
they notice
that's why talking about it is so fun
for them
because you've got nothing else to do
that's Entertainment the credit please
well
what I learned
is that to be successful in YouTube you
either have to make content or copy
someone that's making content
if you're gonna get at us
for making a podcast
because we saw someone else make a
podcast but ours is completely different
though
host different setup different
who you bring on a different
we talk about different
no no no no no like leeway
but you go onto YouTube and type in a
challenge and see how much people copy
publish people
you go onto YouTube and you see how much
people copy other people on certain
things there's guys that literally watch
your stream and cut
and then paste straight onto YouTube
literally directly they cut and put
straight onto YouTube your exact content
they have nothing to say to them
because that's what they do
they cut your stuff and put it on their
Channel well and people forget like they
don't talk about inspiration
like great ideas
each other you
inspired by
honestly nobody's done as much of a mix
of content as me nobody
like I've done Street talks
I've done one-on-one interviews I've
done a live show
I've done panel shows
I've done a dating show
you've done challenges challenges yeah
you've done more Vlogs yeah yeah Vlogs
morning talk like nobody don't like
you can learn too much bro
give them too much
I think the thousands of videos
thousands
literally thousands you look at just
look at this look at this
we'll get there we'll get there we'll
get there
Pearl's Channel Pearl
Pearl let's get to this
let's get to this bro what does that say
why they hate him
what does that say guys 7 000 videos and
the same people the same people will
whine will wine and accuse me of buying
views and buying subs and if they took
two seconds to look at my channel
they'll see I've posted more than anyone
else you could say that's a cheat code
but I played a win baby I play to win
but you oh this is easily checked on
I just watched our group watch watch out
about five views who buys views bro
or buy subscribers and you're seeing how
we're raising subscribers on my channel
that has none you think we can't just
put repost post stuff and then just
start a channel when it's already a
hundred thousand people following
oh you look just cuckoo bro cuckoo for
Cocoa Puff spread
thank you
know watching it bro you gotta see him
on there bro this from here is where the
shutdown happens Ralph
playing Ralph
you're not play too much
playing too much bro
you are seeing this yourself bro
you're seeing this yourself bro you're
seeing this RAV
you let RC in it send you a tick tock
milk at the movement husband requirement
300 pounds asking for yearly honeymoons
and she does know housework dear
actually hold on you don't need to see
this as well
bro for the weirdo ones bro listen
home
videos
shorts
lives
they took down one of your lives
I go in too hard on some people
um
why not
what was I Wagner
who was I going after on that live
listen I go off the people on my lives
bro
so it's like liable to get taken out of
but make sure you see it before it gets
taken down
oh the album preached one oh was that
one was
Oh I thought that's who you meant he did
a reaction to Adam preach
no but I'm saying which one I kind of
remember
the year when we want a life partner
with a low mileage we find the Queen of
Hearts when we want a good time
regardless of mileage we get with the
Queen of Clubs and diamonds and Spades
simps dogs and feminists
oh
see what I'm saying about your old
school super chess Pub yeah they were
though oh my man said you want to get
with a quick bro Queen of Hearts so if
you want to get with a queen of clubs
clubs oh
I wonder who that is I can send them
five dollars right now when we want a
life partner with a low mileage we find
the queen of hearts and we want a good
time regardless of mileage we get with
the Queen of Clubs and diamonds and
spans simps dogs and feminists ruin
Marriage Partners dc-081 ladies you need
to shape up because robots
yearly honeymoons and she does know
housework dear when we want a life
partner with a low mileage we find the
Queen of Hearts when we want a good time
regardless of mileage we get with the
Queen of Clubs and diamonds and Spades
simps dogs and feminists ruin Marriage
Partners
dc-081 ladies you need to shape up
because robot women with artificial
wombs Eternal Youth and beauty and
customizable looks aren't very far off
Polo Dart day there's a big difference
between what a man likes to see and what
he wants to have for Life black pain bro
do you know what pills podcast yesterday
there was a guy on the podcast bro that
said if men and women were separated
uh that women would survive
man said if you separate men from women
the women would survive and the men
would not survive
I was working but I was on my way out I
had to stop and interject in that whole
podcast and be like bro you are cuckoo
for Coco puffs brav go and watch that
live from yesterday after RAV I need a
crazy
um Panther the only Fan's economy is
built off the decline in male mental
health and there are women selling
thousands of dollars of their used bath
water to these kinds of men step
I need to go back to your own
lives and what read the super chats is
what I need to do
my own live super chats were dope dope
bro
this is when men
felt like they could finally have a say
so they were just saying it yeah they
were I would feel bad sometimes
[Applause]
maybe like post-wall
I'm like I'm sorry guys I'ma still read
them though you know what I mean
yeah the question for the woman would
you be okay if the guy slept with
someone else until you were ready to
sleep with him that's actually a decent
question uh
yeah
the UK Economist asked me don't let me
I'm just being honest you know
because
sometimes I just
would you not want to know
I wouldn't want to know that's what I'm
saying like I wouldn't but I feel like
that's fair like if you're gonna ask a
guy to wait like three months or
something it's like well
but the a lot of women you know you see
when they tell you that they want you to
wait they want you to wait during that
time you know like I mean like that dude
they want you like begging for
practically when it's happening well it
depends how old you are you know what I
mean it's like a dude's been like 30
something he's not playing around with
that like
we're waiting
how long as long as you're gonna wait
for a check
I've waited as long as I've waited so
far is a year
you waited a year was she a virgin yeah
oh okay I was like I was like
she was
waiting for like you did you didn't
specify if she was a virgin or not all
right
guys guys guys you already know what I'm
gonna say
you already know what I'm gonna say
amiri's at 624 Subs I'm getting sleepy
all right I'm trying to go to bed
um but I'm not gonna do it until we get
to a thousand subscribers for a mirror
and once we get to a thousand
subscribers
we're gonna react
to Adam preach's video all right all
right they want they want us to see what
we gotta say you know what I mean
and so you guys are gonna have to you're
gonna have to subscribe to his channel
like the video I mean we're gonna I'm
trying to get you monetized
6 24. guys can we can we get to 6 35
there's there's 300 something of y'all
in the chat
it's like can we amiri's his his
channels in the title all you got to do
is click the title
click the time now you tell them in your
way
don't don't come to my channel if you're
not gonna watch my videos and show me
love breath
so if the reason why is still on that
number for the last two minutes is
because there's no one left that wants
to watch my stuff and not be no ghost
follow-up subscriber yet bro
respect stay here and watch me in your
on your favorite Channel
but if you do want to watch my stuff
and you want to see Pearl keep the one
chip challenge
you want me to make Paul say zumunda
properly
they won't do that
you want me to to make to make pearls
sit down and watch American Gangster
City of God shutters and them kind of
films there
if you want to see my podcast you want
to see only friends girls right in the
back there doing what they want
cry
don't be a [__] subscribe
you get
yeah all right let's see what these guys
are at
6 29. can we get to 6 35 I think that's
reasonable before we start the video
we'll start the video again well that's
the strategy we should have used what's
that we'll play the video when we get to
6 35. which one
like now this video so we're at 6 31
we're pausing the video
better one you know what I mean
6 31 when we get to 6 35 we're gonna
play it we're gonna play and I'll let
you know what I was thinking during
these
I wonder if anyone in the chat right now
was a osu's old school subscriber
yeah who in the chat subscribed back
then bro put in the date that you
subscribed to the channel when we start
first started watching let's see who's
the oldest man
hard I'm trying to all right I see the
oldest in the chat was
not the oldest in the age but oldest son
for the channel
no lie in evil
who is this dude he's been on the
channel forever he's one of my new
talents so he's he's with the network
now the jpt network
I blame myself bro cause I like being in
the background but bro since O'Shea Duke
Jackson why my name spread off am I
gonna make me you know that's what I say
um I'm gonna make content I'm gonna show
him I'm going to overtake him we hit 35
six so now we can play the video
we're waiting for marriage or wasting
their time sleeping with random men ice
hollafield if she sleeps around
and then makes me wait that's like me
spoiling all my other girls and deciding
to be humble and take her to McDonald's
to see if she's a gold digger
dumb man it's easy for women to make a
guy wait because there's no cost to her
meanwhile the guy is spending money on
dates with no return on investment
Brandon ocean women let alpha males and
make beta's males wait Mr Minister
respect Samuels for to for the buy dog
and die alone phrase Steven Pierre
Jerome preach Pearl good guys are often
placeholders for the guys they really
want and good guys are starting to wake
up dubman five dollars in fact bro why
are you asking who I am if you are a
true fan of just pearly things bro you
should know who I am bro we're watching
a video of me back in the days on the
same channel you're on it's like almost
a year ago now
about who's this guy oh wait guys he's
at 6 38 at 45.
at 6 45 we'll play the video
I'm sorry guys
bro get don't get on to us get on to the
guys that are not subscribing yeah it's
just a bit rude it's a bit rude
all right we're gonna refresh it
not quite
and guys we are planning on reacting to
Apple and preach Abu and Peach Avalon
Peach can you lower the video volume
did I hear that sneako return to Islam
well you know I mean return was he a
Muslim or went to Islam I don't know
yeah I heard I heard I heard mashallah
man
asked
someone says is it offensive to ask what
you like in a woman and saying what if
one with the vagina
what do I
um 6 45 we can play the video again this
is effective Super Chat and send Polo
why girls why girls think men wants to
live
wait why girls think men want to live
them it does not cross me to leave my
wife so they don't all think like that
Let me refresh and see if there's any
more also guys all the super chats are
going towards updates in the studio and
sign up for our memberships I think
we're about to turn on our members only
chat so if you want to be a part of the
members only chat you gotta sign up for
our memberships okay digital Sparks beta
white hat is sweating like he's being
interrogated by the CIA guys it's pretty
hot in here it's crazy it's it's hot we
don't have AC in the UK I don't know why
someone give him a glass of ice water
and put a fan on him Richard Alvarez
high value men are valuable because they
provide security stability and Status a
high value man should be a regular guy
with a nine to five stable job good
value and that works out this is what
changed to this change to what we
consider a high value man flaskar women
don't care about men's issues because
they don't have to until they hit the
wall and they're rescued from father
time for real from Sapien High ali um
free my dude ish get that manic camera
sorry ish
you know
you know blessing's a great guy
this um
don't mix business some pleasure guys
also we're not gonna play this video
Until amiri's Channel which is at in the
title is that it's at 6 47.
we will play the video
what should we play the video at
um 650.
five you're really too nice sixty six
fifty five
you can't mix business you know
did you know I've been robbed
yeah yeah
what
I'm gonna talk about that
no but that's what I mean like I feel
like people don't
put this on
sometimes it's it's it it humbles you
when like you know something like you
see for example you um
you helped a million old people across
the road and an old person is like oh
you don't help old people there's
something like humbling and nice by not
being the person to be like oh yeah but
I helped a million people it's just be
like you know all right whatever you
know sometimes like it's like actions do
for the talking for us
I don't care what they're doing
I wonder what they're doing right now I
was so sunburned in that
chair right I was
bruh
you see you see the cheeks
red
no not a redness the the the the the the
fat in the cheeks
like I think you've got a
like a thinner jawline now
yeah I think I've lost weight since then
wasn't you trying to though yeah
she's working guys she's working
when I'm moving on guys 55 yeah guys
guys
we'll play the video when Amiri hits 655
6 55 and I'll let you know what I was
thinking In This Moment
in this moment but I need I need your
help
I really want to get a Mary to a
thousand subscribers and then we're
gonna react to Abba and preach
we're gonna maybe even some
floche oh my gosh
um
would you call him um
would you call them people that the the
pan people bro
that that the Prospectors for gold
you're looking for gold with the shape
the shake pad
Shake pan okay
6 49 all right guys we need six more
subs on amiri's Channel The Fresh Prince
of Zamunda
I got it right right you got it right
the fresh prince of Zamunda we need six
more subscribers you say moonace
yeah there you go guys stop calling me
hi I'm not high
oh my gosh 650 five more bro it's 2 20
in the morning what do you mean hi Rob
she's tired she's been up since
playing
I still gotta go home and then come back
here early in the morning and work
you're talking about
all right you don't have to stay
I was just I forget
no it's just for me okay okay
I'm trying I'm just trying to get you to
a thousands then we can just focus on
your watch time
which which I go cover
um yeah I'll make you to watch me man
five more at 6 50 already crazy
6 53 two more they like to see you they
like to push you you know what I mean
like I think people they want to see you
grind yeah
and and and they subscribe
not only that even me I'll be sitting
down watching you be like why should I
subscribe to you
know
is he entertained
is he funny enough
should I do our charity no I don't want
you to do it for charity
Pearl is worn out by the simps
oh from dancing hair
so that's what they're saying I'm worn
out by The Sims one more sub guys The
Fresh Prince of Zamunda they stressed
you out until you you
what
bro have we got anyone from Trinidad we
got
655. look at it look it come on
come on come on shimmy you ready
Chevy
6.55 all right we're big time now we're
big time now baby big time 655 Subs on
YouTube come on 656.
oh my gosh
what are we gonna do they're killing us
all right all right let's abdomen my
monthly contribution one day-ish one day
um laurison the guy in the white white
cap tries to go against the majority it
doesn't matter what the topic is
um and then that's it hey Jack um Jess I
don't know if you can open the door back
there but maybe we could it'll actually
make it a little cooler in here because
I'm sweating too okay
um so we have some new panelists hi guys
I know you guys introduced in the
beginning
um so my question black woman
yeah like what that this is one of our
most popular panels
go through all of them
and this is kind of going back to what
we were asking earlier
when so 50 of women over 30 are single
in chocolate
you have the lowest birth rate ever
practically in human history
when should women settle and when are
their standards too high
I think their standards are too high
when it becomes
unattainable okay and
um
illogical
um as far as when they should settle
I can't answer that but with regards to
standards being too high I feel like if
something's unattained guys never trust
an Englishman that pronounces his tease
the sky was simping on this other pod
yeah
English guy who pronounced his tease bro
if he says water don't trust him
guys guys
we're 6 57. I need 6 62.
to play the video you need to say oh
guys 662 to play the video you got to
hit the fresh prince of Zamunda in the
title and click that subscribe button
we're a determined group
yeah who who inheres from Trinidad
though let me know
because
someone to try someone try to tell me
that trinidadians because I basically I
was talking about um
like most culturalism in Trinidad how
it's a bit better than London in terms
of how people would say I'm
Trinidadian as opposed to saying
why is this or is that they said the
shimmy made them barf
the hell out of this thing
yet my shimmy made them buff because it
was cringy okay good my shimmy was
really good thank you
it was supposed to be cringy RAV
oh well we're at 661 already I said 662.
yeah but you guys are killing the game
662 Subs look at that I think it's time
to get too high just by default okay
what do you guys think
I don't necessarily think her standards
are too high I think like so
I'd like to say in the UK do you oh you
they can't really see it on the screen
but do you see how low I am to the floor
if you guys look at original videos all
the furniture here is too short I like
some tall chairs
but all the furniture here is like right
next to the ground
I want to get I Miss America I miss big
trucks I miss big cars I miss babies
I miss I miss big people I even miss the
whales a little bit
I even missed the whales a little bit
go subscribe to amiri's channel
listen we have some things big over here
man I don't know what she's talking
about two people just unsubscribed
so that's good I told you I like that
y'all rude rude I said 662. we're at
660. but I'm gonna let you guys get away
with it this time because I really want
to see what happens next but next time I
promise I'm not gonna be this nice
a virgin as a woman
before you actually like before you
actually have sex with a man be thinking
about putting a ring on it and I would
always say that like
say that you realize that sex before
marriage bro like oh you're saying sex
before marriage look out they're like
what what sex before marriage what you
should be a virgin but when you when you
think about sex with with someone
like why just think about as a woman why
is your goal to have sex with multiple
people like why is that on look it my
goal was always to be you know a version
of my when I was younger anyway now
doesn't always work out like that you
know what I mean I'm human right but but
I'm saying like that's your goal and it
shouldn't be
like didn't she grow up in like a
traditional household like why is this
absurd even Alex
foreign
gives me so much joke just look at this
guy bro look at this guy bro
I did love this kitchen I did love that
kitchen
and that's the alcohol that they claimed
that we forced them to drink
yeah
I don't force anyone to drink it's the
crazy thing
I don't I don't drink like I barely
drink myself
uh oh my gosh this dude oh my gosh
this dude on Twitter
was like
oh
why do you like the one that we kicked a
girl out uh he's like you guys forced
them to drink or like why do you let
them drink and get drunk knowing they're
gonna do this is orchestrated and I'm
like boy
you think I wanted this [__] to
threaten me on my pod bro first of all
this is a flipping YouTube channel this
is not BBC yeah this is this is people
that's trying to be professional with
the camera out like boom filming a
podcast bro this is not BBC so when you
come in here you feel like home you sit
down listen do you want to drink we have
juice here we have water here we have
alcohol hair we have dinner hair we are
not your parents please drink
responsibly
now we have to force you please take a
shot don't take that much take this
little bit oh wait have you got a
medical record well you can't drink oh
no we're not here to Baby people bro
everyone has over the age of ever of
being an adult
everyone you don't bring no kids up in
there
so be responsible for your own actions
it's like go in the club and blaming the
club for you being drunk in the club RAV
and that on top of that this dude I'm
not going to name names but he
we made this long Thread about how women
shouldn't be in the manosphere
let me I'll show you his channel I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna but but I don't I
don't feel like beef in this guy because
I actually am a fan of him but he's so
hypocritical I'll let you know in five
seconds if I want to destroys us
um and the funniest part of him saying
that women shouldn't be in the
manosphere and he's always tweeting at
me like I said that divorce laws are bad
he doesn't matter you would destroy them
and the funniest thing is this person
this guy was he he [__] on all the guys
saying that for collabing with me when
he was my first collab in the manosphere
you were the first one bro I'm even
buffering to tourism also the other
thing was
this man I'm not responding to no small
YouTuber unless you come for me bro
and come for me satisfactory so I'm like
okay I'll bother to come for you bro
yeah like come on like I'm not I'm not
wasting my time yeah and then and then
this dude was like
what did he say well he's very
pro-divorce and it's rumored everyone
all of his friends say that he got
married again
and so I'm just like bro you co-host
your guests to drink alcohol yeah I
coerced how does he know that
how much guests have you had on your
podcast since the beginning of your
podcast
I don't know they just there's been
alcohol available and drinks available
at every single one of the podcasts
there's been hundreds of guests up in
here how many people have claimed we've
forced them to drink alcohol Pearl does
not just organize her Channel she does
other channels as well where they do
podcasts on that channel in the same
Studio where they have alcohol where the
people that say that we forced them to
drink alcohol
we barely even all like I barely I was
just like oh it's there if you want it I
don't even I don't push it at all
we don't need to all right they come in
hand crap sober 660. guys fresh prince
of Zamunda you need to subscribe to the
Channel I want 665 before bro today
playing again no I forget that today we
had to go come to the podcast with a
[__] husky
[Laughter]
brought a house key a full-grown husky
mouth that is what I'm talking about
like he'd be like bro who does that who
comes to a podcast with a husky dog bro
you would be surprised are we supposed
to look after the Husky while you're on
air are we supposed to let it run around
with the equipment bruh
bro if we let you know what's the back
the BTS of of you bro you you would say
listen Pearl you are a
you're a special one
to handle the madness that happens
behind the scenes and
people have no idea how much we got
going on here we got no idea
no idea guys guys
tell them
what number I'm on in order for me to
play the video we need to get amiri's
channel to 665 subscribers we're at 661.
so I need four of you to hit the fresh
prince of Zamunda And subscribe to his
channel because that's what the stream
is all about I'm willing to react to
some of the hate videos about me
but I need you guys to meet me halfway
we don't work for free and right now
amiri's channel is not monetized and we
really want to work on getting him
monetized so I need you guys to go hit
the Subscribe button on his channel I'll
tell you what though I've had 47 000
Impressions on my channel though
so do you know please believe if you
didn't subscribe today I was still going
to get subscribers I'm still gonna be
successful whoever you subscribe or not
I'm still going to be successful bro
Still Still Pearl still brav
still bruv tell them
look in the camera tell him I'm gonna
get it you're gonna what I'm a gay
you're gonna do what I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it
again
me and Paul made a song Yesterday was it
yesterday
oh yeah what song do we make oh we did
it was like it was about she has me
doing the um walking making your way
downtown oh I'm telling you bro I was
belting them out no no it was about
cheating it was like no don't tell them
bro
cause my I don't even remember how it
went that's good because my lines are
entertainment purposes only you got me
don't take just like my video that man
try to expose and say we was having sex
parties
oh yeah yeah tell them about the the
white board bro the white all the white
room parties the Whiteboard parties that
sounds bro listen you see this you see
this guy here in the middle here
he was there oh you're at 666.
he was there he was there he was crazy
I'm 26 I live in a pet house do you know
how many parties I've had all year
two
if you count the housewarming three
that you didn't count that okay two and
a half two and a half I'm 26 I live in a
pet house one with a DJ
yeah one had a DJ one did not one was
whiteboard yeah one was one it was
really only one real party one yeah but
now the equipment's too nice I told
Pearl to do a million subscriber party
and you not messed it up you little
dweebs bro you not messed it up we were
good at bro bro
[Music]
if you know what I was gonna bring for
you subscribers on the channel
I was the recruiter do you know what I
was going to bring for you guys I'm
gonna get a drink
um no I'm okay
all right guys we're at 667. we're at
667 for him I really want to get him
okay
can we get him to 700 before he comes
back I think it'd be like a fun surprise
but you guys have to hurry you have to
hurry
because my goal oh [__] this phone's
about to die
um
okay I'm going to American next month
I am going to America next month all
right
let's see yeah Paul's going away
yeah and amiri's gonna have a show
and blessings going with her
yeah blessing is going with me Africans
are going they're going to take over
America
my uh my uh amazing employees yeah yeah
you could say African my AF for amazing
employees oh no I don't I don't want the
CL
clip
yeah yeah
listen I don't know if they know but um
Africa is a continent
there's white Africans there's Arab
Africans there's black Africans there's
Indian Africans
I'm just saying
I'm just saying you go to Libya and tell
them about black Africans and they'll
tell you my friend
but no I'm saying you shouldn't be
having sex before
I'm saying you're gonna stop no no no no
I'm saying the reason why girls should
practice marriage before sex is because
the other way around disadvantage is
them it doesn't disadvantage me you see
how they think I'm doing it for myself
they honestly think I'm getting
something out of telling them to get
married
like I can't get vaginal coming out to
say that's a yeah that's a scientific
word yeah
bro I will again I'm in like I'll end
the game if every man gets their prize
bro or every girl gets their prize
literally
because I'm I'm good I could be good
with one I could be good with two I
could be good with three I could be good
before
I'm all right I could do the polygamist
here I I am completely in my zone when
you don't want us for commitment yeah I
don't I don't need it like it's not a
you know I mean it's not I'm not I don't
have to spend money on you I don't have
to be thinking about you I don't have to
do like you know what I mean so it's
worse for you if we don't have a
commitment
who's the smart guy brav
so women should not sleep with men
before they are married big woman
big woman should
that is a big woman there
is a grown ass woman asking me a little
girl question
why does she why do I why why is she
asking me bro
like she doesn't know
bro why is she she's just playing dumb
like is she being cynical there or is
she really asking me because
like how can you disagree with that it's
not you know I mean it's not I'm not I
don't have to spend money on you I don't
have to be thinking about you I don't
have to do like you know what I mean so
it's worse for you if we don't have a
commitment so women should not sleep
with men before they are married yes but
[__] ideally yeah yeah like
hey what you want more dicks before you
get married it's like
foreign
do you think these are hand-picked
and just didn't come in a random from
like close your eyes and any mini
minimal any one of them and you're
getting nonsense out of their mouth
they're virgins but the problem is you
have women that you know get ran through
and then ask the guy to wait and I'm not
sure that's the best strategy but use it
as well and yeah what do you think of
born-again virgins Lord of Mercy okay
it depends again how deep is how How
Deep Is Your Love
how deep your love is no no I'll just uh
take that song How Deep Is Your Love How
deep Bro how deep is your hole
how deep is your body count
okay so born again virgin at two bodies
oh she's all right all right born again
virgin at five bodies
she all right born again virgin at eight
bodies
I'm starting to you know what I'm saying
I'm starting to
think you're not born again
all right so born again you have up to
our born-again virgin at seven bodies
bro I'm not gonna go into the cement
okay roughly roughly five to five to
eight you can be a born-again virgin but
past then you're too far gone no it's
just there's a number that is too much
hey
seven
well I listen I'm in my 30s so I'm
expecting no girl to be um
Mother Teresa
but I'm saying if if you're 21 and
you're telling me your body count is 200
I'm not with it there's just a number I
don't know the number but when I see you
and I know that like I could tell your
value by your number you might have a
different number to someone else like
your seven might be different to another
person seven
based on your based on your age
uh like if someone's 20 versus 30. yeah
based on your location
uh would you rather have a 20 year old
with a seven body count or a 30 year old
with a seven body count
because the one girl's 30 but she's been
like less promiscuous one girl's 20.
she's been more promiscuous it's the
same number but she's easy
that's actually a good question let me
know let me know in the comments a 20
year old with a seven body count or a 30
year old with a seven body count
I mean seven is not that bad so you have
to increase the number a 20 year old
with a 20 body count and by 20 is bad
in 2023
I think so bro these girl uh okay well
dead roasting their chestnuts on the
Open Fire Farm all right what do you
guys say in the chats
bro
20 over 20 body count or 30
with a 20 body count
would you not say
you're making me liable to say none of
them
you're not answering in the chat because
the stream is a little bit behind
um
all right guys we can't play the video
we're gonna finish the video but you
need to get us to 685. does it match you
how much
um woman a man's been with
not really it's just if it's too high
I may think like what are the odds you
settle down with me so a man has to lie
about how how no no well I mean what
percent of guys really have slept with
that many
you know I don't know do you want a 20
man or do you want a 80 man
I think every girl on some level wants a
20 guy but 20 men come with 20 men
problems you know what I mean
so
you could find a good one out of 20.
I mean I sure as a woman you want
everything do you do you get everything
you know but but
would you okay would you rather never
married a man or marry a man with two
wives
uh I'd rather merry go to my wives than
never get married that's why I see
but
um like how how is it that you're
legally allowed to have sex with as much
men and women as you want you could have
gay marriage you could change your sex
you could do all of this you could
almost have sex with a 16 year old
whatever in this country but if you
marry two women you go to jail
that is crazy
that is that is a little crazy
that is so crazy to me bro I could be a
LGBT LMNOP
all day every day RAV
but if I'm married two women I go to
jail
that is so weird
listen if you want to have two wives
subscribe to my channel bro
how many wives do you want you want
three don't you
swear that was what you said
listen it it depends
it if I'm really rich then
I don't know I might do four
if I don't get quite as as damn I do one
or two
if one girl makes me feel like I don't
need another one then it's gonna be one
of them
they said the 30 year old with the seven
over the 20 year old with the seven
why because she's obviously been more
faithful throughout her years
yeah I'd still pick the 20 year old at
the seven if I was the guy it's still
seven
like if you're gonna be the last one
then you might as well pick the 20 year
old with seven at least you get her 20s
and if you and if you're with her when
when she's 20 then hopefully you stay
with her for 10 years and then she would
just be a seven body console yeah well
that's the shoe telling the truth about
a body count in the first place
well I mean but in this in this game you
know it what's your what's your if if a
guy is asking you what's your body count
what's the lie you tell him
um I don't lie tell them the truth
but you don't have to believe me to be
honest no it's not about me it's about
do they believe you yeah I mean
that's a that's the thing if you don't
say it like people think it's this crazy
high number that's a problem it's like I
don't know it's personal because then
the next question they're like okay well
who were they said I'm like ah you know
Justin I'm waiting for that next list of
of EX um pearly things exposed yeah your
ex-boyfriends the they found they found
um sort of they kind of I think that's
confused but no they've already still
want to talk about it no no I'm saying
like um
they did a video where they like went
they went through me and my ex-boyfriend
oh yeah like yeah yeah because my
ex-boyfriend and I were in a super like
public relationship
yeah and so but it was kind of funny
because we used to like do prank fights
all the time online and then they found
those clips and they're like look see
they were real but they were like like
we were YouTubers is it online
yeah but I don't really want to pull it
up no no no like I don't know because
it's like a whole can of worms but then
people would pull those clips up and be
like oh they're this yeah so guys listen
that's all you gotta think about what
you put on the internet because even if
it's a joke later people pull it up and
then it's 6 79 yeah
if you take that to 700 we are going to
watch pose X together
no we are not we will not be doing that
no no no don't worry we'll do it we'll
do that on my channel when we got time
we're gonna be like we're gonna do some
investigating
I know I'd rather not I just wait where
is he from
Chicago Chicago
yeah so it's American boyfriend yeah but
I was dating him you don't care you live
in a completely different country now
Pearl man no yeah but um I was dating
him when I came here initially but you
know
these are probably finding out a lot of
information from this life
but probably it's like oh Pearl was
actually like her personality like she's
like this I don't think you do a lot of
like lives where you're like for this
long way to actually get into they used
to if they watched it a while ago but
they're fickled they're not even going
past last week's videos listen even me
when I see a video has been like longer
than seven days I'm like I'm trying to
watch that that's old news
um
yeah yeah man if you want to see Poe's x
no no no no no no
six six seven six seven what is it seven
I just don't
I just don't like it why did you not
break up
um
you could at least know that
I just I think I probably
we didn't have compatible backgrounds in
my opinion like I think you need to have
like certain like values in common and
so
um
I mean we were like fighting too we were
doing distance but it was a dream Corona
nose after well it was started like
during it but like then I like went to
England we were fighting any but I think
at like the end of the day it was just
really different values
bro I think a lot of people's
relationships broke up and started doing
Corona during covet yeah like like if
you did if you started a dream covet
then you felt like oh yes we're gonna be
together and when Kobe finishes we're
not together so much anymore like we're
forced to be next to each other all the
time so I have to be in the house with
you but now Cove is done I'm out and
about you're like right you've changed
so that's how our relationships break up
or it could be like we're out doing our
things and now we're in the same house
together we're forced to be in the house
we actually realize how much we hate
each other
yeah
no I think
I mean I don't blame you because no but
no but no I'm saying like my coven
experience was just a little bit like
different because it was like um you
might eat Propel if you did not break up
with your boyfriend just you well this
channel will not be here I don't think
so actually I probably couldn't have did
this channel in a relationship
that's so crazy you know why I am yeah
like I don't think he would have liked
like the shows and like people and you
know I don't think
but it's actually kind of how I started
the show because I was sad like I
literally started this like right after
we broke up yeah because I was like
um
I don't know I was sad so to me that is
so crazy like how things in life just
yeah you're going on a path and that's
the reason why that happened that there
that Junction yeah
that's crazy Bob
hmm yeah partially and there's like a
lot of reasons but that was like part of
it was I like had the free time from it
I was kind of trying to get over it
so and so even then in itself they make
you sound like oh po she just came from
America to Britain to go and steal their
culture go over there and
bro you don't even know why she's here
no I mean I came here I came here for
volleyball it was just supposed to be a
year
um
I wouldn't preach don't know this
no they don't I mean they don't know
this you're him but they didn't they're
like Griffin but they didn't even try to
get to like they either that's the point
like like they even said before before
they even knew me in that video he said
she messaged me and I didn't like like I
and I thought this woman was clowning on
black women because I think I sent them
the 200k engagement ring video yeah
um but it's so clear they didn't watch
any of my streams because if they
watched a full thing it's not what it is
at all and that's what's really
frustrating is like there are hosts that
are intentionally combative and
sometimes I debate but it's like I'm
really not nearly as combative as other
people that have shows to be honest and
I could be a lot more combative and so
and say they don't
and that's what I I try I've been trying
to convey is like a lot of the reaction
channels they just have their lens of
how they view the world and like he saw
that through a racial lens before he
even knew me yeah before he knew
anything about me he just saw that he
had his judgment yeah he saw that I I
came from a rich family his racial bias
yeah and then he's gonna call him no no
let's pause your racial bias bro
that's what annoyed the hell out of me
bro you're like these guys that sit down
and say oh this white girl bro if you're
even if you're even stopping to to to
think about what Pearl looks like as
opposed to what she's saying you're
already coming from the bias bro
you're showing your own biases that's
why you too could be both be back up
dancers and call someone a backup dancer
bro because you are showing your true
colors bro
when you go like that and you point at
someone your your fingers is pointing
more at yourself bro
two backup dancers there
okay I'm not a backup dancer
I'm too awkward
maybe if I dance like I wish I could
dance it's actually the one thing I wish
I knew how to do
listen get me one get me 1.9 million
subscribers and I'll get one of the
shirt like Abba bro I'll get one of them
shirts where the buttons is struggling
to stay together
but
yeah but that's that's what I really
real it's like they already didn't like
me so they were just like waiting for
something and then you you know the
first time I realized abom preached like
take people out of context was the women
voting thing oh she the women yeah bro
it was way before that for me that's
what I didn't realize that during the
fresh and fit stuff but I realized that
during the women voting thing because
um
they they clipped it like I like I
wasn't kidding when I said that women
shouldn't vote now I've a hundred
percent changed my opinion on this so
it's kind of it's funny now because now
I like during that interview the first
one I did in October I was joking I was
like oh Pearl's World women wouldn't
vote like and I was just kind of talking
to the podcast but I was clearly kidding
and then they clipped it like I was
serious
I'd say with the birth control like
Banning birth control but I was like
yeah that'll never happen like I was
kidding and so I just remember thinking
like why would they do it like that but
then my opinion changed on that so now
now maybe it's honest journalism bruh
from time I'm even gonna let you know
know exactly when but I'll let you know
it's been time since I know what these
guys are on I've known for time and I've
been like
they're not gonna try no no way they're
gonna try to come no
so I'm like listen hold on a minute
these men come I'm gonna deal with that
you know bro I'll deal with that issue
straight away and then what do they do
they came and then I what did I do I
snap back quick straight away what does
he look what did his lot do why they
were they at night bro
let me tell you about these men
you don't know just because someone
smile up in your face and hehehe and
don't mean they like you but I could
tell when they don't like you or they're
not for you bro they're not trying to
push your team but I could tell rap I
could tell in a man's eyes that you got
Hate in Your Eyes I've done this for so
long bro I've so I've shown so much man
love bro that I could tell when you're a
hater bruv
and bro is there more if there if you're
a GPT
veteran
in the chat right now holding it down
can you tell when someone's been
ingenuine by looking at their eyes bro
just looking into them like looking into
their back bro this person is not
genuine bro I took one look at Paul's
like this girl this there is no way she
could fake this [__]
no way
and she is kept on code since I've known
her brother you may have changed about
10 million times bro one minute you're a
red pill one minute you're this one
minute you're that one minute you're
like this one minute you're like that
bro
well and you you know what else it's
like they all
um act like they care about black issues
but they they're constantly [__] on
fresh and fit
they're constantly [__] on fresh and
fair they don't those are black business
that that's my point and they they help
more genuinely fresh and help more men
than genuinely any other podcast
they are they're deaf like well I don't
know so fresh and fit probably have
about I don't know about 16 to 30 000
people watching their life most of them
men I'll say about 80 to 90 percent what
do you think these men would be doing if
they weren't sitting down watching Fresh
and [__] films
well and and they actually bring on
people to help the guys it's like they
bring on and this is coming from someone
I didn't like fresh and Fit I I
literally did not like you could find
old videos of me talking [__] about them
no no seriously I didn't like my the way
Myron talked like triggered me but then
it's like the longer you listen like you
could tell he cares he cares about men
and there's really no one else that
offers as much like value to men as them
I wish we did but like I'm too back and
forth I don't know how he does it but he
he gets like all these different experts
on like every single show
and I'm like he's an American opal
yeah it would be easier if house in
America yeah but you know I recommend
fusing America though they would concert
you time ago
yeah but I mean I'm just trying to give
credit where credit's due and so no but
I'm saying like like Advent preach will
paint them out to be like at like
they'll keep saying they said their
Alpha but they never call themselves
Alpha and that's what they do they just
like poke they poke it and they do it to
sneak out they do like it's just so
dishonest is that like Fair journalism
I'll show you look um
this is um
this is this is 2020 oh my God
guys get them to 700 Subs fresh prince
of Zamunda
this is youlo's alpha males bro I'll
show you not you know it's Alpha male's
mouth
and you know honestly and you see it
over the test of time to be honest like
because it's like your your words become
your thoughts and your thoughts become
like well you know your thoughts become
your words and your words become your
actions right and so the the stuff you
talk about and the stuff you preach it
it affects you
and look at me a year ago you just saw
me on the stream was it fatter then or
am I am I fat or no
I'm thinner now you're finished yeah
yeah yeah and you can see that it's like
you see what the consequences is of like
life decisions like my Myron all the red
pill dudes sneako jaywalk they're all in
great shape
like
this is you guys Alpha pills
this is your this is your Alpha Mouse
these guys bro
this is nothing to do with Paul I'm
saying this
these are your guys bro this is your
Master's hair brav
o that's that's who you like look up to
Bob
when you like when you like wanna
sit down and look at a man and say what
does a man do sit down in front of a
computer screen the whole day
clicking buttons playing Minecraft
and you know what other accusation they
throw at me
they'll say oh you you're not a
traditional woman of course not
I'm a volleyball player I played I went
to school and played volleyball for five
hours after school I would do three hour
volleyball practice two hour basketball
practice what when did I have time
you know what I mean like and I'm like
okay you know this is coming from you
know in the late in the game learning
this stuff now but a lot of girls like
don't even know that there's a problem
and they act like I'm acting like I'm so
much better and I've never I've never
said that
ah
a cannery
Cannery in the Vine
I'll tell you the story about the canary
in the mind so basically back in the
days they used to do they used to mine
for stuff and they will be sometimes be
gas leaks and stuff like that so what
they would do they would have a canary
hung up
and it will be the first to let them
know if there's gas a gas leak because
the canary would die
so it was the warning before the actual
problem come
so the canary don't have to be the gas
itself warning you the canaries Canary
itself is just being the canary
and you don't respect the canary until
it's dead
and when it's dead it's too late because
you're already you're already exposed to
the gas
don't piss me off brav
1 000 I'm well I'm just getting mad at
these yo kanos in my head for these guys
bro literally but I've read it
foreign
to detect the presence of carbon
monoxide the birds rapid breathing rate
small size and high metabolism compared
to the miners lead birds in dangerous
mice to succumb before the miners
thereby giving the miners time to take
action RAV
that's what she is
she don't need to be your your white
White Queen to save you from oh she's
perfect in every way no
I'm letting you know the problem
it's your choice whether you're not
listen to it
it's your choice whether you listen to
it not
I'm not going to be there at your
wedding marrying you
negotiating with your partner whether or
not your body count matters or not no
but then that is probably too late RAV
I'm trying to get you man young RAV
remember my podcast how to make money
keep money
and make that [__] grow
that's my [__] because I know half of
the job half the mission for half of you
guys is getting money in your pocket bro
I know what it feels like for some of
you 80 percent man bro you can't go on a
date so why bother
you can't you you can't get a goal to
stop so why bother you ain't got a
flashy car so why bother you just work a
normal nine to five so why bother
you get stressed when you stop them why
bother they always ask you that you're
not good enough so why bother bro my
channel is this is why we bother
and forget about forget about them like
what they're on we're doing what we do
just like the manosphere we created a
space and women follow successful men
bro
I don't like who was I was it you that
told me was the other way around
yesterday
what do you mean I I was suggesting that
beautiful women follow
oh
women follow successful men and then
normal men follow beautiful women
that's true
actually I agree with that
you have to be successful for them to
follow you for everyone to follow you
RAV
and success is relative
Roger Federer is successful at tennis
Usain Bolt is successful at running
they're completely different size
profiles but they both got a wife that
you wish you had
this man thing is easy hey takes are the
best player versus player bro
no NPCs out here bro player versus
player brav we're out here trying to
make the best player brother not player
like player player no player as in
best player bro best character
improve improve improve improve improve
improve bro
I'm not gonna be here like these reviews
and moaning and oh we need to do we need
to change we're trying to change
how you how are you trying to change
how are you trying to change it
and I've actually learned so much in the
past year
I'm a much better cook than I was a year
ago I noticed
not much like I barely knew how to cook
I started learning like a year and a
half ago maybe
put it this way if if a woman that was
overweight didn't know how to cook
didn't know how to speak to men and
didn't know what men want watched your
channel a year ago at the start
they will be in a better position to do
that's true
they would have watched you do it first
time and thought right if she could do
it I could do it I don't know which
woman is sitting down now thinking it
can't be done because you are
complaining that she did it
look at the cheek of it they won't let
us do it
[Music]
she did it rather than just like and he
was the first person to complain the
woman this
[Music]
and then when did you have simple men
following the girls yeah yeah
yeah whatever she said
well and the other thing is like they'll
be like oh
you can't you don't do the podcast the
right way and it's always people smaller
than me but I'm like well you can't
reach this many people
so
your way clearly isn't working you you
are nice to them I do you think anyone
could tell me about how to run my
podcast
I saw one guy tell me um I wonder if I
should even say this bro my man sent him
a comment yeah he's like Amiri when are
you gonna come out the closet
you're at 6.95 you're so close you need
five more Hey listen five more I told
you I told him
five more and I told you what I told him
when he told me that
he says Get Out of the Closet
what did I do
what did I do being me
what did I mean we do being me
what did he do what did he say
I'll tell you what I said when when you
did five Morehead
all right I can't wait
do you know I told him I told him
when I'm done with your mother's mouth
is what I would have said if I wasn't a
YouTuber but I am so I'm I'm not gonna
say nothing
I'm so good at this bro like
what
a lot of Mercy
when I'm coming out the clock bro
it's what I would have said if I wasn't
at YouTuber because I am I'm not gonna
say that to you I'm just gonna say
bless my bro
delusion so you just said 700
yay
yeah man this is what I mean when I say
that the the
um
the subscribers no no I'm on Twitter the
the
um
what do you call it the reaction
channels don't go into things in good
faith it's like Destiny's arguing with
me on Twitter when I'm talking about
like men's issues
and he keeps asking me for my sources
and I say I've interviewed judges
attorneys
um you he even spoke to lead attorney a
20-year divorce attorney who told him
that freaking that the the court like
discriminates against men he doesn't
believe the divorce attorneys yeah and
I'm like okay I've interviewed judges
who gave this guy but this is what I
mean like he doesn't go into arguments
in good faith because he he'll be like
oh well what's your Source then you say
okay this lawyer spoke to me about this
and he's like well that's not good
enough and they'll be like okay who's he
who gave him his accreditation and then
and then I'll say okay well look at look
at men only get custody 10 of the time
they pay 80 percent of child support
payments they only pay four percent of
alimony cases you don't think they're
being discriminated against and then
he's like well you know well that's not
good enough like it's like you could
give them and that's what I realized
guys with these twitch and like
streamers they don't actually care about
what's true they can and then he'll say
oh well single mothers are worse off
financially and I'm like well because
they're worse with money in general
and like that's the problem with a lot
of these lefties is you have to argue
with them over like basic things that we
just know like a five-year-old they
didn't man on the street interviews and
they said why do women like make less
than men and they said because women
spend more and work less this is like a
five-year-old is he live right now let
me know if he's live right now man
let me know if this guy at somebody poke
but let me know if this guy's live right
now in the chat bro and give me the link
bro
chat is nonsense bro I'll make him come
on live right now
someone wake up Destiny bro
Chinese Madden Madness bro
yeah but it's like crazy to me that you
don't believe the people that are in the
system it's like I've interviewed men
affected by the system I I and but
that's what I mean they don't go into
stuff in like in good faith if you don't
even like yeah why would he he bro all
right so what works for them is if
people think you've dunked on them by
doing an ad hominem or you've said shut
up and let me talk or yeah it's like
what it what did what did Abba and
preach argue with me your single
argumentative career driven like women
woman or something like that and so it's
like is that a good faith argument
no no their whole premise was faulty at
the start of it anyway because they
don't watch you
they don't own words they don't want you
but let's just give them the benefit of
Doubt saying they do watch you and they
think your argumentative they think
you're what what was the other one
career on our single argumentative
career driven woman something like that
okay everything you argue against
basically what they're trying to say
ah yeah yeah yeah yeah let me break down
these two
okay
eyeball
and preach
who both
were back up dances
one was a fail military man
who got out the Army because he did not
know how to handle Authority
did not know discipline and how to look
after himself
who ran from the sand pits
literally ran from the sand pits
trying to tell someone
bro bro don't let me throw you ain't
gonna do me nothing Eva bro
nothing buff
nothing RAV
you got Fingers 2 000 people subscribing
to you that that means you somehow have
more of a voice than me bro are you
stupid bruv are you dumb RAV
you think you could out talk me bro on
my voice I want to have to tell you bro
let I'll let you be known that whatever
I have to say about you find out and you
hear about it bro and uh don't don't
don't let all your viewers get confused
about this thing you know they hit they
hear and see everything we do you know
brother
they hear when their names get cold RAV
stay here
acting like biatch's messaging time I'm
coming shut up bro make a video make
your money bro tell me not don't try to
message me now bro talk about these
sneaky ass bud
foreign
maybe we could react to this and maybe
as a thank you they'll subscribe
no someone in your comment section is
saying that Ralph and you're getting
tired so that's why you're just giving
up
someone's in my comment section saying
what that oh we would subscribe after we
watch it or something like that oh I
didn't see it
stomach is growing
I am getting tired I'm getting sleepy as
hell
all right guys that was that was a nice
treat
you're so close you're almost at 700.
bro I'm going home bro you didn't they
didn't hit me if I was and I'm going
home tomorrow if I if I thousand I'll
I'll do tomorrow if I was then I don't
care about but until then we'll talk
about anything else apart from them guys
you don't want to play with me brov
she's what do you want to react to
let me know
but I ain't gonna be about them these
reactors love because these a lot of
women are thousand bro you got a 300
more and you want to play with me bro
I'll let you know if the record is free
18 in the UK
I've got home to go to you brother
I got lungs that need catering to
yeah
I need to sit down on my throne and do
my thing and talk to my peoples
yeah because when we were slaves we
wasn't allowed to [__] when we wanted to
and and this is what we wanted to
but now we're free
well historically no just kidding I'm
just kidding
foreign
this is a serious question okay maybe
you look could be able to help her
explain to me this race issue in your
country broth
um
like is it really that segregated in
terms of you you know London obviously
because you live here and you know
America because you've lived there show
you a study but like what is it I'm
gonna show you a study
um
I don't understand it bro
okay
thank you
all right uh so this is from
all right
voters are not
um buying into
example
Alexia
because I think I think I'm just not
understanding them properly because I
don't live their life in terms of how
like because bro we just don't live like
you don't RAV
en Scott Adams
foreign
it's just there's certain topics in the
US that are very like you just can't
really talk about them
because if you do they just label you as
a racist like I like I found out and it
doesn't matter if you bring numbers
stats like you can literally cite your
sources they don't care
um
because of the history of slavery in our
country
yeah well England had a slavery history
as well it had the slavery history
yeah but I think it was a little bit
more prevalent in the you because the UK
also ended slavery like they placed the
waters like the like World slavery
wouldn't have ended if it wasn't for
England
do you know that yeah but do you know
why England ended slavery
why a because it wasn't profitable
because the slaves were rebelling B they
already
colonialized Africa so they they didn't
need to do slavery anymore and see you
know when you've like you you've cheated
so much and it's like okay I'm winning
now okay now that no one can always
could get to how I'm getting to you
because I'm telling you now the only way
to really grow Africa right now is Free
Labor right now I'm telling you like
that's the only way we could do that if
we get volunteers saying we want to go
to Africa and build that and help it out
that's the only way it's gonna do it
volunteers please I heard there was a I
can't find it but I think this is it but
I don't see the actual numbers from it
but
there was like a survey then went out
that said like
of
half of um black people in the U.S voted
in a poll saying if they said if they
agreed with the statement it's okay to
be white
and half wouldn't put that they agreed
yeah it might have been like 40 but it
was something like that what yeah I
remember Scott Adams was like okay super
canceled over it that's I'm trying to
find it
um
foreign
oh here it is
all right the polling group um presented
one
five
oh wait what's this
Washington Post
that's when you could tell they're dying
media form mate fine you get my email
foreign
you see how easy influence she is I'm
fine you could have it it's like what
for me bro bro for the loss the pulling
three years they've been trying to get
money pulling the pulling all right the
pulling group um presented survey takers
with an oddly phrased question do they
agree or disagree with the statement
it's okay to be white with a slim
majority of black respondents saying yes
comment strip Creator Scott Adams cited
the results to argue that black
Americans are Americans are a hate group
urging white people to get the hell away
from black people don't clip that that's
not me saying this I'm just reading it
his racist rant promoted hundreds of
newspapers to drop his Dilbert comic and
disapproval disapproval run during the
decades old cartoon homeless the survey
question was asked by a conservative
leading rouseman reports okay but that's
basically it so yeah so it's not okay to
be white
uh not not according to this poll
um
um all right rouseman citing respondents
reached through automated landline calls
and a panel of of volunteer participant
reported that 53 of 117 black
participants agreed with the statement
but 26 of black participants disagreed
in 21 said they weren't sure so it was
like half and half
how can you not anyway how can you not
be sure
yeah
no NC is like saying is it okay to be
black
it's literally exact thing bro the exact
thing
it's okay to be white and it's okay to
be black bro what you are so deluded
over there bro
the delusion brov
there's a lot of things
I mean there's a lot of people that make
money uh like it's just that can't be a
right number man that can't be the right
I mean that's that's the pool
but that's what I mean like race
relations are just different
bro if you don't want to get out of that
little bubble of that fish tank of of
nonsense
come to England man
just get out of it love you're gonna
waste your life
hating people that you don't even know
why you're supposed to hate them
that's bro this is a waste of energy bro
that is such a waste of energy how can
you tell someone why is it okay to be
white rough
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my entire life Brad
do you think anyone could tell me it's
not okay to be black brood
[Music]
you mad bro you are mad bro
God made you the way he wanted you to be
brav God Don't Make Mistakes bro if you
think what just gonna make the white
race just to to because they're all of
them are evil bro that's just stupid bro
it's a stupid way to think well
so
so how okay so in your neighborhood was
there any black people
my neighborhood
really hang out with people in my
neighbor not a ton but there's some but
it was mostly like on sports teams
um
you know when I was in Trinidad I didn't
like
like so when I came when I fought about
England I thought oh yeah there's gonna
be Mary Poppins and
chimneys and chimney sweepers and stuff
you know it came in a train underground
and
a whole heap of Madness
but what I learned in London
is
how to
I don't know be more accepting of other
people's
fight
where they come from what they're doing
like I I think I know like a bit of
culture from every single country yeah
I've learned even a bunch I mean I
learned how to cook a jollof rice here
you
learn so much just because like people
talk about their cultures you know so
I've learned about like Zimbabwe I've
learned about Nigeria I've learned about
even Eastern Europe
um Spain a little bit it's like you
learn about all these different cultures
because it's just so Multicultural bro
you're you're in East London you come
outside of your house and it's it's Asia
or Africa outside mate
yeah that's that's the other thing I'm
like you guys don't understand where I
live it's just not
[Music]
and so they think I'm specifically like
targeting certain people for my shows
and I'm like good luck tell me how hard
it is bro first and foremost [__] yeah
and we operate a lot
I'd repeat guests yeah so it's like
no so okay I'll say some guests
reach out to us to be on the show so
are we supposed to turn down the guests
that that want to come onto the show
you wouldn't do that we wouldn't do that
so okay let's separate those
then you have the guests that you ask
and they say yes
and they come on the show are you gonna
reject those guests coming on but it's
their world view like they see
everything like that's
and they I mean reaction channels yeah
yeah we know that's no but that's what
they'll do they'll clip it and say she
met someone else by they and then that's
what Lord I even forget about yeah no
but that's the thing like you as a
content creator you start to hear like
the way that they're gonna like clip you
you'll say something you'll be like [__]
they're gonna clip that yeah and it's
like it makes you speak like less freely
because you're afraid that they're just
gonna clip you
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a different
technique now Paul I'm gonna say what I
want mate
once it's not like once it's in the
guidelines I don't care about the court
of public opinion I'm gonna see my piece
because I'm not here to please you not
I'm here to find mys and wonders about
and keep it real with my eyes and
wonders if you don't want to be able to
get what you can subscribe to um in the
title click is at get them to 700 again
because a bunch of y'all unsubscribe you
fake people no they're they're the real
ones
they're the real fake ones
your stuff is already doing better
though do you know like all right would
you rather maybe
um racist to you directly or would you
rather me secretly be racist and not let
you know
uh direct because if if they do it
secretly then they might make a video
calling you a colonizer
after a year of knowing you and thinking
that you're their friend
but that's what I realized like in that
situation like he saw everything through
the lens of race so every time I did
something or like that's just how he you
know like have you not seen these
[__] videos
now I really but no but I mean like okay
you know how like those women will see
everything as assault or abuse yeah and
like no matter what the guy does he's
always wrong like that's what I realized
like he just saw everything through like
a racial lens
do you mean like you you had like you're
already guilty before innocent and you
had to prove yourself innocent yeah yeah
like even like he was implied like how
lying that the people
the people for me are slaves
or how I mean they'll they'll say
something it's a colonial mindset like
they'll say some of their [__] we
know what you're saying
do you know what you know what's weird
about that thing
the first time you see your friend snake
use when you see your friends thank you
that is a weird one bro to be like
oh [__] you had my number
you had my you had my Instagram
you're in direct connection within until
you could vote you have you could if you
wanted to find me you could get hold of
me you could talk to me bro you know you
know what I'm about you know how much
you know what kind of guy I am bro yeah
that's why and I had a really good case
to go to court with it actually and you
know who knows someday I may pursue it
but I was just like I need to get on
with my life I don't have time for this
[__] some of these O'Shea dude Jackson
need to realize bro certain people I
called them out and if I've met them in
real life bro realize they don't cool my
name out bro when I when when Sarah did
this mad thing and I called out Sora he
didn't call my name out when I went for
MTR and I told him holding himself and
he should have done that no no return
from MTR it's only [__] that meet me
in real life that know I'm a real guy
bro and I wear my emotions on my sleeve
bro no bro like if I'm saying something
I'm upset bro I'm saying it I'm upset
I'm coming from a place of Love bro I'll
slap you in a place of Love bro
real talk like don't play with me bro
like you know what I'm about bro like
come on stop playing bro don't do that
Ralph
don't try to do this man RAV
call my name and first name and last
name and all that bro all shades are
flipping oh you're back to 700. oh [__]
he's a bloody madman RAV
but anyway
I'm gonna make sure he has a warm
welcome and he reached down in England
no he's sitting on the stream just
waiting to clip he's like ah my clips
for the week nah bro I'm gonna show him
some some English Hospitality how we
treat people with respect and you know
and then he'll make a hit piece on you
right after
a inFAMOUS or famous bro we're gonna get
it
we're gonna get it
I want to hear what these will have to
say man what he's not chatting about
Mary says I just don't appreciate women
who use men suffering for views and
further exploit them
I said blood you need to stop calling
people's names
are you dumb bro man called my first
name bro should I go to man's video bro
my man cool bro you dumb bro don't call
Men's name bro remember my first name
last name rather you stupid bro like
where I'm from name nationality where to
find me are you dumb bro I was quiet for
two weeks three weeks for the whole
thing I didn't say one word bro until we
call my name are you stupid ruff
don't piss me off bruv but don't cool
people's now cool name whoever I want
bro are you dumb bro man call my name I
call your name bro
don't call the name of the person that
called out your name are you stupid does
that even make sense
bro let me know bro let me know
don't call my name
bro I got nothing against MTR that's why
I called his name literally that's why I
called it because me and MTR is cool he
made it sound like me and Mt had a
problem all I said to MTR is bro why
broth come on G you know what we're
doing and you know me personally you
know what we're doing behind bro
and that reflected on his videos so when
it begs the question is it is that
something you do when you have someone's
number
when you admit it he admitted to me
he he admitted and said that he did not
watch the full video
I could
rotation they think we just send videos
and we don't and we're not in
communication with people that's yeah
[__] videos bro
it's like is that
oh my God the whole thing where he's
like I I had no idea I found out on my
live stream I'm like no you didn't get
out of here
my man said O'Shea Jackson is going to
make a serious video on this but why do
I he's already made a series
he's a well like so am I not supposed to
defend my name and mama is definitely in
my character mama is lying about what I
what and man's calling my full name
about what and what's up bro come on am
I not supposed to defend myself
and you know the other thing that they
clipped that was super dishonest I can't
remember which reaction channel did this
but they clipped me on the trigonometry
thing and then they said that um then
they put they put King Richie's after
when I said my staff wasn't offended but
I was referring to the staff that was in
the room I don't and and if they watch
the full interview which they did
did they yes
I I don't know no but I'd say if they
watch the full I mean the Nick interview
is three and a half hours bro they
watched the obsidian stream because my
man said blessing came on and spoke so
how did you know about blessing came on
and spoke unless you watched the whole
thing like prior to that well and so but
they didn't click they didn't um
oh I wasn't even talking about well and
on Auntie's stream blessing said that he
thought Nick was a nice guy and he liked
him as a guest
and that's what I was talking about and
then they clip it like I'm lying and
that is just so freaking but this is
what this is they're gonna give hundreds
of hours of just reaction
content
but whatever let them it
yeah man
bro you imagine 24 hour stream roll I'm
gonna do a 24 I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get 10 only fan models and find out for
educational purposes only what they do
in their spare time and um I'm gonna
have them up here on a 24-hour stream
bro
for Education educational purposes
LOL cow
low cow what's that do you know what
that is Laughing Cow
is that like gonna be fat
laughing cows lack of cheese
they said Pearl will become a la LOL cow
so on Twitter said that to me I love in
stock
rude
why because they don't know how YouTube
works
bro have you not even seen Pearl's
Impressions about let alone my
Impressions bro I've been on YouTube for
a week and I have like 50 000
Impressions bro stop playing bro you
look you like to say a lot of things and
put things into into um
in into flipping Fusion rather by just
saying stupidness brav so why don't you
use that same energy and say something
like you know what instead of saying oh
[__] is going to make 10 videos and make
a series and get rich from this say
Amiri is gonna get a million subscribers
and do it put that into the atmosphere
I would love you so much for that if you
threw that into the atmosphere
along with what you say because
honestly guys you need to you need to
realize this
I don't care
I don't care if they call my name
I care that O'Shea has made a lot of
money without me bro I'm gonna make some
money as well
we gonna get rich together
and he should want that no because he
wants his black brother to be rich as
well right his black brother he wants
his black brother to be rich right we're
gonna be rich together
we gonna be rich together you want Unity
we're gonna be
so tired bro go sleep man
what okay we got out of the stream we're
gonna end this brother listen if you
don't want I would end it how I end it
yeah get me 20 more subscribers and I'll
end it how I normally end my streams bro
let's see what you're at it's you're
like 700 I think
yeah 702 they brought you back
are you not Legends man I've got faith
in you not Brown
all right so tomorrow
what's tomorrow Thursday
it's tomorrow Thursday today Thursday
yeah yeah that means Pearl's got a show
tomorrow
yeah yeah
Paul's got a show tomorrow Michael's got
a live tomorrow
I've got a live tomorrow
um
Auntie is um in Barbados right now
hope everything's going well for her and
her family
I'm saying through these difficult times
um
you should have seen the MTR
day dating thing on on Pearl's Channel
can't wait to drop that one
when is the Melanie went after is that
one after
yeah
sneakers
also guys listen if you want hey yo when
is Myron coming on the show bro this is
annoying me bro because people think are
you still feel fresher figure bro wait
yo when's the Marine interview coming
RAV
because we just end these guys bro these
guys chat so much crap brav
thank you
what time is it in Miami
12.
they have five hours behind okay I was
just wondering what time they start
uh they live now
I'll say how funny would it be if you
just live stream reacted to their live
show sneakers on their show right now
yeah no he goes on all the time
things like that I should send them a
message
yo if any of you real ones are out there
out there send the two dollar donation
to fresh and fit and say but I was
watching and saying that she she's
supporting the channel support just
party things
foreign
props to you for doing this
[Music]
don't make her blush and smile bro
we made it to 700. bro I am more than
grateful and more than thankful for each
700 of you and even the ones that didn't
even subscribe but sat down and watched
and liked this stream and showed bear
love and that I appreciate it bro
honestly like order aside you know
that's me bantering
banter in if you didn't know that's how
we banned her in the UK
we have a sense of humor brav
so you know
George Valencia thinks Pearl's sexy as
AF
Craig agrees
meant to do the reaction to Abba and
Screech now you guys didn't get us to
attack Frozen we don't
it's 7 45 in in L.A
where's everyone at
want to see La in the building
yeah if you guys are watching this this
um let's see Miami in the building if
you're watching the the this video back
maybe if you get to a thousand tomorrow
we'll react to this stuff maybe yes sir
but that turned out tomorrow I'd have to
be like bro listen I'm in the studio I
don't but po am I not in the studio
almost every single day bro like we
could do this live and talk about these
guys I could have talked about these
guys months ago if I wanted to
you think I didn't know these men are
backup dancers from months ago
you don't think when I
I see you like the fake news how can you
shift that on me bro when you were the
backup dance
wow
like we need to watch that one more time
bro like
wow
how does probe feel about being called
pasty I know I'm pale like what the f I
know I'm pale what
she don't mind obviously but it depends
on who's saying if it's people that's
saying you're racist you paste the ass
white [__]
how do you follow up with like don't
know I don't really care about being
pale I think it looks better than these
[__] yeah yeah he's he's lived a big
I thought you was gonna say awful he was
gonna cancel my stream
[Applause]
I thought you was gonna nuke that button
I said end it how I want to end it
not new kid
yo listen let's hear what these dweebs
have to say
we're all followers and it got to 3
million like so fast I did this video
about like how like short guys get
discriminated against all the time
that's real yeah and uh and then I like
did these live interviews with these
girls and I was like asking them why
they wouldn't date short guys and all
this other stuff and like oh you know he
doesn't you know if I wear heels or I
just I want to hug him and feel like I'm
unsafe and insecurity and I'm like all
right cool and I was talking to them
asking like you guys ask for men's
height
on Tinder profiles I'm like yeah I think
it's important for men to post all right
bro
if you are true fans of apple and preach
bro you would not let this guy get away
with this bro why is his shirt
screaming to stay together
Abba
you are not a size 32.
why is he trying to fit into a size 32.
bro I'm like what if they post like a
weight requirement like and the women
lost their minds and it was just like
this juxtaposition between the two
points so yeah that went viral and then
from there I just kind of kept going
with YouTube ever since uh you know them
girls that bro we have girls that come
onto our sets every day yeah
and we have cushions for them
we call it the fat cushion
and basically where it is we have a
cushion so if you feel uncomfortable
about your weight you can put the
cushion right there and cover it and
make and you know it feels so nice and
I'm so relaxed where I am but it really
is just to cover your your [__] bro
if you do not stop fiddling on
Kinder profiles I'm like yeah I think
it's important for men to post out I'm
like what if they post like a weight
requirement like and the women lost
their minds and it was just like this
juxtaposition between the two points so
yeah that went viral and then from there
I just kind of kept going with YouTube
ever since uh preach ended up jumping on
shortly afterwards
let me leave him alone man because you
know in certain countries when you when
you're big like that they know you eat
in good bath
so
maybe I need to put in something about
maybe six packs are not in these days
what do I know Daria how'd you know
he's also a street dancer oh
bro
these guys called me a backup dancer
and the women lost their minds and it
was just like this juxtaposition between
the two points so yeah that went viral
and then from there I just kind of kept
going with YouTube ever since uh preach
ended up jumping on shortly afterwards
and uh yeah how did you know
he's also a street dancer oh okay yeah
yeah he's he's lived a big a long life
bro that is just weird bro
foreign
to me bro like are you for real nah
bro why are you not talking about
coldibe
I was be hella disingenuous bro that's
what I'm trying to say bro men's watch
these guys for Years bro
and then sometimes you'll be like
bro I know you Ralph
I know you know it's like it's like
Ronald McDonald
Pearl is calm fam
I'm not gonna lie to you but I post calm
bro
we're just having fun bro this is all
for entertainment guys please this is
all for entertainment bro when we when
we roast them bro it's gonna be all for
entertainment bro we want everyone to
win out here bro I just pearly things
everyone we want them to win bro we
don't we're not here to hate no one bro
we encounter no channels every person
we've ever
debated we've told them you have the
opportunity to come on anytime you want
and discuss it bro how else more open we
are bro we don't tell people no people
that you think we hate they've been on
our channel Time After Time After Time
off the time bro like you can't bro come
on man come on man a real guy like Doc
Savage what does he say he says Pearl is
dope as [__] in my book I hope my
red-headed little mama ain't taking all
this hate and lately to Heart
but most common
you're sleeping like a baby right now
she's going to sleep now
yeah kairu perfect perfect would you say
Abba picks and chooses what to grift on
like Destiny bro that's literally where
it is bro
that's why I got so mad because it's
like bro are you really trying to
are you really trying to do the council
thing with us
after like I sit down and be like yo we
really need to be like certain to change
and be you know when you sit down and
think oh look let me try and make
something positive in life let me try
and do something positive boom boom boom
let's make a
um a podcast and let's talk about this
and hopefully we'll be able to help and
then and then when you hear people say
oh you're not doing a Jesus hey and
bring down people and it's like
wow
wow so they do they want us to not
I wanted to change
like do they do they feel comfortable
that there's fathers out there that
don't get to see their kids
like as men are they happy that there's
what 60 to 70 percent of men under 30 of
virgins or haven't slept with anyone in
the last year
but yet 80 to 70 percent of women are
sleeping around am I supposed to be
happy with that number am I supposed to
be happy with the fact that that women
could just decide to up and leave in a
relationship and take your family and
break apart your family take your
resources take and what am I supposed to
be happy because of that
are we supposed to just allow that to
continue are we supposed to allow our
daughters to tell us what to do as grown
men in our household like we we can't
tell our daughters what how to do are we
supposed to be happy about are we
supposed to be happy that you're
teaching our little kindergarten kids
about the egbt key bro is that is that
okay bro are we supposed to be happy
about that
are we supposed to make stuff stay how
it is
and just complain about it and not
actually make an effort to make it
change are we supposed to be happy that
we've got men that are leaving women
that will be perfectly fitted for them
to go to a different country to find a
woman bro
just one that just respects them enough
you know just just respects him bro like
he gets up and he works and he's a
working man and he didn't he didn't kill
nobody he didn't stab nobody then steal
from nobody then fee from nobody like
just he's a good man and you want to
make me feel bad about being a good man
and want to call me this names and that
names and I'm not good enough and
because I'm not six foot five and I
don't make a million pounds and I don't
make a million dollars that I'm not good
enough for you do you want me to watch
men that write me stories every single
day on our Instagrams in the pre-game
Instagrams telling me their stories
about what their wives has done what
this has done that and you want me to
just leave them alone and just ignore
them
just watch the world crumble right in
front of me is that what you want you
reviewers is that what you want Ralph
disrespect my my subscribers and our
subscribers that are subscribed to the
Channel watch our stuff
um donate give us good advice message us
give words of wisdom come to the meetups
so invested in us want to be
participants on the on the channel
are we supposed to just give up on that
this is what you look as responsible
subscribers supposed to ask these men
bro
this is what you're supposed to be
asking them bro because sometimes I
don't know like what you want bro you
don't want us to what does girls want to
do you like one of your girls out there
and only friends bro
I saw I saw I saw a girl
today on King Rich's
um podcast
and
she before she says uh hi I'm dinner I'm
single
and I was like oh wow a beautiful girl
like you you're single what's going on
in the world only to know five minutes
later yeah I have only fans sorry
ah
that's why you single you know what I'm
saying it's right there yo it's like
Mission Impossible why you're single no
it's not Mission Impossible it's simple
let's see what you'll have to say though
yeah speak on it brother yeah I'm trying
man
Cody what's that um maybe I'll try maybe
I'll try that I've always been curious
on Islam and how it works never really
been religious but I've always been
curious maybe I try it out and do some
reading yeah
I don't think I need to explain to my
subscribers maybe I'm just extreme to
you Lord because you're not jpt
subscribers
you see me
no I can't play with my future and and
my afterlife yeah so what I'm gonna do
as a responsible person is I'm gonna
take 20 minutes out of my time and I'm
gonna read other people's holy books
math
I'm gonna study people's holy books and
I'm gonna see if my frame of thinking is
correct bro I know people that say
uh burn out their Muslims but they've
never read the Quran
uh fire on these Christians but they
never read the Bible
I don't mess with them Jews Jews Jews
just do all they ruin the world never
read the Torah
all these girls in there
star signs and the essence but they
never
took no Hindu books
no Buddhist books
all the books are out there you could
even go on int on the internet on
YouTube and you could get the audio book
of it RAV
don't play with your future RAV
don't let people
um get your your your your your your
extra ticket to the to the whole fire
breath don't do it
it's not pearls where this is my words
I'm saying it when bro I'm only saying
again out of the love for you lot bro
I'm trying to say just like how with the
girl thing when I'm like yo I think you
should be married not because I it
benefits me like that's all I want you
not to know like it's not really
benefiting me
I'm just
giving you a point of view that you
might not have thought about
that's all I'm doing
but yeah bro listen you are the most
amazing brev bro you look my you look my
not
you might not understand but bro you lot
helped me bro I thank you so much bro
bro 700 subscribers
I've got to thank the jpt like bro you
know I love you bro so I'm gonna I'm
just gonna read out you lots comments on
that for the for the love you know
can your brother stream on what is the
purpose of life
um
I'll do a stream on that
I don't know if you would like it
um
Jesus is a prophet not God the man can't
be God oh that's what I believe but you
can't force someone to think what
otherwise
um
you never heard it like that bro that's
how I am sometimes but that's why I told
you subscribe to my channel bro because
I don't just bro like to my detriment
sometimes I'll tell you like the truth
real talks I'll tell you like the truth
to my detriment sometimes
but um
Yeah man so I think Pearl has me around
man I'll be telling the truth too much
um
I go about it from a different approach
I mean
if you the the more you look at things
the and the more places you go trust me
I guarantee you like that's the main
issue I have with people from America
bro that's my main issue with you lot
Eula are the wealthiest country in the
entire world bro you have the most
resources to hand in anywhere else
yeah
if you wanted to you could get a
passport and you could travel bro I beg
you please do that for me go to a
different country and see how they live
and see how the system runs and how it's
different to yours and bro it would open
your mind there's nothing more open mind
opening than going to a different
country bro what do you think Paul like
seeing a different
um like culture in that and how they
live it depends on the culture no but
wouldn't it just be changed like eye
opening if they if you've never seen it
before like how how the rules are
different or how yeah when I went to
India and like Japan it was pretty
eye-opening
you went to India
in Japan I've been like a lot of
countries we grew up traveling
India is one die cut I mean I have no
life experience though
country I've probably been to like 30
plus countries
do you know what cost is
yeah so do you know they still have that
in India right yeah I know I remember
talking to them about it bruh like you
could bro in India you find the richest
man we really have casts when you think
about it too it's just social class it
might not be written but it's like
Unwritten rules like you know what I
mean that's that people judge them for
their caste system but we have the same
thing it's just class they have a cast
system we have a class system you're
right and it's like you know how because
you can marry up or down one and there
most people marry up or down one when it
comes to social class like the same up
or down one and you can't get into
certain places but like based on your
class over here mate that's that's a big
thing bro you can't do for certain
things yeah I mean get away with
anything we feel that right over here
like but what I was gonna say India you
know India has like some of the richest
people and the poorest people in the
world
yeah imagine that in the same country
the richest
crazy because it had these have these
fences people are trying to get in like
that's the most poverty I've ever seen
in my life in India yeah it's about it
gets bad today like everywhere to be
honest I went to dupai I went to
um I went freaking everywhere
hmm
Germany I lived in Italy Amsterdam I got
them literally how you been Germany yeah
well east west east OS
[Music]
um
start which is like North
pole man ESO Wes
North no but obviously Germany was cut
in half in it
so and then I went to
okay one side was for
um Russia and the other side was for the
Europe
after the after the war
I don't know I need to go to bed yeah
I'm so tired I'm sorry I really wanted
to get you to a thousand but I gotta go
to bed
you don't need to stop getting hung up
about this race issue so much bro as
well bro it will free your mind bro
just see people for being good people or
bad people bro forget about what they
look like or what their race is bro
it's annoying bro it's like we're living
in 2023 bro
all right guys I'm falling asleep thank
you for getting him to 700 subscribers
wait what we wait you can't end the
stream like that bro after they just
blessed me with like 500 subscribers
I'm so tired guys guys I'm serious thank
you guys wait hold on hold on this is
how I end my stream okay
this is our ended tell me if you like it
yeah
so you've got three minutes to say your
gas RAV let them know your gas
I'll let you know how I do it I'll give
you an example
jpt
biggest channel in the world
don't hate
appreciate
we affirm ourselves as best
the greatest
subscribe
[Music]
well
they're the biggest in the sea
they're as big as can be whoo they're
bigger than a sale
I'm going off the rails
whales
you could be white
she could be black
[Music]
let's get this black
subscribe
whales
scales
okay
females that dressed as males
subscribe
[Music]
thumbnails
bum Wales
from Wales
good night
all right like the video on your way out